[Musique]
Pierry Corel, Quentin Leot, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Donc
Pierric Aurel, moi je suis agriculteur
dans les Alpes de Haut Provence. Je suis
en agriculture biologique, j'élève des
vaches à l'étente euh en GaEC. Donc
c'est un groupement d'associés
d'exploitation en commun avec mon
cousin, mon père. Euh voilà, on a une
centaine de vaches et puis euh 200
hectares de culture où on produit
essentiellement du blé, du foin et puis
du colza aussi. Voilà, un petit peu de
céréales, tout ça en bio en agriculture
biologique. Je suis installé depuis 2010
et je suis aussi engagé dans le syndicat
jeunes agriculteur et je suis secrétaire
général national de de jeunes
agriculteurs. Puis j'ai gravi mes
échelons aussi petit à petit dans le
syndicat puisqu'on a commencé très
localement cantonal puis départemental
puis régional histoire de se faire ses
les armes et puis pour finir au national
pour essayer de de mener les combats
dans lesquels on croit quand on
s'installe en agriculture.
Quentin le Guillou.
Ouais, Quentin Le Guillou. Donc moi, je
suis installé depuis 2016 euh l'ouest
parisien. Je suis au nord de Laurel
Loir, donc 60 km de Paris en grande
culture uniquement la grande culture.
Donc céréales, colza, blé, orge, maïs,
un peu de poids, féverol, enfin voilà
vraiment tout ce qu'on retrouve dans les
grandes cultures. 2016 je me une
exploitation où j'étais salarié arrivé à
la retraite, mauvaise année, très
mauvaise année en 2016. L'exploitant m'a
dit "Bah je peux plus, j'ai plus rien,
j'ai pas envie de je peux plus
continuer, donc est-ce que tu veux
reprendre ? Est-ce que tu veux
t'installer ?" Donc il m'a accompagné.
Au bout d'un an de démarche
administrative et autres, j'ai réussi à
m'installer et et à reprendre
l'exploitation. Et aujourd'hui, bah j'ai
envie de dire ça fonctionne plus ou
moins. Voilà, j'ai essayé de me lancer
dans un nouveau modèle un peu agricole,
agriculture dite de conservation,
c'est-à-dire j'ai vraiment tout revu
toute la ferme qui était avant labour.
Moi, j'ai tout j'ai tout arrêté, tout en
semidirect, souscouvert, vraiment
diminuer les charges fortes sur sur le
GNR parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est c'est les
charges. Donc voilà, installer comme ça.
Aujourd'hui, bah ça fonctionne marié,
deux enfants chez jeunes agriculteur
aussi. Depuis 2009 dans le syndicat jeun
agriculteur, j'ai commencé par le canton
département, la région et puis
maintenant national depuis 3 ans et
demi, secrétaire général adjoint. Et
puis voilà, comme on dit, bah on est à
fondant, à fond dans le syndicat, à
fondant la défense agricole.
On a décidé de vous recevoir tous les
deux parce que depuis le 8 décembre, on
avait rouillé cette interview. On avait
déjà repéré que les Allemands étaient un
petit peu fâchés et on s'est dit vu que
dans notre village, le panneau était
déjà retourné, on s'est dit on va
contacter les agriculteurs et vous avez
été les premiers à répondre. Donc c'est
pour ça qu'on vous reçoit.
On vous ressort aussi parce que pour
nous les agriculteurs sont la première
ligne de transformation de la calorie
fossile en calories assimilables par
l'homme. Et donc vous êtes exposé à tout
un tas de menaces que ce soit
climatique, géopolitique, énergétique,
de ressources et tout un tas de choses.
Et c'était on était très content de de
recevoir des jeunes agriculteurs qui qui
n'en veulent. Première question avant de
vous charcuter un peu.
Pourquoi vous êtes engagé dans un
syndicat ? Qu'est-ce que vous touchez du
pognon de ce syndicat ?
Alors bon, je je vais me lancer du coup.
Ouais, on alors pourquoi moi je me suis
engagé honnêtement au début ça s'est
fait au travers de de quelque chose de
qui nous fait assez bien tous. C'est la
convivialité. En fait, il y a une petite
réunion de Canton où on m'a dit "Bah
écoute, viens boire une bière puis tu
verras, tu pourras parler de tes
problèmes
avec modération la bière." avec
modération la bière évidemment hein, ça
ça caractérise évidemment les
agriculteurs et donc on est parti on est
parti là-dessus et puis c'est vrai qu'on
a très vite échanger sur les
problématiques notamment à
l'installation et voilà et puis après
euh au bout d'un petit moment on dit "Ah
ça serait peut-être pas mal que tu
montes au département écoute on a besoin
d'un petit coup de main pour filer un
coup de main sur des des des problèmes
de qui sont locaux quoi. Voilà on a un
préfet qui veut pas trop lâcher sur le
curage des faussées ou voilà des trucs
qui me parlaient quoi. Et donc j'ai dit
bon bah ouais, je veux bien prendre un
peu de responsabilité et puis voilà, ça
m'allait bien d'être un peu des fois
véhément aussi et de de de pousser avec
le cri du cœur le voilà ce qui ce qui
m'avait posé problème dans mon parcours
à l'installation et ce qui me semblait
poser problème pour me développer.
Et donc bon ben voilà, au début on
commence comme ça, on met un doigt et
puis l'engrenage est parti et puis on on
se prend assez bien au jeu aussi
finalement de de voilà de défendre le
métier parce que bon moi quand je me
suis installé, c'était avant tout un
choix de vie hein finalement de dire
voilà moi je vais être agriculteur ouais
par contre ça conditionne que bah je
vais peut-être mettre aussi une partie
de ma vie sociale entre parenthèses
malheureusement au début parce que je
vais passer beaucoup d'heures sur mon
tracteur derrière mes vaches et et donc
voilà donc c'est parti comme ça et Puis
je me suis aperçu qu'il y avait d'autres
personnes qui étaient avec moi qui qui
partageaient aussi la même philosophie
de vie et qu'on menait les mêmes
combats. Et donc voilà, on a on a
commencé comme ça et puis après ben j'ai
pris un peu du grade. Voilà, je comme
j'étais celui qui criait des fois un peu
plus fort que les autres, on m'a dit
"Bah tiens, vas-y, commence, passe
devant et puis on te suivra." Puis on
finit président de département et puis
comme on continue à crier toujours un
peu plus fort que les autres, on finit
président de région et puis voilà, ça se
fait comme ça. En même temps, on
développe sa son exploitation. On a
aussi des expériences de vie.
et euh et voilà qui nous apprennent
aussi d'autres choses et on se rend
compte queil y a pas complètement que le
travail et que il y a aussi voilà des
interactions sociales qui nous ouvrent
un peu l'esprit et puis pour le coup
jeune agriculteur le syndicat ben ça
nous ouvre l'esprit parce que bah au
départ c'est des copains et puis on
s'aperçoit qu'autour il y a pas que des
gens qui sont que des amis et quand on
commence à discuter avec voilà des
personnalités politiques ou autres ou
quoi, on s'aperçoit que bah là c'est un
panier de crabe quoi. et qu'il va
falloir naviguer au milieu de tout ça et
que va falloir apprendre très vite. Et
pour le coup, J ça nous aide beaucoup en
tout cas, moi ça m'a aidé beaucoup.
Et puis voilà, on finit au national et
alors tant qu'on est euh
département, région et même au national,
on a pour revenir sur la question du
financement comme ça on l'évacue tout de
suite, mais on a des des remboursements,
des frais kilométriques. Voilà, ça varie
en fonction des départements. Euh voilà,
c'est c'est laissé libre à chaque
département un jeune agriculteur de
d'indemniser au tarif qu'il veut. Et
puis après, on a des indemnités
journalières. Euh voilà, moi à titre
personnel, j'ai une indemnité
journalière de 100 € en tant que
secrétaire général de jeunes
agriculteurs. 100 € par jour que je
passe pour défendre le métier
d'agriculteur. Voilà. Donc moi, ça me
paye un salarié sur mon exploitation
parce que quand je suis à Paris
évidemment, je suis ou en déplacement,
je suis pas sur mon exploitation et donc
ça me permet de rémunérer. Bon bah là en
l'occurrence une apprentiation
qui qui j'espère fera d'une pierre de
coup, je motiverai. Voilà.
Passer un coucou. Oui. Salut Ambre si tu
regardes, voilà. Dédicace à Ambre.
On va te venger Ambre, t'inquiète.
Quin et ben Pierric a quasiment tout dit
en fait. Jeune agriculteur. Moi j'étais
sorti d'études, fraîchement diplômé.
Quel type d'étude ? Combien de temps
d'étude ?
Alors euh j'ai jamais aimé l'école.
L'école m'a pas trop aimé. En 4e.
Faut pas que tu formules ça comme ça. Il
faut que tu dises que tu n'étais pas
adapté au système éducatif.
Ouais, on va dire ça comme ça. Bon. Moi
et moi moi et l'école ça fonctionnait
pas. Voilà, on arrivait pas à apprendre.
J'étais au collège dans un collège
public. Arrivé en 4e, on m'a dit "Bon
bah c'est soit tu t'en vas, soit tu tu
penses à redoubler." et je me suis
rapproché d'une école agricole MFR,
maison familiale rurale. C'est des
écoles qui sont euh des écoles privées
agricoles pour pour les 3/4 euh où
dedans il y a une partie de stage ou
d'apprentissage. Et euh et moi c'est ça
qui m'a plu en fait quand je suis allé
voir l'école, on m'a dit "Tu vas avoir
17 semaines de cours, une semaine à
l'école, une semaine en entreprise. Que
du bonheur." Donc moi, j'étais
stagiaire. J'étais stagiaire à l'époque
donc sans sans forcément de rémunération
hein, mais mais le fait de pouvoir se
dire "On va aller on va sortir, on va
aller sur le terrain, on va aller dans
des fermes et on va pouvoir aller voir
des fermes, aller travailler sur des
fermes, ça c'est vraiment en fait bah
moi c'était un élan, ça m'a donné envie.
Donc 3isème j'ai commencé, j'ai fait
ensuite 2 années de BEP en production
végétale et ensuite un bac pro sur 2
ans, conduite gestion d'exploitation
agricole. pareil, une semaine d'école,
une semaine de stage et à chaque fois en
changeant euh en changeant de stage, en
changeant de secteur, je travaillais euh
dans un élevage de chèvre, j'ai
travaillé euh dans une exploitation pour
mon BEP en grande culture, une petite
exploitation 200 hactares grande culture
et puis j'ai fini sur mon année de bac
une exploitation grande culture et qui
avait de l'élevage aussi volaille off.
Donc j'ai pu voir un petit peu bah ce
qui se faisait par chez moi, les
différents types d'agriculture. Une
agriculture peut-être un peu plus
raisonnée, une agriculture un peu plus
forte, une agriculture un peu plus sur
vers le bio, enfin voilà vraiment puis
une notion d'élevage. Et euh un jour, un
voisin qui m'appelle qui me dit "Bah
tiens, il y a une fête sur le
département, sur le canton, sur la
commune à côté. Nous c'est festival de
la terre que ça s'appelle. Euh donc
c'est une fête agricole où tous les ans
ça se réunit, concours de labour, les
courses de alors nous on a plus de moi
se bat, c'est tracteur tondeuse donc
course de tracteur tondeuse et puis bah
on étale ancien matériel, différents
concours, présentation vraiment de
l'agriculture locale aux gens. Euh je
suis venu euh j'ai euh rencontré euh bah
des agriculteurs voisins. Euh je leur ai
demandé est-ce que je pouvais me rendre
utile pour pour essayer de d'aider un
petit peu. Donc j'étais à gauche à
droite piquer le concours de labour,
servir des bières, enfin voilà vraiment
la base. Et puis euh bah on passe une
bonne journée puis le lendemain, on nous
dit bah tiens, on organise une réunion
où on va débriefer un peu tout ça et
puis peut-être s'organiser un petit
voyage avec l'école qu'on a avec
l'argent qu'on a récolté. Voilà, on a on
a gagné 2 3000 € ça vous dit ? On paye
un petit peu un truc et puis bah voilà,
c'est parti. On a mis le pied dedans et
puis comme a dit Pierric, bah d'un coup,
il y en a un qui ouvre un petit peu plus
sa gueule que les autres. On lui dit
"Bah tiens, il y a des places au
département, ça te dit de monter des
chelons et puis bah voilà, département,
région euh et puis bah région, j'étais
bien mais je me suis dit bah le boulot
maintenant, il faut aussi le monter
parce que au département, c'est ce que
disait Pierric, on a les problèmes
vraiment qui sont locals. On rencontre
son député, on rencontre préfet, les
présidents com de d'Aglo, discute un peu
sur tous les problèmes qu'il y a mais on
voit qu'il y a toujours des problèmes
au-dessus et on essaie d'aller les
comment dire les les débloquer de de
d'essayer de trouver des solutions sur
tout ça. On a des idées, on essaie de
les apporter et on se retrouve bah
arrivé au national. Moi je suis dans un
échelon juste en dessous. Moi je suis
c'est mon chef, c'est secrétaire
général. Moi je suis adjoint. Donc moi,
c'est 80 € d'anemnité journalière sur
quand je suis ici euh à JA euh et que ou
que je que je passe mon temps aussi sur
J parce que maintenant que je suis au
national, on je voyage aussi un petit
peu dans la France bah pour aller amener
la parole J, amener ce qu'on fait et
essayer aussi sur le terrain de de
d'écouter. Donc bah on se promène un
petit peu partout. Euh voilà. Bah moi ça
me ça me permet j'ai un un salarié en
groupement d'employeurs. En fait, c'est
un groupement qui a été créé sur trois
exploitations où on se partage un
salarié. Donc moi, bah l'indemnité me
part me paye en partie aussi une partie
bah euh du salarié euh et puis bah me
ramener ramène aussi sur mon temps en
fait tout le temps que je suis ici euh
en ce moment je suis à peu près 2 tr
jours semaine sur Paris euh où à voyager
un petit peu en région. Donc voilà,
c'est c'est quand même du temps qu'on n
pas sur les exploitations. On fait des
erreurs sur nos fermes quand on n pas
quand on n pas quand on n'est pas là.
Bien sûr, moi ça m'est arrivé mes
premières années sur sur Paris de me
dire "C'est bon, tout roule et puis
après un mois de septembre complet sur
Paris, on rentre fin septembre et ah
waouh ! Les cultures elles ont pas
survécu, il y a des choses, il y a eu
des attaques, il y a eu des des des
insectes qui qui ont tout détruit et là
bah c'est un manque à gagner direct.
Donc on se repose, on se remet un peu en
question, on discute et puis après bah
il y a toute la vie sociale à côté,
l'épouse, les parents, voir est-ce queon
peut essayer de gérer une entraide les
enfants. Je suis papa de de petit donc
on a envie de les voir aussi donc on
essaie de rentrer le plus possible. Moi
j'ai l'avantage d'être à 60 km. Voilà,
c'est un gros avantage que j'ai par
rapport à Pierriic qui doit lui
traverser toute la France. Donc bah je
me suis payé les petits scooters et puis
maintenant je fais mes allers-retours
ici en scooter pour pouvoir essayer de
de passer un maximum de temps avec la
famille parce que aujourd'hui c'est
c'est ce qu'il y a c'est ce qui nous
tient fort aujourd'hui comme on est.
Première question, vos taux
d'endettement,
est-ce que vous avez un crédit ? Est-ce
que vous avez été obligé de sortir du
pognon ? Vous en avez encore pour
combien de siècles à rembourser ? vous
êtes pas obligé de répondre
et essayer de tirer ce sujet concernant
les autres agriculteurs.
Alors moi je me suis installé hors cade
familial, c'est-à-dire que j'ai pas
repris l'exploitation de mes parents. Ma
mère était agricultrice et toujours
agricultrice, mon père était dans un
autre domaine. Il est dans le git. Il a
rejoint le GEC d'ailleurs en 2019. Donc
c'est un cursus un peu inverse de
d'habitude. C'est les gamins qui
reprennent les exploitations des
parents. Moi, j'ai installé mon père et
je me suis installé en cas familial.
Donc je suis parti avec un compte à la
poste, j'avais 19 € quand je suis
débarqué à la Banque Populaire. J'aurais
dit "Écoutez, voilà, moi j'ai pas le
permis de conduire, je vais faire
agriculteur parce que j'étais j'avais 19
ans, je l'avais raté. Enfin bon, bref,
voilà, le mec sérieux hein, qui présente
bien et tout, voilà, j'arrive avec mon
petit dossier et voilà, je vais faire
agriculteur, j'ai besoin de 150000
balles pour m'installer. Je vais acheter
un tracteur et 4 hectares de terre et un
peu de cheptel et tout. Et j'ai proposé
ça à deux banques hein et Crédit
Agricole, Banque Populaire. Banque
populaire m'a suivi, c'est des acteurs
historiques du monde agricole. Et et
donc ils m'ont suivi, la Banque
Populaire m'a suivi et donc là il a
fallu rentrer dans ce qu'on appelle le
professionnalisme quoi. Parce qu'il faut
rembourser, on rigole plus, on joue plus
avec les tracteurs dans le sable et
c'est plus pour rire quoi. Et donc
petite transition parce que c'est un
rêve, je le dis, c'est voilà, c'est un
projet de vie puis là c'est un projet
financier. Donc on est parti, je suis
parti tout seul donc 150000 € puis j'ai
remboursé puis ça se passe bien. On a
des aides à l'installation, la fameuse
dotation jeune agriculteur 36500 € moi à
l'époque que je touche voilà que je
conserve de côté pour pouvoir m'assurer
un peu de revenu histoire de de quoi
vivre. À l'époque je suis en couple avec
mon ex-épouse et voilà, on a un projet
d'enfant donc bon il faut un minimum
assurer le le le revenu quoi. Puis bon
je un peu de fierté quand même peut-être
déplacer mais vouloir assumer le le
foyer familial. Donc on part là-dessus,
je pars là-dessus et je rembourse. Et
puis petit à petit, ça fait son chemin.
Euh ça fait son chemin. Et aujourd'hui,
voilà, je continue donc je rembourse mon
premier tracteur, mes premiers prêts
puis je continue puis je voilà, je je
continue à acheter un peu de matériel,
un peu de terre, un peu de cheptel, un
peu de c, un peu de là et euh ça se
développe, ça marche plutôt bien.
Aujourd'hui concrètement je
j'ai alors on a acheté une exploitation
en 2020 dans le centre de la France en
Sonir pour 600000 €.
J'ai réinvesti sur mon exploitation
entre-temps.
J'ai j'ai j'ai honnêtement, j'ai plus
tous les chiffres en tête mais
6 700000 € sans problème. Donc je suis à
1 million 15ion5 d'investissement
aujourd'hui. J'ai un projet, on a un
projet de de bâtiment photovoltaque sur
l'exploitation où il va falloir remettre
4 500000 €. On arrive à rembourser.
Enfin, j'arrive à rembourser, la banque
me suit maintenant. Voilà, il y a pas il
y a plus de problème avec ça. Mais
je la la question de l'endettement en
fait, elle a elle a elle a très vite été
moi enfin moi je me suis dit bon ben
j'ai pas de pognon, j'ai j'ai juste mon
mon courage, mon envie, il va falloir
que j'y aille. Ma production certes
c'est compliqué, certes c'est là, mais
apparemment dans la société si on y
croit, on investit et qu'on bosse, on
arrive à des résultats. Ouais. Voilà,
j'y vais et bon ben voilà, j'arrive à
rembourser aujourd'hui. Ça ça ça ça se
passe bien. J'ai fait des choix
d'entreprise qui me qui font que je me
tire pas un gros a honnêtement. Je me
prends 1000 balles par mois sur
l'exploitation.
Après, pour être honnête, mon
exploitation, je veux dire, c'est mon
assurance de bagnole, elle est sur
l'exploitation. Partie du gazo
exploitation. L'électricité c'est enfin
c'est pas de l'argent de poche mais je
veux dire voilà c'est c'est pas à mettre
en enfin c'est à mettre en perspective
avec un salaire de de de smicar aussi ou
quoi que même s'il faut dmircardiser la
France. Voilà. Bon bref donc voilà moi
je j'estime vivre bien. Je veux dire
j'ai construit ma baraque. Je veux dire
j'ai j'ai remis
Ta femme travaille ?
Ouais ma femme travaille. Alors
paradoxe de la chose elle est
conseillère agricole à la banque
populaire depuis peu. Donc à croire
signer crédit non. Non, elle a pas le
droit. J'ai dû changer d'agence parce
que il y avait conflit d'intérêt. Donc
euh donc non mais
très très bonne réponse.
Oui. Mais du coup euh du coup voilà mais
pour dire que finalement ça fonctionne.
Bon et par contre c'est beaucoup
d'investissement euh euh moral aussi
quoi, de se dire il faut y aller et
voilà.
Moi de mon côté du coup 2016 bon dans la
présentation je pas tout dit, j'ai mon
père qui est agriculteur quand même sur
une exploitation à côté. Donc moi, fils
d' combi de temps,
euh mon père, il est agriculteur depuis
84,
il a 65 ans, il a encore pour 2 ans. Euh
il aurait pu arrêter il y a un an ou
deux mais euh l'amour du métier continue
en fait. C'est ça la combien sa pension
de retraite ? Ah euh on en a discuté
justement ce weekend parce que on a
essayé de tout ressortir un petit peu.
Euh il devrait tourner autour des 100
1500 € à peu près de retraite. Euh et on
va dire qu'il est très bien l'ti parce
que il a eu des bonnes années parce que
il a cotisé ta plein sur la MSA là. Nous
la MSA c'est mutualité sociale et
agricole chez qui on cotise comme les
artisans à l'ursaf ou autres. Voilà nous
c'est la MSA. Donc il a vraiment bien
cotisé des années. Il a eu des très
bonnes années dans les années 2000. Donc
il voilà, il est sur un 100005.
Aujourd'hui, c'est pas majorité des
exploitants agricoles qui après 40 ans
de carrière ont sorti à 1500 €.
C'est c'est combien la moyenne en ce
moment ?
Ah bah si on espère que on espère avoir
au moins des agriculteurs qui vont
toucher plus de 1000 €. Maintenant euh
on en a qui vont pas enfin
voilà il y en a qui sont à 600 6 800
balles hein
actuellement c'est dur hein pour enfin
euh des des personnes qui ont quand même
tri sur leurs exploitations hein et je
dis bien tri parce que moi je me suis
installé il y a du matériel mais on
prend des personnes qui ont aujourd'hui
75 80 ans qui ont connu tout à la main
avec le matériel qui est arrivé de
l'endettement sur des premiers tracteurs
nouveaux en tout technologie qu'on a pu
connaître qui est arrivé au fur et à
mesure dans les années 70 80 et
aujourd'hui sont arrivés au bout du bout
et vont sortir 6 700 € aussi
avec une exploitation déjà payée.
Oui, avec une exploitation payée mais
qu'ils ont légué derrière. Alors certes,
ils l'ont revendu un montant, certes,
ils ont eu un montant au moment de la
session d'exploitation, mais j'espère
pour eux qu'ils ont eu des très bons
placements parce qu'en fait aujourd'hui
avec 6 700 € il y a pas grand monde qui
peut vivre aujourd'hui comme ça.
On appelle ça survivre.
Ben c'est survivre totalement. C'est une
survie. Bon, mon père toujours toujours
en en exploitation. Moi, je me suis
installé donc 2016 très mauvaise année
chez nous à gros alléa climatique, donc
une grosse pluie sur joint, les cultures
catastrophe. Mon père me dit "Bon bah
c'est super, tu reprends l'exploitation
du du voisin, chez qui tu es tu es
salarié. Sache que moi, je vais pas
pouvoir t'aider financièrement. Je vais
pouvoir t'aider éventuellement. J'ai du
matériel, on va je vais te prêter un peu
de matériel, tu vas reprendre du
matériel aussi sur l'exploitation, mais
je vais pas pouvoir t'aider
financièrement. Donc moi, j'avais un peu
plus de 19 €. J'avais mon livret jeune
qui venait tout juste de finir. J'en
avais 26 ans. Donc la banque m'avait dit
"Ah, il faut ouvrir un autre compte. Euh
1500 € en poche, je vais voir la banque
et je dis il me faut 600000 €." Et là
600000 € il me fait "OK, ça marche, pas
de problème, bah tu nous sors un PE,
donc un plan économique,
un petit rein déjà, on pose tout. J'ai
tout peaufiné, je suis allé voir donc le
sédent chez qui lui il a arrêté et je
lui dis bon bah donne-moi tes
rendements, donne-moi ta comptabilité,
donne-moi tout ce que tu peux et je vais
essayer de tout travailler, les
cultures, qu'est-ce que je peux faire ?
Où est-ce que je peux aller tirer un peu
d'argent, essayer ? et et la banque nous
dit "Bon bah, il faut nous sortir un
plan économique sur 5 7 ans." Donc avec
une vision sur 5 7 ans qui est
aujourd'hui intenable he parce que sur 5
7 ans bah on l'a vu, on a eu le Covid,
on a eu l'Ukraine. Donc je plains les
jeunes qui sont installés sur 2020 21
c'est c'est intenable. Donc moi 2016,
j'arrive avec mon plan économique et ils
me disent "OK, pas de problème, tu vas
nous rembourser 58000 € par an,
on te prête de l'argent." Bon bah je dis
"OK, c'est parti." Ils me disent "Quel
objectif que vous souhaitez vous tirer
?" Bah je vais essayer de me prendre
1000 €. D'accord. A c'est un peu serré.
Bon bon bon. Donc ils m'ont accompagné,
je suis allé prendre l'ACRE création
d'entreprise euh donc qui donne la
moitié du chômage qu'on pourra avoir.
Enfin bon bref et cetera. Donc j'ai pu
récupérer un un peu d'aide je crois qu'à
l'époque 11 ou 12000 € que j'ai pu
récupérer sur l'ACre. La DJA. Donc moi,
j'étais dotation jeune agriculteur. On
était sur une nouvelle DJA par rapport à
toi. Donc moi, je suis allé chercher
11000 € d'aide à l'installation
que j'ai mis sur un compte que j'ai
gardé pendant 4 ans parce que je me suis
dit un jour il on sait jamais, il y
avait tellement de à l'époque en fait à
l'époque au moment où j'ai eu la DJA, il
fallait respecter des critères, il
fallait que
le le résultat bénéfice net de
l'exploitation soit un supérieur à un
SMIC et inférieur à trois SMIC. Je me
suis dit si je touche pas assez d'arg,
si je crée pas assez d'argent et que je
suis inférieur à un SMIC, catastrophe.
Ça veut dire que mon exploitation est
pas rentable et en plus il faut que je
rembourse les 11000 € et résitale
au-dessus. Si elle sort trois SMIC, bon
bah tant mieux. Ça veut dire que
l'exploitation fonctionne bien donc
faudra que je les rendre aussi. Donc je
les ai mis de côté et je me suis dit
pendant 4 5 ans, je vais les garder
parce que je suis pas à la brique quoi
que ce soit. Heureusement pour moi, j'ai
fait une moyenne, je crois à 2 22, je
crois SMIC sur les sur mes 5 années
d'installation. Tant mieux. Ça ça a très
bien fonctionné. Quand on dit 22 de SMIC
2,2, c'est pas ce que je prends. En
fait, on a notre chiffre net avant
impôt. Donc derrière, on retire les
impôts qui est qui qui vient nous en
prendre une bonne partie. Et puis bah on
a les petits coups durs, on sait jamais,
un tracteur, un moteur, un moteur c'est
10 15000 € donc on va pas tout chercher.
Aujourd'hui, moi je je me prends 1500 €
par mois sur l'exploitation. Mon épouse
euh est salariée à mi-temps sur une
entreprise et l'autre mi-temps, je l'ai
embauché là depuis 6 mois euh parce
qu'on a créé des pâtes. On on fait des
pâtes sur la ferme. Des pâtes, ouais.
des pâtes à manger, des pâtes sèches.
Voilà, on a je fais une culture de
bléure bléure pour faire les pâtes. Donc
je
Notre Dame Dandisait ça des pâtes super
bonnes.
Ouais. Bah moi je suis en pâte
semi-omlète donc en fait le je prends
mon blé
un moulin à côté une minoterie. Je lui
emmène mon blé, il me l'écrase et il le
passe deux fois. En fait au début la
première fois on l'a écrasé complet. On
a mélangé avec de l'eau. On a fait des
pâtes. C'était des pâtes complètes.
C'était imangeable. Personne voulait en
manger. Nos parents nous ont dit "Mais
comment vous allez vendre ça ?
imangeable, c'était pas très marron,
très foncé, très forte. Donc on a
refaire passé une deuxième fois,
réécrasé une deuxième fois et du coup on
est arrivé sur des pâtes semi-complètes
et ça a très bien fonctionné. On avait
commencé moi tout seul 201920 période
Covid c'était les gens ils faisaient le
petit papier uniquement pour venir nous
acheter des pâtes. C'était ça cartonné.
remplis toutes les normes pour pouvoir
faire des pattes.
Je sais pas s'il y a des normes pour
Euh étant donné que
on reparlera on reparlera de problèmes
de norme, on va parler d'économie, on va
parler d'intelligence économique en en
agriculture, je mets pas d'œuf dans mes
pattes. En fait, si demain je mets un
œuf dans mes pattes, alors là je touche
des choses vraiment invraisemblables
parce qu'en fait là, il y a une sécurité
hygiène bien plus élevée que si j'en
mets pas. Moi aujourd'hui, j'ai un j'ai
un labo donc en fait tout blanc, carlé,
voilà en fait tout propre.
Qui a payé le labo ?
Moi.
Moi donc bah je j'en ai repris un petit
un petit en plus donc machine à pâte
séchoir pour sécher les pâtes parce
qu'en fait comment sont fait les pâtes ?
C'est de la farine farine et de l'eau.
On crée les pâtes derrière je les mets
dans un séchoir. Ça tourne.
Combien tu vends ça le kilo ? Euh le
kilo, là je suis à euh je veux pas dire
de bêtises euh 357 7 € le kilo 350
direct producteur.
Direct producteur
avec un emballage qui ressemble à un
vra.
Je suis un emballage carton. Je on s'est
dit euh aujourd'hui alimentaire
contact alimentaire bien sûr hein. Bah
je toute la mon emballage me coûte 80
centimes la boîte. 80 centimes la boîte.
Je vends ma boîte avec les pattes dedans
3,50 € sur 80 centimes de boîte seul.
Euh en plus bah faut retirer une grosse
part d'électricité parce que bah mon
séchoir euh voilà donc là il m'en coûte
un petit peu. Ma matière première, mon
blé. Mais en fait mon blé lui qui
représente euh bah le blé dur euh 400 €
la tonne. Donc euh on fait vite la
division, on est à 40 centimes du kilo,
donc sur 500 g de pâte 20 centimes. Donc
sur mes 3,50 € j'ai que 20 centimes de
de farine dedans de blé qui me coûte
vraiment. Mais en fait, j'ai tout mon
coût à côté. Mes machines qu'il faut
payer, mes remboursements,
l'électricité, une part de l'eau, le
salarié de mon le salaire de mon épouse
aujourd'hui. Et aujourd'hui,
malheureusement suite Ukraine euh bah
les gens, il y a plus de revenu nulle
part.
Alors, on voulait parler tout voulait
parler tout de suite, tu as fini ou pas
?
Vas-y.
Non, dis-moi.
Non, mais en fait en fait ce que tu vois
tu vois sur le côté sur le côté des
patttes pour pour finir, ça a très bien
fonctionné Covid. Là aujourd'hui, je
suis en train de me poser la question
d'arrêter. Euh pourquoi ? Parce qu'en
fait, on sortait 4 5 tonnes de pâtes à
l'année. Là, je vais faire très
difficile de ton 5 de pâtes.
Mais je comprends les gens, mais c'est
normal. Moi aussi, j'ai travaillé avec
des GMS. Les GMS pour le coup GMS, les
grandes surfaces, Terre Marché, Leclerc,
Auchamp, peu importe. Je suis allé les
voir, eux, ils étaient contents, ça
redonné une belle image. Ils m'ont ils
m'ont pas négocié les prix pour le coup.
C'est pour ça, moi ils m'ont pas négocié
les prix parce que c'était du direct.
Moi directement, je leur vendais, ils
m'ont pas négocié les prix. Ils ont
pris, ils ont mis en rayon, très bien,
super. Ils ont pris une petite marche
dessus. Moi, je leur vendais 2,80 € la
boîte. Prix pris de prix de vente pour
eux. Ensuite, derrière, il margeaient
dessus. Donc là, en ce moment, ils sont
à 3,80 3,90 la boîte chez eux. Euh donc
ils prennent leur part de marge. Sauf
que quand il y a ma boîte à 3,80 € 500 g
et qu'en dessous bah en ce moment on a 1
ou 2 € le kilo le kilo de pâte en grande
marque lustucru panzani ou autres de
marque. Bon et ou allez on va dire les
marques
européens
marques européennes. Ouais les marques
européennes. Les grandes marques, les
grandes marques distributeur et cetera.
Euh ben moi je suis je suis en face la
concurrence, je peux pas je peux pas
suivre je peux pas suivre. Donc quand il
quand ils me disent baisse tes prix bah
moi en fait j'ai un remboursem j'ai à
rembourser derrière j'ai à tout payer
donc non je peux pas descendre. Donc en
fait aujourd'hui nous ça se dégringole
et là aujourd'hui on se pose la question
de continuer vraiment ça parce que bah
on arrive au bout du truc quoi.
J'ai entendu plein de choses dans votre
présentation.
Le coût de production, l'énergie,
l'électricité.
On n pas parlé de bouclier tarifaire,
j'ai entendu Ukraine, j'ai entendu
concurrence peut-être ou même pas
concurrence déloyal, pas encore.
Encore qui prend le sujet géopolitique,
qui va prendre le sujet guerre
économique ? Est-ce que la première
question que je vais vous poser, c'est
vous en tant que syndicat, vous êtes
plus proche de la FNSEA, vous êtes
FNSEA, vous êtes jeunes agriculteurs,
vous êtes jeunes agriculteurs avec
d'autres syndicats, vous êtes que tout
seul vous. Vous,
on va on va mettre ça tout de suite au
propre, au clair pour tout le monde.
FNSA, c'est un syndicat, jeune
agriculteur, c'est un syndicat. Pour le
coup, on partage quelques positions et
quelques accointances avec la FNSA. On
fait liste commune pour les élections
chambre d'agriculture, ce qui est le
bras technique du syndicalisme sur le
territoire des Voilà. Donc, on est plus
ou moins OK avec les on est plutôt OK
avec la FNSEA. Ceci dit, euh nos
adhérents sont pas constituées de tout à
fait les mêmes agriculteurs. Nous, on a
des nouveaux agriculteurs qui arrivent
dans le dans le milieu chez jeunes
agriculteurs qui adhèrent au syndicat.
La FNSA est plus sur une position mais
parce que c'est l'essence même de leurs
adhérents conservatrices en fait. Et
donc des fois ça diffère un peu mais
c'est la ligne politique globale qu'on
partage aujourd'hui. On la partage. Vous
entendez qu'est-ce que tu entends par
ligne politique ? c'est politique en
terme de protéger les intérêts des
agriculteurs ou une ligne politique
politique c'està-dire gauche droite
extrême droite extrême gauche on est à
politique en tout cas on se revendique
comme à politique chez jeunes
agriculteur la FNSA aussi quand je dis
ligne politique c'est la vision en
agriculture où on dit bon b il faut
quand même un minimum de production faut
quand même un minimum de de protection
des agriculteurs sur le territoire parce
que voilà on n'est pas dans dans enfin
on veut pas le business à tout va
partout et voilà donc c'est en ça qu'on
se rapproche aussi de de la ligne
politique qu'on défend avec la FNS.
Ton bras droit, il confirme ?
Ouais, totalement. Totalement.
Aujourd'hui, pas de politique chez J. J
et enfin, on peut même regarder d'un
autre œil là, FNSEA ou quoi que ce soit.
FNSEA, c'est pareil. Il y a aucune
politique que ça soit un gouvernement de
droite, de gauche, de Après, il y a
toujours des des discussions plus
ouvertes avec certains, ça c'est clair.
Voilà. Il y a pas parce que on en a qui
veulent pas soit nous voir, d'autres au
contraire qui essayent plutôt de venir
nous caresser pour nous dire "Venez me
voir." Non, nous on essaie vraiment de
de de fonctionner le plus droit
possible. Euh l'idée c'est vraiment la
défense agricole. Voilà, il y a euh il y
a des textes de loi qui tombent, il y a
des normes supplémentaires, il y a
l'Ukraine, parler de géopolitique,
clairement aujourd'hui une concurrence
déloyale où
on on va on va on va y rebondir.
On y reviendra mais voilà la
confédération paysane, vous entrenez des
rapports avec eux ? Pas du tout. avec la
Confédération paysane, on a on a des
échanges, on a des discussions. On
essaie chez JA, on essaie un petit peu
plus d'ouvrir des fois un petit peu le
débat. Malheureusement, des fois il y a
des choses qui se font en face que on
peut pas tolérer. Je vais
et ben je vais parler les bassines, je
vais parler Saint-Soline dès qu'il y a
de la dégradation, Confédération
paysane.
C'est peut-être pas eux.
Non, c'est pas eux mais
mais ça se sont fait voler les drapeaux.
Alors il voilà, on a vu des drapeaux
confédération paysane. Ils ont soutenu,
ils ont poussé, ils sont sur une ligne
de conduite qui est beaucoup plus
radical en terme de d'agriculture.
Ils souffrent peut-être plus,
je sais pas. Je enfin je sais pas si
c'est vraiment de la souffrance. C'est
c'est un j'ai pas envie de dire modèle,
mais bon, allez, c'est un modèle
agricole différent où eux ils vont
peut-être plus prener le bio et pas
encore et pas que à 100 %. euh mais un
modèle plutôt très familial, petites
exploitations euh où ils vont pouvoir
essayer d'embaucher un maximum et
cetera, il y a pas de problème. Moi
quand je ferme les yeux, j'ai envie d'y
croire, c'est super. Sauf
qu'aujourd'hui, malheureusement
ça ça manque ça manque clairement de
revenu. Moi, je veux bien demain euh
dans dans le plus beau du du monde. J'ai
184 184 hectares, me dire je vais
diviser ma ferme en 18, tout le monde 10
hectares, on embauche à plein, on fait
tout à la main. Sauf que c'est pas c'est
pas possible. Qui c'est qui va payer
derrière ? Quel revenu on va pouvoir
sortir sur tout ça ? Même si on vendait
mieux nos produits. Enfin, on peut
parler du bio. Le bio aujourd'hui vit
une grosse crise quand même sur le bio
ou moins par les côtés grande culture où
en grande culture le prix des céréales
bio est vendu le même prix voire
peut-être 10 € de plus que du
conventionnel. Alors les mêmes
rendements,
les rendements sont divisés par de gér
Voilà, en terme de charge pour pour moi
en grande culture, mes voisins bio
charge de carburant hein, GNR, c'est
plusieurs passages pour essayer
d'éliminer les mauvaises herbes. Des
rendements en moindre, il y a pas de il
y a un peu de fumier, un peu de lisier
qui sont qui sont mis dessus mais ça
manque. Enfin voilà, donc il y a un
manque sur tout ça et puis à la
finalité, ils ont plus de charge et puis
ils vont vendre 10 € plus cher que
conventionnel ou alors même on va lui
dire bah non, on n pas trouvé le
débouché donc je te mélange au
conventionnel. Donc euh non, la filière
bio aujourd'hui vit une grosse crise.
Donc quand on voit la Confédération
paysane, au contraire, on est là plutôt
de leur dire ouvrez-vous, venez plutôt
euh vous vous battre aujourd'hui pour
tous les agriculteurs qui existent
aujourd'hui. Peu importe en fait que ça
soit tel modèle ou comme si ou comme ça.
En fait aujourd'hui c'est tout le monde
qui est dans le même panier. Il faut
reprendre un petit peu les reines là et
et et puis essayer de s'entraider, de
s'accompagner et trouver la solution
ensemble euh demain pour pour amener et
ramener un peu de revenu sur sur les
fermes agricoles.
Alors avant qu'on commence l'interview,
on a discuté un petit peu.
Vous m'aviez dit que vous m'avez dit que
vous aviez regardé Jean-Marc Jeankovici.
C'est quelqu'un qui qui a quand même des
des points de vue assés sur la
production, la mécanisation et les
répercussion de l'augmentation du coût
énergétique sur vous-même. D'ailleurs,
au départ, je parle sous votre contrôle,
mais au tout départ de l'agriculture, un
agriculteur, il nourrissait
lui et 0,5 ou voire une ou deux
personnes maximum derrière. La
mécanisation est arrivée et là ça a
permis de nourrir plus de personnes. Le
nombre d'agriculteurs en France se
réduit comme pot de chagrin. Il y a des
il y a des questions de suicide, des
questions de surendettement, des gars
qu'en peuvent plus. On va aborder aussi
ce type de sujet sur la question guerre
économique.
Vous êtes un syndicat jeune, beau et
dynamique les gars.
Derrière, est-ce que vous faites de la
prospective ? Certes, vous avez
peut-être des climatologues qui vont
nous expliquer qu'il y a un orage de grê
qui va arriver. Il y a peut-être les
viticulteurs qui sont connectés
directement avec les satellites météo,
avec les météorologues pour savoir si ça
va geler. Ils vont peut-être mettre des
lanternes, voir même faire voler des
hélicoptères au-dessus de leur parcell
pour éviter que ça gèle.
En terme de prospective
guerre économique, est-ce que vous êtes
comme le petit dindon qui va à
l'abattoir ? C'est-à-dire, vous avez un
prisme de lecture qui n'est pas éclairé,
personne vous conseille. Si vous aviez
fait de la veille sur la guerre avec les
Russes, les Ukrainiens, vous si vous
aviez regardé Syerview à partir de 2016,
vous auriez peut-être pris des mesures
proactives pour éviter de vous retrouver
en short avec l'augmentation du coût des
intrans, des engrais, le coût de
l'électricité, le coût de tout ça.
Est-ce que vous en tant que syndicat ou
est-ce que vous avez déjà entendu autour
de vous, mis à part les banquiers qui
font de la spéculation sur certaines dé
alimentaires, est-ce qu'il y a des gens
de l'État qui vous filent des infos un
petit peu comme le phare dans la nuit
pour éviter de vous faire dzinguer par
manque de prisme de lecture, par manque
de visibilité sur des éléments
extérieurs qui vont vous impacter
grandement où c'est vous voyez vous vous
êtes le capitaine
Vous supportez le capitaine de pédalo
qui navigue à vue et qui fait de temps
en temps un petit coup de corne de brume
pour essayer de savoir s'il va pas se
prendre un rocher.
Ouais, en fait c'est ça. On est seul. On
est seul. Je veux dire le capitaine il
est pas là. En fait, c'est ça qu'on a
cri le cri du cœur là qu'on a fait il y
a quelques temps. En fait, c'est c'est
le c'est ça c'est il est où le
capitaine. Ouais. Non mais enfin en fait
c'est ça c'est il est où le capitaine ?
Il y a pas de vision. On voit qu'on va
dans le mur parce que bon enfin je veux
dire on garde les infos, on regarde ce
qui se passe autour de nous. On voit que
enfin la guerre économique, elle est là.
La guerre géopolitique de
l'alimentation, elle est plus que là. Et
en fait, on se dit on est tout seul. On
est tout seul et on est
Tu es tout seul, c'est continue de faire
ton ton champ, on va te filer un peu de
subvention et de pack et puis surtout tu
nous emmerdes pas avec ton tracteur,
avec tes conneries.
Ouais. Voilà. Parce que nous, on a des
vrais enjeux de de bonhomme qui sont les
enjeux électoraux. Sauf que nous, on dit
en face, on a des enjeux de de de
souveraineté alimentaire. On a des
enjeux parce qu'on tient la
géopolitique, que vous le vouliez ou
non, que vous restiez au gouvernement ou
non, de toute façon, c'est comme ça et
ça c'est immuable. Par contre, il y a
deux trois trucs qui changent, c'est le
commerce international n'a plus tout à
fait la même tronche que ce qu'il était
avant le Covid. Je veux dire, voilà. Et
donc nous, qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Quels
sont nos repères ? Tout ça s'est
bouleversé. Enfin, on le disait tout à
l'heure avec le coût de l'énergie, de
l'engré, voilà, les interlocuteurs qu'on
avait hier sur l'engré et l'énergie, ce
seront pas les mêmes que demain. Et et
ces gens-là ont partagé deux trois
enjeux de de souveraineté alimentaire et
et on n' pas que des petits camarades
là-dedans. On n pas que des petits
camarades là-dedans. les gens qui
étaient a priori fréquentables hier le
sont pas aujourd'hui pour les gens qui
sont censés nous donner une vision et et
moi j'ai l'impression qu'on a juste
aucun indicateur qui vont dans le bon
sens que ce soit en France mais on le
voit en Europe partout en fait alors on
est tous mobilisés on dit pas tous la
même chose mais le message de fond c'est
de dire on n pas de vision on va dans le
mur on n pas de vision et et de l'autre
côté mais en fait si nous on je veux
dire on se remet pas en question et si
vous nous mettez pas en capacité de se
remettre en question parce qu'on On est
comme ça avec les finances et parce que
vous nous avez mis comme ça pendant 30
ans parce que de quelques politiques
qu'on parle, ils ont pas été fichus de
nous donner une vision claire et nette
quelque enfin quelque bord que ce soit,
c'est même plus le sujet. Et et donc en
fait se dire vous nous répondez avec des
mesures alors très bien, on va on va pas
lier à l'urgence, on y reviendra
peut-être sur les mesures voilà très
très terre à terraire très actuell quoi.
Mais nous ce qu'on demande c'est quand
on dit on change de logiciel, c'est la
vision. Enfin comment on va pouvoir se
positionner. Moi je je veux bien qu'on
dise bah écoutez en France on va faire
de l'écologie, on va faire de
l'environnement et on va vendre ça aux
autres touristes européens et ils
viendront se promener en France. Mais
qu'on nous le dise, qu'on nous paye pour
ça mais que ce soit honnête et que ce
soit fait. Voilà. dit "Bah vous les
agriculteurs, de toute façon, vous allez
finir à 100000 100000 têtes ou 200000
bonhommes." On vous paye. Vous nous
entretenez le paysage dans les Alpes,
vous foutez du loup comme ça on va se
promener. Dans les Pyrénées, on met un
peu d'ours, on fera peut-être un remake
de Yellow et puis ça ira très bien. Sauf
que nous, si on nous le dit pas, on peut
pas faire les bons choix et on met en
danger des gens et voilà, on arrive à
des drames humains, des sociétés de qui
font faillite, voilà, des drames
familiaux. Et ça va falloir à un moment
donné qui qu'on le mette sur le papier
et que chacun porte ses responsabilités.
Donc là ce qu'on dit c'est qu'est-ce que
vous voulez de nous ? Est-ce que on veut
continuer de la production vraiment sur
le territoire ? Au quel cas il va
falloir faire des concessions parce
qu'on pourra pas tout se permettre en
terme d'écologie et de dogme
lié à ça et et si c'est le cas, comment
on s'inscrit dans tout le visage
géopolitique européen et international ?
parce que bon ben on pourra plus acheter
du gaz pas cher et qu'on ne peut plus
acheter du gaz pas cher et que voilà.
Je te rassure, ils ont qu'un prisme de
lecture performant. C'est vu. Nous nous
on les a vu sur la guerre en Ukraine, on
a vu le truc se préparer. On a fait des
émissions concernant Poutine qui montre
ses muscles et ses nouvelles armes. On a
même fait venir un scientifique qui
était en pointe à l'époque sur ce type
de technologie. Et les mecs, ils sont
borgnes.
Il est aveugle au mieux borgne.
Comment rajouter un mot ?
Ouais. Je vais rajouter enfin on on
reprend, on va retourner un petit peu en
arrière. On va aller dans la France des
années 80 90 à l'agriculture au top. Ça
fonctionnait. Ça fonctionnait. Bah moi
je en parler mon père il m'a dit dans
les années 80 90
on sortait on sortait un peu de revenu.
On sortait un peu de revenu. Aujourd'hui
il regrette enfin il regrette. Oui et
non il m'a dit j'ai préféré tout
dépenser faire des enfants et acheter
des golfs. Mais en fait j'aurais dû
acheter des voitures
des golfs GTI. Bien sûr. Ah
ouais. Non
bah la jeunesse. Mais il m'a dit à
refaire aujourd'hui j'aurais dû acheter
des murs dans le milieu de Paris ou des
trucs du genre pour essayer de créer
mettre de mettre de mettre
d'investissement essayer de placer de
l'argent parce qu'en fait aujourd'hui où
est l'agriculture française quand on
regarde sur la carte monde ? Il aurait
pu acheter une Citroëne VTS quand même.
Merde.
Aujourd'hui aujourd'hui ça pèse plus
rien. Aujourd'hui l'agriculture
française quand on prend le monde ça ne
pèse plus rien. Moi je suis beaucoup sur
les cours Rx qui Chicago tout ça.
J'essaie de suivre un petit peu. Il y a
il y a une application qui à Gritel qui
nous donne les cours sur Ronex qui nous
donne un petit peu les tendances
journalières sur le lendemain et cetera,
qui jamais nous dit ça monte, ça
descend. Attention, prévoyer parce
qu'aujourd'hui je connais pas le
magicien qui est capable de nous dire
ils ont peut-être pas le droit de te
donner des conseils.
Bah il s essayent d'en amener des
conseils parce qu'ils sont là pour pour
essayer de conseiller et au contraire
eux plus l'agriculteur va avoir des
revenus plus peut-être l'agriculteur
pourrait derrière après leur acheter des
conseils. Donc ils essayent d'en amener
un petit peu mais aujourd'hui personne
n'est capable vraiment de dire après je
suis d'accord il y a géopolitique
Ukraine d'un seul coup c'est arrivé pas
c'est pas d'un seul coup
c'est pas d'un seul coup en fait oui on
avait vu venir il y avait la Crimé il y
avait des choses il y avait plein de
choses qui s'étaient mis en place
toi
oui sauf que à quel moment exactement on
allait pouvoir se dire c'est là ce
jour-là moi je veux bien on peut me dire
mais pourquoi vous avez pas anticipé sur
de l'achat d'engrais et cetera et cetera
et mais on est au bout on est au bout.
Moi je peux pas me dire tiens je là les
prix sont redescendus, la géopolitique
est pas terrible, allez hop, je
m'investis pour les trois prochaines
années. Parce qu'aujourd'hui, j'ai
personne qui va me dire "Tu es sûr de
toi ?" Non, moi je te suis pas.
Aujourd'hui, les banques vont nous dire
"Bah non, je te suis pas. Soit tu te le
caches toi-même, tu l'achètes cache
direct tout de suite. Sinon, moi je te
suis pas, je vais pas t'acheter de la
fourniture que tu vas mettre dans un
coin de ton bâtiment en quantité
extravagante pour te prévoir les trois
prochaines années."
Qui va l'assurer ?
Qui va l'assurer ? Puis puis ça se
trouve bah ça va repousser et puis ton
acte géopolitique sera arrivé dans 2 3 4
5 ans. Donc aujourd'hui ben voilà, on
était arrivé à bout, on a eu un manque
bah d'un se coup bah voilà la date
fatidique est arrivée, invasion, hausse
hausse des matières premières. Hausse
des matières premières sur les céréales.
Les agriculteurs ont sauté dessus en se
disant "Allez, c'est cool, on va pouvoir
vendre un petit peu plus." Ça fait ça
fait 10 ans qu'on avait les marchés qui
qui étaient très très calmes, très
calme. C'était un vent plat total qui se
faisait quand on allait rechercher 2 €.
On était gagnant comme tout, on était
content. C'était la fête au village.
C'était c'était vraiment tout plat. Et
d'un seul coupf est parti sur les
marchés, ça a explosé là-haut. Tout le
monde a acheté dessus, ça a rechuté. Les
charges engrais, phyo et cetera,
électricité, ça a suivi hein. Ça a suivi
mais sur un pas de temps légèrement
différent. Toute petit écart. Et puis
d'un se coup, bah là actuellement c'est
ce qu'on c'est ce qu'on critique enfin
ce qu'on critiqu maintenant, ce qu'on
subit l'effet ciseaux. C'est-à-dire bah
ça s'est croisé les prix. Là on me
propose d'acheter mon maïs 150 € la
tonne. 150 € la tonne c'est un prix que
mon père vendait dans les années 2000.
C'est un prix qu'on a vendu en 2016.
C'est un prix aujourd'hui où bah on
retire tous les systèmes d'inflation
hein. On est revenu très très bas. 150 €
je vends à perte. Mon maïs, il faudrait
que je le vende 230 240 € pour être à
peu près équilibre et essayer de me
sortir quelque chose. J'ai 10 hectares
de maïs, c'est pas énorme heureusement
mais là là je le vends à perdre. Donc je
l'ai toujours, il est en stock chez moi
en me disant peut-être que je vais aller
rechercher 10 € de plus en espérant mais
je suis pas à l'abri que bah j'en perde
encore 10 €. et les charges. Là, je suis
en train de payer mes charges de l'année
dernière où j'ai acheté des engrais à
650 700 € la tonne, sauf que en 2000
quoi 20189, j'ai acheté 200 € la tonne.
On a fait x 3 sur les charges, on a fait
x 2 sur le prix du céréal super et là
pouf, je rembourse mes charges et je
vends un 150 €. Là, j'ai plus d'argent.
L'année dernière, on on clair, l'année
dernière fiscale, je déclare 46000 avec
le revenu de mon épouse. Cette année,
c'est le revenu de mon épouse qui va me
sortir quelque chose. Je me prends de
l'argent mais parce que j'en ai besoin
sur mon exploitation, parce que j'en ai
besoin personnellement parce que j'ai
deux enfants parce qu'il y en a un qui
est à l'école, l'autre la petite, elle a
16 mois, faut payer les couches. Donc je
prends de l'argent, faut payer la
nounou. Là, je viens de faire une
demande sur une accompagnement sur
l'aide l'aide. Je vais avoir une une
aide au logement supplémentaire qui va
arriver là. Euh enfin voilà, je demande
je demande de l'aide là aujourd'hui,
c'est il faut nous trouver quelque chose
mais je je reste un petit peu un côté
optimiste en me disant c'est une
mauvaise année là.
C'est parce que tu es jeune ça.
Oui. Oui. Mais parce qu'on a envie d'y
croire. parce qu'on a envie d'y croire
et parce qu'on sait que on peut encore
changer certaines choses. Mais faut nous
écouter. Faut nous écouter. On a l'année
dernière chez jeunes agriculteur, on a
travaillé sur un rapport d'orientation
pour essayer alors c'est tous les ans,
on travaille toute l'année sur des
rapports d'orientation sur différents
thèmes et l'année dernière c'était sur
l'adaptation changement climatique,
l'anticipation du changement climatique.
On a tout posé, on a regardé, on a dit
tiens, il y en a qui nous disent 2
degrés, il y en a qui nous disent 4
degrés, il y en a qui nous disent qu'on
pollue d'autres qu'on pollue moins,
qu'il faut arrêter l'élevage, qu'il faut
augmenter, qu'il faut mettre plus de c
plus de ça. On a essayé tout regrouper,
on a essayé tout remettre et on a
travaillé nous interne avec le réseau
jeune agriculteur pour essayer de
trouver des solutions. Essayer de
trouver des solutions pour bah comment
travailler avec le changement
climatique, comment essayer d'adapter
nos exploitations sur l'avenir. Et
l'avenir aujourd'hui en fait là bah
c'est ce qui manque clairement
aujourd'hui
nous c'est ce qu'on réclame là il y a eu
toutes les manifres qu'on eu là sur
dernier temps. On n'est pas à l'abri que
ça reparte elle est où la vision ? On a
aucune vision on demande une vision sur
du long terme. On demande de
l'installation. Je vais reprendre mon
installation. Je me suis installé avec
un plan économique sur 5 7 ans.
5 7 ans. En 5 7 ans, j'ai tout vu. Je
suis installé 2016, Covid, Ukraine
dégrolade. J'ai tout vu. Mon mon plan
économique, je ne l'ai pas tenu. Je ne
pouvais pas le tenir. Donc on demande
une vision. Nous ce qu'on c'est ce que
disait Pierric. Au pire faut nous le
dire hein. Si on veut devenir des
fonctionnaires, bah qu'on nous le dise
maintenant. Moi, on me donne 3000 € par
mois, je devais un fonctionnaire, je
mets tout en herbe, tout en ja, tout.
3000 € par motion.
Mais non, mais agriculteur enfin moi
c'est ce que j'essaie de dire à certains
quand même, on est quand même la le
premier. On est trois fois par jour dans
dans dans les ménagers matin, midi et
soir. On nourrit les gens, on est la
base et aujourd'hui les deux qui font
voir, c'est la base, le consommateur.
Entre deux, il y a il y a un manque
quelque part. On sait pas trop où va
l'argent, mais ça c'est un autre sujet,
on y reviendra. Et aujourd'hui, on dit
"Ben à ce moment-là, vous voulez qu'on
soit fonctionnaire, vous voulez qu'on
entretienne le paysage, vous voulez plus
de phy si, vous voulez comme ça, vous
voulez." OK, pas de problème. Vous nous
payez, on vous fait ce que vous voulez,
il y a pas de problème. Mais on veut du
revenu aujourd'hui. On veut vivre de de
l'agriculture. Enfin, je je suis né sur
une exploitation, on on je fais j'étais
dans un tracteur à 1 an et demi, j'étais
sur un tracteur à 3 ans. À 3 ans, j'ai
eu un accident. Je suis passé sous un
tracteur et je suis là aujourd'hui et je
continue. Toujours. Bah, il me reste
qu'une cicatrice, hein. Euh, occital,
tricranien, hélicoptère rond. Enfin, la
totale des souples à stage là.
Ah oui, très souple. Ça c'est plutôt
bien reconstruit.
Mais ça a été très compliqué sur
l'exploitation quand il se passe ça. Euh
voilà, mon père qui était au volant, moi
quand on est tombé du tracteur, bah ça
ça fout un choc quand même sur
l'exploitation hein. Donc pendant un ou
2 ans, il y a il y a plus de tracteur
hein. J'ai plus vu un tracteur.
Ah non, c'était terminé. Et puis ben
non, en fait l'agriculture c'est c'est
dans le sang en fait malheureusement ou
heureusement, j'en sais rien. C'est dans
le sens, c'est une envie, on a envie de
la suivre, on a envie de la pousser, on
est libre et aujourd'hui c'est ça qui
dérange. C'est la liberté. C'est la
liberté. Vous êtes pas aussi libre que
ça. Je vais vous je vais vous remontrer
vos chaînes et puis on va reparler.
Oui. Oui. Non, en fait, je je veux dire
que tu es libre, c'est-à-dire si moi
demain matin
les semences, tu les achètes où ?
Ben les sem Alors, je fais une partie
que je récolte et c'est moi qui fait mes
semence.
Tu as le droit de faire ça ?
Bien sûr, bien sûr. J'appelle, j'appelle
moi je je garde mes je récolte mon blé,
on va prendre un blé, on va prendre une
variété variété X, je prends
profeté.
Ah si c'est les variétés qui sont bébé
mais aujourd'hui on peut garder on peut
garder cette semence parce Ah totalement
parce qu'elle est dans le elle est dans
le elle est class elle est
dans le catalogue d'en
catalogue d'en autorisé et vendu dès le
départ au moment de l'achat de cette
semence là on paye une petite part de
taxe dessus sur les renouvellements de
semences qui vont servir pour renouveler
et pour créer des futures semences. Moi,
au moment que je vais reprendre ces ces
ces sens-là, à la fin euh c'est c'est
déduit aussi. J'ai ma fiscalité, j'ai ma
comptabilité, tout ça c'est cré en
charge dessus. Euh je quand je vends le
reste mes de mes semences, je paye
aussi, je sais pas, je vais vendre 200 €
la tonne mon blé, je vais on va me
prendre 1 € 1,50 € sur mes 200 € qui
vont permettre de payer la recherche de
semence, le renouvellement des semences
et tout ce qui gravite un petit peu
autour sur la recherche pour mes futures
semences. Donc oui, ça c'est autorisé.
là où après je vois je vois bien un peu
après le c'est sur les variétés
anciennes, c'est sur les variétés qui
sont plus dans le catalogue ou qui sont
sorties des voilà des variétés
aujourd'hui qu'on peut plus trop
travailler. Là celle-ci euh crée un peu
débat parce que soit elles sont sources
à maladie ou soit elles sont plus
recherchées, soit plus personne peut la
tenir. Bon là c'est un autre sujet.
Soit tu sais pas la faire pousser,
soit tu sais pas la faire pousser.
Aujourd'hui moi je suis sur une variété,
je suis bête et méchant. On me sort un
catalogue, on me dit bah voilà celle-là
tac, elle va bien. Celle-là attention,
elle est un peu plus à risque à maladie.
Celle-là, bonne production mais elle
aime pas la sécheresse. Bon ben, je
regarde mes qualités de sol, je regarde
ce qui fonctionne chez moi, je fais ma
solution.
Tu regardes comment tes qualités de sol
?
Analyse de sol en fait
combien ça coûte ?
Alors il y a il y a
sur quelle profondeur ?
Alors il y a plusieurs il y a plusieurs
analyses. On va dire on va avoir la la
simple relica azotée, c'est-à-dire tous
les ans. Moi, je suis dans une zone
vulnérable. Dites vulnérable.
Aujourd'hui, il y a une grosse partie de
la France qui est en zone vulnérable.
Donc c'est-à-dire avant de mettre de
pour pouvoir mettre de l'engrais dessus,
il faut que je prenne une petite carotte
de terre sur 30 et 60. Moi je peux pas
descendre plus parce que mon profondeur
de sol, après je suis sur une seule dure
mais dans les grosses terres profondes,
ils peuvent même aller chercher à 90 cm
de sol. Ils en font trois. Euh ils
analysent et dedans ils sortent le
relicard restant 90 de
cm de profondeur.
C'est c'est que dalle.
Bah c'est que dalle. Maintenant c'est
les racines. elles descendent à combien
de tomblé que super après ? Ça dépend
des cultures et ça dépend aussi des
types de seul et de la faisabilité. Mais
voilà, une racine qui descend à 90 cm,
on est déjà sur des des sols quand même
très performant, des sols qui
fonctionnent très bien. Moi chez moi,
quand il touchent la roche, elles sont à
60 cm, elles essayent de se créer un
chemin, on arrive vraiment au bout.
Après, il y a des variétés, enfin il y a
des cultures qui qui vont plus loin que
d'autres. La voine, la voine a un
système racinaire beaucoup plus profond.
Euh là, ça là ça ça ça perce, ça va.
Sur ton analyse de sol, il te propose
combien
? Là sur mon analyse de sol, j'ai mes
rolicas, j'ai mes restes avec ça.
Combien de petites bêtes qui sont
vivantes ? Quel type de
Alors ça c'est une autre analyse de sol.
Çaen est une autre. Après pour connaître
ce qu'on a dans le sol, phosphore,
potassium, le bord, le zinc, le fer,
tout ce qu'il y a dedans,
matière organique, le pH. Voilà, la
totale, ça c'est la grosse totale. Donc
celle-là, elle coûte 250 300 €. Moi,
j'en fais trois par an systématiquement.
Tous les ans, je me dis il faut que j'en
fasse trois. J'ai mes parcelles, je fais
un roulement tous les ans pour voir s'il
faut des choses que je rapporte ou pas
parce que tout ce qu'on apporte ça coûte
et si je peux m'en passer bah je le fais
parce que à la fin bah c'est c'est là
que ça peut revenir. Donc
je je peux te poser une question ?
Vas-y.
La qualité des sols en France, elle est
comment ? Avec une agriculture intensive
depuis les 30 dernières années avec des
intrans à gogo. Est-ce que la qualité
des sols en France elle peut résister à
on arrête de mettre des choses dedans et
quelles vont être les rendements ?
Aujourd'hui, ça va résister sans
problème. Aujourd'hui, demain on se dit
stop, on arrête tout phy cultures.
Plus d'engrais, plus de d'insecticides,
tout ça.
Ah ben on va perdre des rendements.
Combien ?
Oh bah on est sur là, je veux pas trop
m'avancer mais on est sur un bon plus de
50 % de perte. Pourquoi ? Parce que
tu fais combien en blé ?
En blé chez moi, je fais 7 tonnes 5 8
tonnes de blé à hectare pour combien de
de tonnes d'engrais
? Et je mets alors c'est en unité azoté.
Alors attends que je leur fasse le
calcul comme ça de tête. Euh je vais
être à peu près à 400 kg
total qui vont qui vont me représenter
150 160 unités d'azote en fait parce que
quand on achète c'est comme sur les
produits phytaux quand on achète le
bidon qui fait 10 L dedans il y a un ton
il y a un poids de matière active s'il
est euh s'il est gradé à 0,39
s'il est gradé à 0,33 voilà c'est sur
une base 1. Donc je vais mettre 4
pardon excuse-moi je t'en prie.
Vas-y vas-y.
Donc en azote tu mets combien
en azote ? 430 450 kg à peu près qui me
représente 150 unités d'engrais sur un
champ de blé. Sur un champ de colza, je
vais être plutôt autour de 180 unités.
Le colza un peu plus gourmand pour en
azote. Et à l'inverse en face on a les
poids et les féveroles où on met zéro
parce que dessus sur les racines, on a
des petites boules blanches qui
s'appellent des nodosités. Et ça ça en
fait le poids capte l'azote de l'air, le
redonne dans le sol, nourrit la plante
et derrière quand la plante le poids où
la fvoile est récolté, on s'aime un blé
dedans. On sait que moi dès le départ
quand je mets un blé derrière des poids,
je vais retirer entre 30 et 40 unités
parce que la culture d'avant l'a relâché
dans le sol. Donc ça va faire bénéfice
ça à mes cultures.
Tout seul toi à faire ça ? Est-ce qu'il
y en a de plus en plus qui essayent de
travailler ses sols ?
Ah il y en a de plus en plus. Alors oui
pour des questions économiques ou pour
des questions de on arrête de balancer
n'importe quoi dans les sols ? parce que
ça coûte cher
parce que quand je t'écoute, j'ai
l'impression d'entendre un mec à
Amsterdam qui m'explique la culture
semi-hydroponique du chanvre textile, tu
vois, c'est si tuas tu mets pas d'un
tran bah non, ça va pas le faire. Alors
c'est pas de l'hydroponique,
non
mais ça commence à y ressembler quand
même. Moi je me dis je suis en je suis
je suis en sorte de permaculture
industrielle, c'est-à-dire je suis en
grande culture. Tu
en transition quoi.
Ouais en fait je suis en culture de
conservation des sols. Donc je travaille
plus mon sol. Je récolte, je sème un
couvert. Donc un couvert, c'est de la
moutarde. C'est de la moutarde pas pour
consommer en moutarde, mais bon, je je
la récolte pas. Elle la moutarde, elle
va créer un système racinaire qui va
aller capter l'azote, qui va le remonter
dans la plante. Au moment de la
destruction de la plante, choup, à leur
largue. Bénéfice pour la culture qui
suit. Pois févrol, elle capte dans
l'air. Bénéfice derrière de la voine
gros système racinaire. Elle structure
le sol. Au moment qu'elle est détruite,
mon blé dedans, les racines, le chemin
il est fait. Il y a plein de petites
cultures comme ça. On crée ça. Au moment
de ma destruction, je laisse tout le
paillage sur le dessus. Donc tout le
paillage qui est sur le dessus va me
recouvrir le sol. Maintenant, grosse
permaculture, on va mettre 10 cm de de
de paille dedans. Ça va vraiment la
chaleur, elle va éviter de pénétrer,
vraiment garder l'humidité. Moi, je sur
en grande culture, je vais jouer sur 1 2
3 cm. Mais tous les ans, tous les ans,
tous les ans, tous les ans, tous les
ans. Quand je me suis installé, j'étais
à 1 2 de pourcentage de matière
organique sur mon sol. Là en ce moment,
les dernières analyses que je viens de
recevoir, je suis entre 25 et 27. Donc
j'ai augmenté mon taux de matière
organique. En augmentant le taux de
matière organique, je capte mieux l'eau.
Quand il pleut, bah les pailles
conservent plus l'humidité. Donc je suis
moins en source d'érosion par la pluie.
Euh avec un sol couvert et non
travaillé, je suis moins aussi à
l'érosion par le vent. Le quand on
travaille un seul, tout ce qu'on voit
volée, c'est la la poussière et autre,
c'est de l'argile. C'est la meilleure
des terres. C'est la plus belle. C'est
la voilà. et et celle-là aujourd'hui
quand elle s'envole, bah malheureusement
euh elle se retrouve sur nos capots,
elle se retrouve sur les toits, euh
voilà, elle se retrouve sur les routes,
c'est pas le but. L'idée c'est vraiment
de la garder. Moi, je suis plutôt parti
là-dessus et puis c'est surtout mon gros
point, c'est en terme de finances, je
voulais faire des économies, des
économies de matériel et des économies
euh carburant. Carburant aujourd'hui,
une agriculture, on va dire une
exploitation moyenne, va consommer entre
100 et 120 L de carburant à l'hctare.
Euh là, sur l'année 2023, je suis à 56
L. Exactement. moissonneuse et moisson
comprise. Donc euh parce que c'est la
moisson qui me coûte le plus hein. La
moissonneuse devrait consommer quasiment
30 L hein, elle toute seule à l'hctare.
Euh donc tout compris, voilà où j'en
suis aujourd'hui. Donc j'ai diminué par
deux mes coûts de carburant, donc
beaucoup moins dépendant euh et puis
j'ai des sols qui fonctionnent mieux.
Et tes rendements ?
Et euh rendement, j'ai vu une petite
baisse sur le début. Là aujourd'hui, je
suis en train de revenir à stabiliser un
peu. Malheureusement, je suis sur des
sols où ce que je disais, j'ai 60 cm de
terre en dessous, j'arrive sur de la
roche, j'arrive sur du
années vraiment à coup à coup de sec là.
Euh alors oui, avec ma matière
organique, je vais avant que ma culture
décroche et qu'elle fan, je vais
peut-être gagner 2 3 jours. Euh mais en
fait, on a le changement climatique est
clairement là et et quand tu te prends
un coup de sécheresse qui dure un mois,
bah je suis comme tout le monde, plof,
ça crève. On va reparler des bassines et
des des rétentions d'eau. Pierric, quand
on tend ton Quentin ton bras droit, euh
au niveau de votre syndicat, ça parle de
ce type de changement de pratique, genre
arrêter de labourer 40 cm de profond,
c'est-à-dire retourner des
des organismes qui qui devraient pas
être à 10 cm proche de l'air. Est-ce que
cette psychologie
change ?
Ouais. C'est pour des questions
financières, pour des questions de
respect de l'environnement, pour des
questions de coût, pour des questions de
on s'adapte parce qu'il faut survivre.
Ah, j'ai envie de te dire, tu as un peu
tous les profils chez J. Tu as les mecs
qui sont là pour l'économie qui se
disent "Bah le semidirect, l'agriculture
de conservation des sols, j'ai fait mon
calcul, je consomme 2/3 de moins que que
qu'en bio hein. Par exemple, moi je suis
à 176 à l'hectare, je labour à 30 cm de
profond parce que sinon j'ai de l'herbe
partout et je produis
de tiers de moins que Quentin à
l'hectare, mais c'est la réalité hein.
Moi je je peux pas amener de de d'azote
minéral. Enfin bref et donc en fait il y
a une partie des gars qui se disent bah
enfin des gars et des nénettes he 30 %
de de nénettes qui s'installent en
agriculture
de femmes pardon mon dieu euh de femmes
qui s'installent en agriculture. Donc
euh
il y a il y a tous les profils. Il y en
a c'est vraiment pour l'économique le
business et voilà si demain ça revient
le business avec les produits phyx sur
les produits phys. Et il y a des profils
qui sont quand même, moi, j'estime, la
majorité qui se disent "Mais en fait,
nous on n pas envie de pourrir le sol de
nos gamins, on n pas envie de laisser
une terre dégueulasse." Et l'agriculture
de conservation, ça constitue un modèle
qui est plutôt vertueux. L'agriculture
bio sur des modèles d'élevage extensif,
c'est-à-dire du pâturage sur de la
prairie permanente ou des estives ou
quoi, bah ça constitue quelque chose de
vertueux et et voilà. Et donc en fait,
il y a quand même plutôt des gens qui
sont sensibles à ça sur le côté
environnement
purement quoi, écologie et sensibilité
parce que on est né aussi à un siècle où
enfin moi je veux dire 33 ans tous les
deux.
Ouais. Et et donc les questions
environnementales,
j'ai l'impression qu'elle me concerne un
peu plus que quand je discute avec mon
grand-père qui dit "Putain, attends, le
bidon, il y a combien ? Faut doubler la
dose."
Et sans masque.
Et sans masque, voilà. et je vais
touiller avec les doigts. Enfin,
j'exagère à peine quoi.
Ouais. Et et et donc moi non, je vais
mettre une combinaison de cosmonaute. Il
va se [__] de ma gueule mais c'est pas
grave parce que voilà, je vais essayer
de de garder ma santé le plus longtemps
possible parce que d'abord j'ai pas
envie de mourir sur mon tracteur à 60 à
60 et quelques années.
L'espérance de vie d'un agriculteur en
France, c'est combien en ce moment ?
Bonne question. Franchement,
je je me demande si j'avais pas vu un
article passer comme quoi même les
agriculteurs disaient plus
source. Alors mais attends,
si tu as pas la source, tu gardes ça
pour toi.
Ah ben je garde ça pour moi. Mais si
s'il y en a qui veulent regarder, je
pense que ils peuvent regarder parce que
même là d'un coup je suis curieux.
Moi je je Ouais je je je sais pas
l'espérance de vie moyenne d'un
agriculteur. Déjà la moyenne nationale,
je même plus combien on est maintenant.
Mais mais en tout cas ce que je me dis
c'est que bon moi j'ai j'ai pas envie de
mourir sur mon tracteur. J'ai pas envie
de voilà, j'ai j'ai envie mon activité
professionnelle de bah voilà, je sais
pas, d'aller voyager dans le monde,
faire du bateau, d'autres trucs parce
que voilà, il y a d'autres trucs qui
m'attire dans la vie que de travailler
former des jeunes
ou former des jeunes, voilà et en tout
cas donner l'envie mais mais aussi à un
moment donné dire ben stop enfin moi
j'ai contribué voilà l'alimentation la
défense syndicale et enfin voilà j'ai
d'autres projets de vie aussi des
enfants, tu vas pas
Ouais, j'ai un grand de 10 ans et un
autre qui va avoir 3 ans la fin avril et
et donc voilà, j'ai aussi envie de enfin
cette sensibilité là, moi je me dis
enfin les enfants on les élève à la
ferme, on les enlève on les élève dehors
en tout cas enfin voilà quand on est
agriculteur et je me dis mais enfin
pourquoi sous prétexte qu'il faudrait
produire pour des raisons économiques on
alors qu'on a les capacités de le faire
différemment peut-être que mon
grand-père les avait pas à l'époque et
et qu'aujourd'hui on les a pourquoi on
les saisit pas et en fait c'est tout ce
public là qu'on a chez jeunes
agriculteurs notamment mais qu'il y a
aussi dans d'autres syndicats euh qui se
disent ben voilà on veut produire
différemment par contre on veut gagner
du pognon On veut avoir une vie sociale
et on veut pas faire ça toute notre vie.
Et donc ben l'agriculture de
conservation des sols pour le modèle
grande culture fonctionne et puis il y a
d'autres modèles qui fonctionnent pour
la viticulture pour pour pour on
reparlera de la transmission des des
exploitations et de du renouvellement de
des agriculteurs. On revient sur le côté
géopolitique guerre économique.
Il y a un acteur étatique qui va voir
les syndicats pour faire passer le
message que eux ils anticipent ça ou pas
du tout.
Il y en a un qui est chargé de cette
mission à la base hein. Le ministre de
l'agriculture. C'est qui ? Le celui qui
sait combien al hectare ça fait combien
?
Non non pas celui-là. C'était pas le bon
ministre de l'agriculture.
Mais merde. Fais gaffe, il est aux
finances.
Ouais. Bon faut il a peut-être pris des
cours de match he
il a pris des cours de de d'écriture.
Ouais je Oui, c'est vrai. Pas faux. il a
pris des cours de littérature. Bon, je
suis pas sûr que ça nous aide beaucoup
dans la situation économique du pays,
mais bref. Non, normalement celui qui
est censé nous apporter la vision parce
qu'il a cette capacité à prendre du
recul parce qu'il consulte bah les OPA,
les syndicats, tous les acteurs et
servic
les services de renseignement si si si
grand bien lui grand bien lui fasse de
nous dire ben voilà les gars, il faut
qu'on vous faut que vous alliez
là-dedans parce que c'est la vérité
parce que voilà. Est-ce que vous avez
entendu il faut réarmer l'agriculture ?
Ah oui, il faut tout réarmer en ce
moment.
Est-ce que Est-ce que vous avez entendu
il faut militariser l'agriculture ?
Celui-là, je l'ai pas entendu. Militaris
fois, ça va venir.
Ah bon ? Bon ben, on se prépare alors.
Tu te prépares comment ? Alors
là, on entend les Allemands qui disent
dans 5 ans faut être prêt à la guerre.
On entend les Polonais qui sont en train
de de cigner un petit peu. Les les les
Estoniens, les Lituaniens, les
Finlandais, les Suédois. sont tous en
train de faire ou ou il y a le monstre
russe qui est parti depuis les 8
dernières années qui a designé son
économie en mode économie de guerre
comme on a des pignouf on a rien vu
venir et ils viennent de se rendre
compte que il y a une stratégie de
guerre une économie de guerre qui est
mise en place et que avant que le
mammouth ralentisse le mammouth risque
un petit peu de leur marcher sur leur
plat de bande. Donc vous vous êtes en
première ligne pour nourrir les gens,
vous êtes l'armée de de l'estomac.
Donc militariser l'agriculture. Bon ça
ils en sont pas encore là mais vous
inquiétez pas et vous vous appelez quand
ça va commencer à chauffer. Et réarmer
l'agriculture.
Alors réarmer l'agric enfin en fait tout
ça moi je je veux bien mais
amener les gens à avoir peur pour se
dire qu'on a pris les bonnes décisions
politiquement. Je pense qu'ils ont pas
encore bien compris l'enjeu de leur
métier ces gens-là parce que c'est pas
en cultivant la peur notamment chez les
agriculteurs parce qu'on parle de ça
qu'on va amener les agriculteurs à
prendre des bonnes décisions. Moi je
pense qu'il faut surtout se dire
attendez il y a des enjeux colossaux
tous les autres pays il faut réarmer
machin et tout mais on peut se dire
qu'il y a certaines choses qui
fonctionnent très bien et qu'on a un
savoir-faire en agriculture en France et
qu'on a une traçabilité et il y a des
repères forts qu'on valorise pas du tout
qu'on valorise pas du tout. On nous a
tous amené à faire de la qualité. Moi le
premier je m'a dit voilà faut faire du
bio. J'ai fait du bio. Je suis incapable
de valoriser mes produits en bio.
J'arrive pas à les vendre sur le marché
bio. Il y a plus de marché bio. On l'a
pété. On nous a fait monter en gamme.
Très bien. C'était l'Eldorado et tout
super ne marche pas. Et donc en fait
quand on dit réarmer l'agriculture c'est
quoi ? C'est on fait peur au mec et on
leur explique qu'on va droit dans le mur
et que de toute façon nous on est
incapable de prendre des décisions.
Enfin moi je le lis comme ça. Quand on
dit je vais réarmer l'agriculture, on
excite tout le monde. Mais c'est quoi
l'objectif final ?
C'est de faire du bruit avec sa bouche
et agiter les bras. Ouais, j'ai
l'impression que c'est ça. Sauf que nous
ce qu'on demande c'est "OK, vous vous
faites peur, vous vous gérez la peur.
Moi je je pense que le politique tant
qu'il commandera avec la peur, il serait
incompétent." Et bon, ça fonctionne
comme ça. Bon,
tu as l'impression qu'il gère quelque
chose là ?
Non, ils subissent, ils subissent.
Enfin, je veux dire, ils subissent et
nous derrière, on subit bêtement parce
que voilà, on prend tout dans la tronche
et ça ne nous amène pas à avoir une
vision et pourtant on demande d'une
vision. Et donc en fait à un moment
donné ces gens-là, j'ai l'impression
qu'ils ont la capacité à pouvoir prendre
du recul parce qu'ils ont accès à des
informations, à une vision qu'on a pas.
Enfin, je veux dire, c'est pas à
l'Europe, ils voient bien comment leurs
petits camarades réagissent quand ils
appuyent sur tel ou tel bouton ou qui
déclenchent tel ou tel truc. Et pourquoi
nous ils nous enfin, pourquoi ils nous
ramènent pas ça pour qu'on se le mette
en perspective ? Parce que moi j'ai
envie de nourrir mon pays. Enfin, je le
fais, c'est un choix de vie. Je je me
régale à faire de la bouffe et et de la
faire comme il faut et j'ai envie de le
faire. Et
on parlera de la battage de tes vaches
un peu plus tard. Quo Ouais, il y a pas
de problème. Et et et en fait voilà, je
je veux dire c'est ça qu'on on leur on
leur dit mais en fait pourquoi vous êtes
pas capable de nous amener une vision
alors que il y a tous les signaux et et
cette culture de la peur pour prendre
des décisions en agriculture on sait que
ça fonctionne pas. Bon après, il faut
pas être complètement miop, se dire
"Non, non, tout va bien, vous inquiétez
pas, il se passe rien." On voit bien que
voilà, on se prépare à des conflits
armés, on parle beaucoup d'armement,
tout le monde remet des milliards sur
l'armement de chacun de son pays. On
n'est même pas tous d'accord entre
enfin, c'est illisible pour
l'agriculteur lambda qui veut produire.
Euh voilà et c'est ça qu'on dénonce. Et
quand ces mecs-là sont sont élus, bah il
faut qu'ils aillent jusqu'au bout de
leur mandat et de leur fonction et qu'
prennent des décisions et qui nous
disent "Bon ben voilà, ça sera comme si
ça sera comme ça plutôt que voilà des
grandes concertations, des machins, des
trucs. On a plus le temps là. On a plus
le temps. Faut bombarder pour le coup.
Tiens, voilà, faut bombarder. Non mais
c'est vrai, je veux dire, enfin si on
réarme l'agriculture, faut qu'on
bombarde. Il faut qu'on
On réarme où ?
Et ben, on réarme parce qu'on va
installer des jeunes, parce que on va
former des salariés en agriculture
aussi, parce que tout le monde n'est pas
avoué à devenir un chef d'exploitation.
agricole. Tout le monde n'est pas voué
être entrepreneur de agriculteur ou
paysan. Tout le monde n'est pas voueté
devenir paysan comme ça on parle de tous
les modèles et et voilà. Et donc il faut
former aussi des salariés. Il faut voilà
c'est ça réarmer. C'est pas vous dire
ben on va vous filer du pognon parce que
vous gueulez un peu plus fort que
d'habitude et comme ça vous allez vous
taire. Ça c'est pas régler les
problèmes. Même si évidemment ça
concerne toute une frange de de
personnes qui sont dans le besoin parce
que je le disais tout à l'heure la
politique de 30 ans en arrière qui n'en
était pas une et qui n'apporte rien. Et
ben si ces gens-là prétendent qu'ils
sont mieux que leurs prédécesseurs, ben
qui nous le démontr
Quentin ?
Ouais. Non mais il y a il y a a y a il y
a un truc quand même qui qui existe et
qu'on connaît tous, c'est quand même
l'histoire. Et sur l'histoire, je pense
qu'on l'oublie très vite en fait.
L'agriculture a toujours trinqué dans
tous les sens, dans toutes les guerres
tout le temps. On avait besoin des
agriculteurs pour aller au front quand
il y a eu les guerres. Il fallait
redonner vite agriculteur produisez, il
faut nourrir, il faut nourrir et vas-y,
on y va. Et c'est là que derrière il y a
eu des miracles qui enfin des miracles,
j'ai envie de dire les avancés phyux,
les avent avancé engrais, mécanisation
technologique qui sont arrivé après les
secondes guerres mondiales parce que il
fallait vite redonner à manger. Pourquoi
? parce qu'il y a eu des pas de temps où
on a loupé plein de choses et puis on a
dit non non l'agriculture c'est rien et
puis quand finalement tout le monde
avait faim ah zut o c'est c'est pas le
tout d'envoyer du monde à la guerre mais
faut peut-être les nourrir quand même un
petit peu là aujourd'hui. Enfin je suis
désolé il y en a un qui doit bien
rigoler et bien sauter les mains quand
même hein voilà chercher he il est
complètement à l'est lui. Là il a
regardé on y a tous tapé dessus. Ah bon
ça envahit. Allez tiens, on va te mettre
ça, on te met ça, on te met ça, on te
met ça, on te met ça. Et là, toute
l'Europe bouge sur l'agriculture.
Et je veux pas dire, mais l'agriculture
aujourd'hui russe, aujourd'hui ils sont
là, demain ils sont ils sont là-haut.
Eux, réchauffement climatique hein, ça
fonctionne plutôt bien. Voilà, on va se
le dire. Réchauffement climatique, ça
fonctionne. Ça va aider la Russie pour
demain. Clairement,
parce que ça libère
Ben parce que parce qu'aujourd'hui, la
Sibérie est en train de reculer au fur
et à mesure. La la glace et et les
neiges sont en train de fondre. Il retou
totalement il retour le méthane
ah bah ça ça redégage mais après on n'a
pas les mêmes politiques
environnementales entre nous la France
on essaie de faire plus vert et être le
plus vert dans tous les copains. Je mar
avec le l'épée de ses vaches là.
Voilà. Bah nous en France il va bientôt
falloir qu'il mettent des sacs pour les
récupérer. Euh là-bas en Russie il y a
pas de problème pour ça hein. C'est pas
grave. On y va.
Vous avez goûté les tomates en Russie
? Non non
non ça ça vaut le coup.
Ah ça vaut le coup.
Ah bon ? Ah d'accord. On va se garder
ça.
Non mais ça c'est un truc
extraordinaire. Non mais eux
ça c'est un truc qui m'a choqué
d'ailleurs. Le le goût des tomates en
Russie c'est mais à milieu du goût des
tomates qu'on a en France
et pourtant j'ai des copains qui font
des variétés anciennes de machins de
bidules.
Ah mais lain ouais mais voilà la
l'agriculture russe enfin eux tous les
ans se libèrent des milliers d'hectares
supplémentaires parce que parce que
voilà ils en retrouvent euh ils sont cap
et puis là ils ils en veulent un peu
chez les Ukrain
pu en plus de temps en temps vo bah là
il y a une petite guerre alors détourner
deux trois de trois bateaux de trois hop
ça récupère un peu, ça renflou les
stocks. Tous les ans il tapent des
records. Tous les ans. Tous les ans.
Tous les ans.
Tu fais ça comment ?
Euh Euronex Aggretel c'est la petite
application que je suis. Euh dessus ils
nous mettent on a tous les rapports qui
tombent. monde euh pour les États-Unis,
rapport USDA. USDA, c'est le ministère
de l'agriculture américaine qui tous les
15 jours nous sort un rapport sur l'état
des stocks et l'état des récoltes monde.
On connaît les plus grands euh
tricheurs, on va dire, les petits
menteurs monde. Ce sont les Russes et
puis les Chinois. Alors, les Chinois,
ils sont côté menteur, mais le problème
du Chinois de de de Chine, si tu dis que
c'est les menteurs, faut leur donner des
chiffres. Et en fait c'est c'est pas en
fait pour eux malheureusement côté
mensonge, c'est qu'en fait la Chine est
tellement grande que il y a tellement de
petites exploitations que si dans toutes
les exploitations il y a une tonne de
blé qui est stocké quelque part, ils
sont pas capables de la quantifier. Donc
ils nous annoncent en fait des chiffres,
finalement ça se rattrape voilà, c'est
un peu au doigt mouillé. Alors ils
arrivent à mieux quantifier, c'est de
mieux en mieux. Mais euh du coup quand
on fait les bilans annuels, on fait le
bilan hors Chine et le bilan avec Chine
parce que la Chine est un gros
importateur quand même. La la Chine, un
alléat climatique sur une grosse partie
de la région. En fait, la Chine a a
divisé parce que c'est les productions
et que ça que ça fonctionne mieux dans
une région qu'une autre entre le blé,
entre le riz, entre toutes les autres
culture et du coup ça bah quand il y a
un alléa climatique sur un endroit, ils
deviennent 100 % importateurs. Donc la
Chine, on reste toujours très méfiant
sur la Chine parce que du jour au
lendemain
et l'Afrique elle aime pas trop en
général.
Ah bah non du tout. Et et puis après de
l'aut côté, on avait les Russes, les
Russes qui qui ont raconté énormément de
choses sur les dernières années. Et là
les Russes tous les ans, ils viennent
depuis euh
2016 17, ils arrivent, on tape du
record, on tape du record. Nous non,
c'est pas vrai, c'est pas vrai. C'est
des mensonges, c'est des mensonges. Puis
tous les ans, puis tous les ans, puis en
fait, on regarde bah ce qu'ils annoncent
et puis après bah un truc que peut tout
le monde voir, c'est l'exportation.
Qu'est-ce qui sortent ? On connaît la
population, on connaît l'exportation.
Bah, on n'est pas loin d'avoir le
tonnage qu'ils ont produit chez eux. Et
en fait bah non non, il m' plus il m'
plus. Aujourd'hui la les la la
production en Russie, elle est
exponentielle. Là aujourd'hui, on tourne
quasiment entre 90 millions et 100
millions de tonnes. Il si on continue
sur le graphique comme ils sont là, je
veux pas dire de bêtises, mais dans 15
20 ans, ils sont à 150 millions de
tonnes. La Russie,
imagine s'ils prennent l'Ukraine dans
son intégralité.
Je veux même pas en parler. Enfin bon,
voilà. En terme de pression géopolitique
compliqué la géopolitique
très forte aujourd'hui très forte les la
c'est malheureux hein mais
l'alimentation l'agriculture est une
place forte
des échanges des discours, des
géopolitiques. On peut serrer et fermer
le robinet et affamer quelqu'un
avec les robinets de gaz.
Voilà parce qu'en fait l'agriculture
c'est de la calorie totalement. Ouais,
mais c'est ça c'est enfin c'est c'est
voilà, on sousalimente ou on suralimente
bah les marchés les marchés étaient
forts. Euh fin arrivé juin, juillet, on
commençait à avoir une petite baisse sur
les marchés sur les marchés céréales et
euh
grosse récolte en Russie encore cette
année. Poutine annonce bah j'ai des
bateaux en trop, j'ai du blé en trop, je
vais envoyer gratuitement gratuitement
en Afrique des bateaux. Bon, il a mis du
temps quand même. Et puis ça mis du
temps. Quand ils sont partis, on les a
vu, hein.
Bah, le marché complètement en bas,
complètement en bas parce que envoyer
l'alimentation et nous on était plus en
terme de concurrence, il les envoient à
zéro. Donc, on a des pays qui sont
arrivés à côté, ils ont dit "Attends,
attends, attends, il les envoi à zéro."
Bah moi je vais vous allez moi je vais
vous les acheter quand même, mais vous
les acheter à 200 dollars, je vais vous
les acheter que 160. Bah non, non, non,
non. Bah regardez. Oh oh ! Un bateau
supplémentaire qui va gratuitement. Vous
êtes sûr ? parce que sinon j'appelle
Anton représentait rien du tout
Antonage ça reproduit rien. Sauf que
c'est c'est un message très fort hein.
C'est un message très fort quand on
commence à envoyer un ou deux bateau
gratuitement sur un pays. C'est un
message très fort. Ça veut dire les gars
j'ai tout ce qu'il faut. J'ai tout ce
qui va qui va bien. Vous allez voulu
vous avez voulu m'attaquer sur la
finance, regardez j'envoie gratuitement.
Vous m'attaquez sur agriculture,
regardez, j'envoie gratuitement.
Les répercussions de l'Ukraine, là on
voit les agriculteurs polonais qui râent
parce que le c'est pas les mêmes normes,
c'est pas le même prix.
les poulets qui sont pas élevés comme
chez nous, les œufs qui sont pas
produits comme chez nous, le blé qui est
pas produit comme chez nous et ça passe
s'il y a pas de taxe de bonière si j'ai
bien compris.
Ouais, tout à fait.
Est-ce que vous pouvez me développer un
peu ça
en en fait ? Ouais, sur l'Ukraine, bon,
ils sont ils sont pas dans l'Union
européenne, ça aura échappé à personne
évidemment. C'est
ils sont peut-être bientôt.
Ils seront peut-être bientôt. Bon,
voilà. En tout cas, nous
ça va être savoir quel impact qui rentre
dans l'Union européenne pour vous les
agriculteurs ?
Ouais, franchement, c'est une
catastrophe. Faut pas parce qu' en terme
de de en terme de production de standard
de production et de quantité de
production,
ils vont être obligés de se [__] avec
nos normes. Mais jamais de la vie. Ça
marche pas comme ça en Europe. Ça marche
comme ça à la télévision européenne mais
ça marche pas comme ça sur le territoire
européen. Les Espagnols ont pas le même
degré de norme pour l'utilisation des
phyosanitaires sur leurs légumes qu'en
France. Les Italiens sur ton coup là. Ah
ouais, cahier enfin le le il y a des
produits qui sont utilisés en
agriculture en Espagne pardon, qui sont
plus utilisés en France. Euh il y a un
truc la ferme des 1000 vaches en France,
ça ça n'existe pas. On en a fait un
totem. Moi, j'habite à 3h de l'Italie en
bagnole. vous descendez dans la plaine
du pot des fermes où il y a 4000 animaux
à l'engraissement, c'est les gens, ça
pose problème à personne. Donc les
mentalités sont différentes au sein des
pays et donc la la relation avec
l'agriculture déjà sur les pays qui font
partie de de la communauté européenne
sont pas tout à fait les mêmes. Je parle
même pas de la question sociale he du
SMIC du SMIC espagnol, du SMIC français
du enfin on est voilà et donc il y a
quand même cette question de distorsion
de concurrence qu'on dénonce nous au
sein de nos petits camarades de l'Union
européenne. Puis demain on fait rentrer
l'Ukraine, enfin il y a il y a un gars
qui fait du poulet en Ukraine, il pèse
un milliard d'euros à lui tout seul. Les
Bretons,
enfin on dit que c'est de l'élevage
industriel, il va falloir qu'il
s'énervent les cocos parce que je veux
dire l'autre s'il est ternu, c'est
poulet ils arrivent enfin je veux dire
c'est c'est c'est colossal. Et sur la
céréale c'est pareil. Je veux dire les
fermes ukrainiennes c'est 20000
hectares. Nous apparemment voilà quand
on a 700
Ouais. Le mec président de la FNSE avec
ses 700 hectares, je veux dire c'est un
Mické quoi. Bah oui c'est un Mické à
côté un Ukrainien qui en a 20000 et qui
embauche je sais pas quel quelle ethnie
pour conduire ses tracteurs. Enfin je
veux dire de quoi on parle ? Et c'est ça
qui nous pose problème quand on dit on
va faire rentrer l'Union enfin l'Ukraine
dans l'Union européenne. Moi j'ai pas de
problème avec les Ukrainiens. Je rav
super génial. On a besoin de plein de
monde et tout, mais avant ça, faut qu'on
harmonise faut qu'on harmonise en
Europe. Euh il y a, je disais voilà,
tout à l'heure la question des produits
phys, il y a il y a la question de de
l'interprétation ne serait-ce que du
cahier des charges bio. Il est pas
toujours interprété pareil par les
organismes certificateurs italiens,
espagnol ou français. Et ça crée de la
concurrence, ça crée de la défiance
quand on est tous là en plus à agiter la
peur parce qu'il y a des vrais enjeux.
Et ça ça nous rassure pas. Et c'est un
problème et et c'est un problème que je
je suis pas sûr que le fait de dire on
va faire rentrer l'Union l'Ukraine dans
l'Union européenne, je j'ai pas
l'impression que ça nous amène vers de
la sérénité.
Juste on met en perspective ce que je
disais tout à l'heure. Si on nous
déclare comme le parc du Yellowone là,
les Français en disant "Bah les gars, on
va faire venir nos touriste chez vous et
vous entretiendrez le paysage pour faire
ça." Après tout ma fois, si les
Ukrainiens ils ont 20000 hectares et
qu'ils font du poulet à trois balles sur
nos étales, donc c'est pas grave. De
toute façon, on sera le parc du Yostone
et on sera payé pour l'entretenir.
Non, mais il question de ça. Non,
le poulet le poulet de chez nous, le qui
va bien là,
le bon poulet du fermier du Gers.
Ouais. Ouais. ou même comment ça
s'appelle le poulet breton là 20 balles
le k
bon la belle rouge
ouais le poulet loué enfin le poulet
classique
loué c'est une marque
bon oui c'est vrai non bah le le le
poulet de bresse enfin on a des labelles
rouges sur du poulet il est bon moi
enfin je veux dire ma mère elle est
tiens ma mère elle est à confédération
paysane elle produit du poulet fermier
salut si lu
[__] j'en aurais pas ces dédicaces ce
soir
et et en fait elle fait un poulet bon
mais je veux dire c'est c'est moi je
peux pas manger un autre poulet depuis
que je suis né Je mange ce poulet là,
c'est un poulet fermier mais c'est un
poulet que
tu manges à 6 dessus quoi.
Alors on mange à 6 dessus pendant 3
jours parce que le poulet il va faire 2,
3 kg et que c'est un poulet qui a le
vend 18 balles du kilo mais parce que
son aliment il est fait à la ferme avec
des céréales qui sont récupérés 30 km
autour et parce qu'elle a une production
confidentielle c'est c'est moins de 1000
volailles par an et elle arrive à en
vivre. elle arrive à en vivre et et donc
en fait
moi je me dis comment quelqu'un qui a
qui mange ce poulet-là, qui achète ce
poulet-là, demain il va pouvoir manger
un poulet ukrainien plumé avec je sais
pas quel produit ou enfin je veux dire
c'est c'est le gap il est trop important
et et donc en fait ce qu'on dit c'est
moi je je je veux bien du peuple
ukrainien en Europe, il y a pas de
problème hein mais sur la production
agricole waouh nous on n'est pas prêt.
Nous, on n'est pas prêt parce que parce
qu'on on a 30 ans de politique, de
retard, de on n'est pas sur les mêmes
enjeux. Et c'est tout le sujet là qu'on
a avec aussi les traités
transatlantiques, les les traités de
commerce. Ouais. Mercour, le Chili,
la Nouvelle-Zélande, je le disais tout à
l'heure en fait, nos nos petits
camarades d'hier ne sont plus nos
collègues d'aujourd'hui.
C'est des ennemis.
Ah, je c'est pas à moi de répondre à la
question, c'est c'est c'est les
politiques qui peuvent y répondre. Moi,
je je me sens pas menacé directement par
la Russie ou par les Chinois, mais
en tout cas en tout cas ça redessine la
mondialisation, ça redessine le commerce
international et c'est pour ça qu'il
faut qu'on aille en Océanie, ben essayer
de vendre quelques sous-marins, quelques
trucs qui viennent de chez nous.
Ça marche pas ça.
Ouais, ils nous ont fait à l'envers. Pas
faux. Mais alors du coup, on va essayer
en Amérique du Sud. Peut-être que
ceux-là sont plus
fourguer des vieux porte-avions, je
crois.
Ouais, on a deux trois reliques à à
refourguer. Nous, ce qu'on dit, pourquoi
pas ? Il y a à tous à tous ça on a
refrogué à tous on a refoué quoi d'autre
?
Moi je trouve qu'en commerce
international techniqu technique
sur nos reliques on pas
c'est même pas qu'on s'est refourgué on
se les a fait piquer peut-être non
ouais je je souvent on les a
je je je pense que ouais on se les a
fait piquer on nous a vendu ça comme on
les avait refourgué mais enfin bon bref
chacun mettra le curseur où il veut mais
moi ce que je dis c'est que allons
vendre notre agriculture dans le monde
entier elle est enfin je veux dire moi
j'ai enfin le président dia qui fait du
du compté le compté il est dans Dou
il est dans le doux.
Où ça ? Dans le dou
euh à côté Besançon
à Tabier.
Non non non Bouclan.
À Bouclan
petit village.
C'est à côté de Mout ou non ?
Oh j'en sais rien. Je suis allé une
fois, j'ai dû me perdre là-bas. Et
parce que tu avais pas les yeux ouverts.
Ouais certainement. Et non c'est très
jol
s'il nous regarde je suis mort.
Le doux c'est très Non, il fait du
compté.
C'est c'est magnifique là. Le le doux
c'est magnifique. Ils ont une production
de fromage qui est extraordinaire, qui
est valorisée dans le monde entier.
Enfin, je je
on reparlera un peu pollution après. OK.
Oui, oui, oui, mais ça enfin mais mais
parce que c'est le vrai sujet avec le
commerce international. C'est aussi ce
qu'on dit hein. Je veux dire le on est
là nous dire "Ouais mais vos vaches
elles polluent. Enfin, les miennes elles
polluent parce que voilà, elle lâche du
m elle rumine pas assez ou je les
nourris pas assez bien et du coup elle
pollue trop.
Et en attendant, on fait traverser des
des bateaux réfrigérés qui eux bon bah
ils marchent au croue he ! Le crude
c'est du pétrole non raffiné. Donc tu
mets une vache morte dedans, il digère
pareil le bateau hein, il avance avec
quoi. Et et en fait c'est vraiment
absolument dégueulasse mais ça pose de
problème à personne parce que ça fait de
la enfin je caricature un peu mais faut
que chacun prenne conscience que cette
alimentation là vraiment elle est elle
est toxique pour pour eux quand il la
bouffe et pour la planète.
Quelle quelle alimentation ?
Celle qui traverse les océans dans un
porte container qui qui se gave au
passage de de dollars pollue aussi.
Voilà, je veux dire il marche au cou.
Moi, j'ai mangé du du de je vais me
faire frapper par les les gens du Mont
Saint-Michel, mais j'ai j'ai mangé de
l'agneau de de de
Donc le le bon Saint-Michel est en
Bretagne, donc le le est pas en
Normandie.
Merci.
On va se faire fracasser pour les
On les embrasse. J'ai mangé du du
mouton de Nouvelle-Zélande. Je suis pas
mort, hein. Bon, c'était surgelé. Oui,
c'était pas cher.
C'était pas cher et et et je sais il
était moins bon que celui de du
monichel.
Voilà. Et et non mais mais au-delà de la
qualité gustative en fait, c'est que
enfin
c'est la méthode.
C'est la méthode. Et puis je veux dire
quand on a un label rouge en France, je
veux dire dans l'agneau, il y a de
l'agneau. Point c'est de l'agneau, c'est
de la viande.
Tu m'autorises à à te couper
ou à vous couper si tu voulais prendre
la parole.
Comment on fait pour nourrir les pauvres
? Quand comment on vous quand on voit
une inflation dingue, quand on voit que
80 % de la population, je demande à me
faire un fa checker, 80 % de la
population gagne autour de 2200 balles.
Là, ils viennent se taper 20 % et des
patates d'inflation sur la bouffe.
Il y en a qui perdent leur boulot.
Alors, on veut nous faire croire queil
faut traverser la rue pour choper
n'importe quoi comme taf, ça va bien se
passer. Comment on fait pour nourrir les
pauvres ? Et ben déjà, on demande pas à
ceux qui gagnent 1000 balles qui font la
production alimentaire de ce pays de
d'être la variable d'ajustement. On sort
les doigts euh des poches et on va au
travail pour pouvoir euh ben être en
responsabilité, redonner du pouvoir
d'achat. Enfin, je veux dire, on peut
pas être la variable d'ajustement de
tout ça. Et le le le problème, il est à
l'envers. Le problème en fait, il est à
l'envers. C'est qu'on demande à nous
agriculteur de produire mieux, pas cher
pour nourrir une population qui est sur
les revenus de moins en moins élevés et
où bah aujourd'hui
tape de plus en plus dans le budget
alimentaire. Les Français là hein,
clairement, c'est tout ce qui est pas
nécessaire. En fait, il y a un problème.
Je pense qu'il faut tout reposer là et
ça serait bien qu'un jour il y ait
là-haut que ça non mais un éclair de
lucidité là. Bah un éclair de lucidité,
on dit bah tiens, et si le consommateur
au lieu de toucher 2200 € de moyenne,
toucher 3 ou 3500 € de moyenne en
France, il pourrait peut-être se
permettre d'acheter des produits
convenables à un éleveur, convenable à
un marécher, enfin de et de se faire
plaisir avec de la bonne alimentation.
Aujourd'hui, en fait, on est plutôt en
train de dire "Wou, le consommateur,
c'est compliqué. Bon, alors attends, je
vais signer avec le mercure. Je vais te
faire venir 10000 vaches élevées dans un
parc où il y a pas un brin d'herbe
nourri à l'alimentation. Interdite en
interdite en France interdite dans
l'Union européenne qui s'appelle la
farine animale. Farine animale
aujourd'hui hein on s partir de la vache
folle. Farine animal pas de problème.
Farine animale. Farine animale sur
France vachefolle. Vachefol dans les
années.
Prion prion pronon à cause du prion.
Oui, à cause du prion. Mais bah on était
arrivé où on s'est dit stop là faut
arrêter l'histoire un petit peu quand
même. On va donner à manger à des vaches
de l'alimentation qui bon bref on passe
sur du cannibalisme l'histoire donc et
nous on va continuer à importer ça.
Alors en fait sur qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que c'est ces traités vraiment
de Mercosure ? On en importe déjà, il y
a pas de problème. C'est juste qu'il y a
des frais de douanes là. Aujourd'hui, on
va signer un traité Mercosur ou
Nouvelle-Zélande ou quoi que ce soit. Tu
es vraiment sûr de ton coup avec les
farines animales hein ?
Ah oui, farine animale.
Farine animale sur le mercure. Brésil,
Brésil, Paraguay, Argentine. C'est quoi
ta source ?
Ah bah source c'est l'agriculture USDA,
fabrication alimentation
euh euh du sud. Pas parler sur les
États-Unis, aller peut-être sauter sur
les États Productur de vache. Là, il dit
quoi ?
Ouais, j'en sais rien. Moi, je regarde
pas ce qu'ils font ailleurs parce que de
toute façon, ils font de la merde. C'est
moi le meilleur producteur. Non mais je
veux dire,
tu es français toi ? Non.
Ouais, exactement. Ouais, je suis un peu
chaud.
Quentin.
Mais non mais aujourd'hui en fait voilà
c'est là le truc c'est que on va dire
bah l'agriculture ça coûte cher, on
narrive pas à produire narrive pas à
produire pas cher pour un consommateur
qui n'a pas de revenu. Donc du coup on
va importer des choses qui respectent
plus du tout les critères et le cahier
des charges français. On va faire venir
bah ce qu'on dit la merde.
Bah non en fait moi le problème il est
pas là. Le problème c'est qu'il faut
ramener du budget partout chez tout le
monde. Il faudrait que tout le monde
puisse se dire cool, j'ai du revenu, je
suis bien, je suis aisé, je
du gros père Noël.
Ah ben j'aimerais bien y croire.
J'aimerais bien y croire. Sauf que quand
on dit à au gouvernement et à l'État
s'il vous plaît aider l'agriculteur pour
ramener un revenu en fait c'est nous
mais c'est consommateurs aussi he qu'on
parle he les les manifes et tout ce que
vous avez vu. C'est pas uniquement
agricole he c'est consommateur
agriculteur. Je suis consommateur hein.
Moi je veux du revenu sur mon
exploitation c'est pour pouvoir manger
aussi. Moi, je me retrouve maintenant
agriculteur à aller faire les courses,
non plus dans une grande surface de
grandes marques, mais peut-être à me
dire tiens, je vais peut-être plutôt me
rapprocher de Lidl et puis d'une autre
marque
ou d'une autre marque mais du sur du pas
trop cher et puis de prendre de la
marque de distributeur pas trop cher
truc bien chez Lidle quand même.
Mais bien sûr qu'il y a des trucs bien,
je pas de problème et puis avec des
bonnes marques qui respectent des
critères des cahers des charges français
ou qui prend du français. Mais je vais
essayer de faire ça et de temps en
temps, je vais me faire un petit
plaisir. Je vais prendre de la viande.
La viande, moi sur sur euh aujourd'hui,
on a réduit quasiment de 50 60 %. Moi
dans la maison, j'en on en on en achète
moins à à 17 ou 18 € euh le kilo de
steak haché euh en grande surface.
Attends, chez nous, c'est plus cher.
Oui, parce que moi je suis à 60 km de
Paris mais je Et puis on va juste sur
les applications de drive hein. Moi
j'aime bien temps en temps, je vais sur
les applications drive, je me prends un
blade complètement paumé dans du dans le
centre de la France. Oh ! Et puis le
kilo de steak haché, je vais le trouver
à 14 € donc même un peu moins cher en
même temps.
Combien de martères grasse dans ton
steak haché à 14 € ?
Euh là, je vais chercher sur du 5 %.
J'ai une femme qui qui essaie de de bien
manger et qui veut pas trop de matière
grasse. Donc du coup, de temps en temps,
j'y dis rien. Mais j'espère qu'elle me
regarde pas. J' Pourquoi tuappelles pas
ton pote qui produit de la vache et qui
te dit voilà je te fais un colifrais et
je t'envoie mon kilo à 15 balles le kilo
parce que moi, je me fait livrer de la
de la barbque d'un petit producteur qui
a ses vaches qui sont que sur de
l'herbe. Il s'est mis dans son petit
syndic syndicat de producteur de vache
et il me fait pas trop trop vachement
moins cher et j'ai des beaux morceaux.
J'ai j'ai de quoi si je veux congeler un
peu, si je veux faire mon bourguignon.
Bon, certes, il y a un peu trop de
plastique pour me pour moi parce que
c'est tout sousvide,
mais mais
j'ai de la qualité pour le coup. C'est
exactement ce que je fais. Je fais de la
vente directe, donc sous vide, dans
carton, livré et tout. J'ai arrêté.
J'ai arrêté parce qu'en fait Ouais, la
rémunération, j'y suis plus. J'y suis
plus en fait. Le truc c'est que mon coût
de de d'emballage, mon coût de de de
rémunération des des gars qui
transforment à prestation de service,
elle a triplé. Et donc en fait mon
en combien de temps ? Oh bah là, depuis
la sortie Covid, sortie Covid, enfin
guerre en Ukraine, euh l'inflation que
tout le monde connaît là. Voilà.
Et donc en fait au bout d'un moment, je
me suis dit "Mais attends moi, enfin la
le gasoile livraison, amener ma bête à à
l'abattoir, je veux dire voilà, c'est du
temps c'est machin
et et du coup bah mon kilo de de viande
que je livrais chez les gens à 17 18 €
en bio euh avec tous les beaux morceaux
hein parce que c'est un beau colis 10 kg
les les filet,
il y a du filet, il y a de la bascou,
il y a Ouais, pour les pour les
privilégiés. les intimes ils ont la joue
euh mais voilà mais sinon euh sinon
voilà et ben j'y arrive plus. Je suis
obligé de vendre enfin je suis obligé
euh le prix de la la vache en circuit
long à remonter, le prix du bovin a
remonté et donc aujourd'hui j'ai plus
intérêt à vendre mon mon ma production
ma vache au à la coopérative ou au
Maquignon pour moi je je suis un peu
antiaquignon. C'est un système un peu
archaïque mais en tout cas à la
coopérative euh pour pouvoir voilà et en
fait je valorise mieux mes vaches comme
ça que de les vendre directement au au
consommateur. Moi au bout ça ça ça
m'embête parce que je trouvais que le
truc était plutôt sympathique. Dire les
gens ils voyaient ils voyaient ils
voyaient leur enfin les vaches ils
venaient il passaient à la ferme machin
et tout on vendait les vaches.
Ouais je vais te manger
et ouais voilà. Bah oui, c'est c'est le
cycle de la vie quoi. Et et et puis en
même temps ça avait aussi les
consommateurs ou avait les
consommateurs, il y avait une relation
retour sur le produit. Enfin, c'est
super gratifiant quand tu es
agriculteur, on dit bah là tu es bien oh
là c'était pas terrible, faut que tu me
fasses ça. Et et voilà, aujourd'hui je
le fais plus. Aujourd'hui, je vais
chercher parce que voilà la dimension
économique, moi j'ai ma boutique à faire
tourner. J'ai dit qu'il y avait certain
nombre de
fallu vendre plus cher en face de ça. Le
consommateur, bah il y a des endroits
Oui, moi les caissettes j'en ai acheté.
J'en ai acheté. J'ai des éleveurs aussi
à côté du Yveline, il doit rester alors
je veux pas citer de source ou quoi que
ce soit mais il doit peut-être rester
trois ou quatre éleveurs qui pour le
coup font font essayent de faire de la
caissette. Euh le truc c'est bon bah
dans ce tu reçois le message ces
cissettes là dans une semaine. Ah ouais
ok. Bon attends il y a pour 175 € de la
caissette et tout le truc. Euh bon c'est
super.
20 kg ? 20 kg ? Non plus.
Ah je suis sur du 10 15 kg là. 10 15 kg.
Bon bah tu vas payer ton bon ok voilà tu
tu es content. tu as un bout de morceau.
Bon bah nous on a plutôt fait le choix
de dire bah on va diminuer un petit peu
la consommation de viande. Bah le jambon
ça va bien. On va acheter de la
barquette de jambon ça ça va bien. Le le
petit il est content. Un peu de steak
haché. Un ou deux morceaux de tournoo
dans l'année parce qu'on adore ça dans
le mois je veux dire parce qu'on adore
ça. Alors des fois on sont dit non et
puis bah on est plutôt à se dire bah dès
qu'on a réussi un peu de côté les
enfants sont pas là ils sont à l'école.
Bon ben ce midi on se fait un bon petit
resto sur le bistro du coin qui achète
chez les producteurs locaux et qui fait
jouer tout le monde.
Tes enfants vont te regarder là
et là oui bah
profitez bien de l'école pendant ce
temps là papa il va manger un petit
resto un bon plaisir une bonne fois pour
toutes et voilà là au moins ça est là
enfin mais on peut parler de tout moi je
je très frayant de cinéma ben cinéma
déjà on a eu les enfants voilà donc ça a
calmé et puis le fait aujourd'hui stop
quoi. Oui, non, on peut pas, je peux
plus. On fait des choix. On fait des
choix. Donc, on essaie de réduire
différentes choses. On réduit un peu
d'alimentation, réduit un petit peu de
loisir. Ça fait un an et demi que je
suis pas parti en vacances. Mes
dernières vacances, c'était en weekend
chez lui cet été. Il m'a accueilli sur
chez lui. On a pu on a pu manger de la
viande et et déguster des produits
locaux plus ou moins liquides. Et euh on
a bien profité et voilà. Ça c'est mais
ça c'est un petit plaisir et ça
fonctionne très bien.
Quelle est la partie de l'agriculture
française qui souffre le plus selon vous
? C'est l'éleveur en montagne qui essae
de faire conserver des des races qui
vont bien ? le petit maréché canchi.
Qu'est-ce qui pour le coup, j'ai
l'impression que c'est un peu universel
à toutes les filières et j'ai
l'impression que
il y a il y a des gars dans chaque
filière qui vont être capables de
générer de la valeur avec pas beaucoup
et qui vont s'en sortir et puis il y en
a pour qui ben c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué.
Je le je le disais là tout à l'heure,
c'est le côté chef d'entreprise he mine
de rien. Bah il y a des fois quand les
planètes elles s'alignent pas, ça veut
pas et et puis puis c'est dur quoi. Et
donc tu c'est là que tu ça décanille. Il
y a il y a il y a des il y a des
secteurs qui sont vraiment en
difficulté. La viticulture française
pourtant on disait la viticulture
singrale. Enfin production de valeur
ajoutée et tout machin. Là les mecs il
dégustent. Eux eux c'est beaucoup dû.
Enfin il y a il y a deux facteurs
identifiés principaux je dirais. la
baisse de consommation. Euh bon, ça fait
un petit moment, ça fait depuis 56 qu'on
arrêtait l'alcool à la cantine, enfin le
vin à la cantine, donc ça voilà. Mais la
baisse de consommation de vin en France,
elle baisse. Voilà, c'est remplacé
bière, enfin voilà,
des trucs moins chers.
Des trucs moins chers, des trucs moins
chers. Pour notre génération, moi le le
vin rouge, le vin blanc, c'est associé
au repas de famille le dimanche. C'est
pas forcément l'alcool que je bois à la
maison. Voilà, je je suis pas un poivre
qui boit voilà qui boit à la maison,
mais je veux dire si j'ai un alcool à
consommer, je veux dire ben voilà en
famille, entre amis, c'est plutôt bien
consommer avec modération.
À consommer avec modération évidemment.
Euh et donc euh le vin rouge, il est
enfin le vin dans sa globalité, il est
soumis à donc à cette baisse de
production et au réchauffement
climatique. La vigne dans le sud enfin
c'est c'est la galère. Je veux dire, ça
prend du soleil, c'est des degrés
d'alcool en pagaille. Tu ils arrivent
plus à faire du du du bon vin. On
préfère de la poudre à canon. Non.
On peut faire du gel hydroalcoolique
avec le binard, on en a fait. On peut
faire marcher les voitures, ça
fonctionne aussi,
mais les viticulteurs, il ça enfin ils
se lèvent pas le matin pour faire de du
gel hydroalcoolique ou ou de l'alcool,
enfin ou l'essence pour la voiture.
Eux voilà, c'est c'est et et là on est
dans une crise, les viticulteurs, ils
sont vraiment dans dans la difficulté
par rapport à ça. Il y a des bcins qui
s'en sortent mieux que d'autres. le
champenois est pas tout à fait confronté
au même problème que la Gironde. Euh
voilà, encore une fois, c'est c'est des
produits qu'on est capable d'aller
valoriser sur historiquement à
l'étranger
et à l'export. Je je vous donne deux
trois sujets qu'on va aborder là.
L'Europe, le réchauffement climatique,
les bassines.
Oui.
On commence par quoi ? Quentin, tu
choisis.
Fais-toi plaisir. On part sur les
bassines.
Allez bassine.
Allez. Et ben bassine, qu'est-ce que tu
veux ? Qu'est-ce que tu veux savoir sur
les bassines ? Bines pour vous, c'est
les bassines pour vous c'est bien, c'est
pas bien ? C'est la privatisation de la
flotte pour des gros agriculteurs ?
C'est c'est quoi
alors sur les bassines ?
C'est un truc qui va s'évaporer, ça va
être de l'eau qui va être en contact
avec des plastiques. Qu'est-ce que c'est
?
Tu vois sur sur les bassines, moi j'aime
bien j'aime bien on vient on vient me
chercher un petit peu en ce moment pas
mal euh parce que on a été les chercher
fort cet été, tous nos opposants. Puis
là aujourd'hui, je leur dis "Qu'est-ce
qu'on fait ? Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?" On
a vu tout ce qui est tombé.
C'est qui vos opposants ? On va parteler
certains groupes très écologistes ou
anti antifito environ très environ
discuter avec eux.
Oui bien sûr bien sûr qu'on arrive à
discuter.
Ah bah quand on a le salon, on va les
croiser. Salon de l'agriculture, on va
les croiser. On va pouvoir tenir la
parole pendant une petite heure. De
temps en temps, on est auditionné ou
questionné sur une question
environnement s'ils sont là on arrive à
échanger ou avoir un truc. Euh dernière
dernière en date, c'était sur une
interview euh post interview média là
pendant les mobilisations, je suis
sorti, on a croisé et on a discuter un
peu houlement, un peu
un peu fort et ben parce qu'on avait pas
du tout la même vision sur les
rétentions d'eau, sur les ce qu'on
appelle les bassines ou les méga
bassines parce qu'en fait, j'ai posé la
question "OK, d'accord, qu'est-ce que
vous proposez vous
Moi, j'ai envie de dire à certains OK,
d'accord, c'est peut-être pas pour moi,
c'est même c'est même clair, c'est pas
le c'est pas les bassines qui vont
révolutionner l'agriculture de demain.
Faut pas croire qu'on va faire des
bassines partout et que ça va
révolutionner.
Est-ce que ça ralentit l'adaptation les
bassines ?
C'est même pas une idée d'adaptation.
C'est enfin c'est pas ralentir, c'est
aujourd'hui pour cultiver les plantes,
arbres, vignales et cetera, faut de
l'eau. Pas tortiller, faut de l'eau.
Donc comment on va aller chercher cette
eau là ? Faut combien de litres de
flotte pour faire un kil de barbac ? Ah
là en je sais pas sur sur la barbque, je
sais pas sûr. Attion attention je veux
où vous emmener attention parce qu'il y
a plusieurs eau. Il y a l'eau qui tombe,
il y a celle qu'on va chercher dans les
nappes, il y a celle qu'on utilise après
pour viande, abattage et cetera sur le
nettoyage eau chloré du voilà donc il
faut tout reprendre en perspective. Moi
moi je suis capable de dire combien moi
ma vache par jour après la boit. Ouais
elle quand elle elles sont à 50 L par
jour.
Et c'est de l'eau du robinet.
Ah non c'est de l'eau c'est de l'eau de
pluie. Ouais, c'est de l'eau depuis que
je récupère. Et si c'est la question,
c'est savoir si c'est environnemental ou
pas, c'est économique
et c'est autorisé de faire tes vaches
avec de l'eau de plu qui passe.
Une question que je me suis posé, je
suis allé voir le véto, il m'a dit il
faut rajouter des minéraux dedans parce
qu'elle est souvent déminéralisé ou
carencié ça et
peut-être que j'aurai un contrôle du
coup après, c'est pas grave.
Sur sur sur les bassines. Oui. Moi ce
que je ce que je pose à certains, c'est
qu'est-ce que quelle solution on peut
avoir aujourd'hui ? Il y en a qui me dit
il faut changer tout modèle 100 % de
permaculture, faut installer partout,
faut mettre 1 million d'eux
d'agriculteurs partout sur France et OK,
ça marche mais quel revenu aujourd'hui
il y a pas de il y a pas de pépette.
Comment comment on peut intéresser un
jeune lui dire e viens jeune viens
t'installer
viens pauvre avec moi.
Ah bah je vois très bien les jeunes
arriver avec son balluchon. Ah super wou
quel avenir. Donc non aujourd'hui on est
plutôt en train de dire bon bah là il y
a un problème agricole qui est là, il y
a un souci d'eau. Comment on va le
palier ? Amélioration de l'irrigation.
Il y en a sur l'irrigation d'aspersion à
plein. Est-ce qu'on peut pas essayer de
faire du goutte à goutte ? Donc là,
c'est des tuyaux enterrés sur les arbres
ou dans les vignes ou quoi que ce soit.
d'essayer un goutte à goutte moins
consommateur d'eau. Nafréatique, pompage
napfraatique dans certains coins,
rétention d'eau, rétention d'eau sur
l'eau qui tombe. Et puis on a aussi les
nappes, il y a il y a plusieurs types d'
de nappes. On a les nappes vraiment
souterraines, les nappes de surface qui
bah on va prendre là le cas des
charantes hein, 450 500 mm qui est tombé
autour du partir du 15 18 octobre
jusqu'au 1er janvier. Là, ils se sont
retrouvés sous l'eau, sous l'eau, sous
l'eau. Il y a des nappes qui ont vite
bah qui ont vite projeté, qui ont vite
été à niveau. Bah pourquoi on n pas pris
cette eau-là pour la mettre dans une
bassine alors que du coup, on l'a
regardé partir ? Je vais prendre
l'exemple là de la scène. Il pleut, tout
est tout est béton sur Paris, tout est
goudron, tout est impeccable. Il pleut,
tout va dans la scène, la scène ça file
tout droit et puis ça la retrouve après
nous l'été quand on fait nos vacances
là, on la voit arriver à l'embouchure.
Ça y est, elle est arrivée là. Bah tu la
sens la poudre de plaquette de frein
parisienne ?
Ben voilà, mais on on peut pas essayer
de se dire bah éventuellement cette eau
là, on pourrait peut-être en capter 15
20 % de l'eau qui tombe sur Paris. Elle
tombe là, on la met sur des bassines.
Madame Dallalgo si si elle nous regarde
peut-être se dire tiens, on va financer
des bassines pour les agriculteurs. Se
dire bah on va leur financer, on va leur
mettre de l'eau dedans. Comme ça, au
lieu qu'ils aillent pomper sur des
nappes fréatiques autour de Paris qui
sertent en plus à boire dans nos
robinets, et ben on va plutôt aller
chercher cette eau là.
pour la mettre, j'en sais rien, sur des
grandes cultures, sur maréchage ou quoi
que ce soit. Enfin, je pense qu'il y a
des solutions aujourd'hui qui existent
et et quand ça part sur les discussions,
on va faire des bassines, ouais mais ça
capte l'eau et il les mecs, ils la
mettent en extérieur et puis ça évapore
ça. Bon, enfin, il y a un moment c'est
c'est quoi la solution ? Moi je veux
bien. OK, mais on se pose autour d'une
table.
Aux États-Unis, met des espèces de
petites bibilles au-dessus de
Ouais, les billes en plastique. Ouais.
Bon, je sais pas. En terme
d'environnement, j'ai pas étudié trop le
sujet sur les
transferts de de contenu plastique. Il y
a pas peut-être des falates là ?
Bah, il y a peut-être sûrement des trucs
qui doivent se on avait regardé, j'avais
vu une bassine où dessus ils avaient mis
les panneaux photovoltaïques. Panneaux
photovoltaïques qui pouvaient avec la
pluie, les vents, la nuit qui pouvaient
s'incliner de manière à bien laisser
rentrer l'eau et puis ensuite qui
arrivait à se remettre. Bah juste ça,
une zone hein, bah c'est tout de suite
un certain pourcentage d'évaporation en
moins. Donc c'est plein de petites
solutions aujourd'hui qui pourraient que
ça soit plus efficace. Et les les
discussions houleuses que désolé tu
coupé les discussions houleuses que tu
tu as pu avoir, pourquoi c'est monté en
pression ?
Pourquoi c'est monté en pression ? Parce
qu'en face c'est vide. Je suis désolé.
En face
non non
non en face je te jure il y en a il y a
aucune proposition. On nous tape dessus
et je suis là et je dis OK c'est quoi ?
Qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous me
proposez ? Qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
pour améliorer le système ? OK, vous
voulez pas de bassine, on en fait pas.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait d'autre ? Qu'est-ce
qu'on propose ? Et là, là c'est vide.
Là, c'est vide. Ou alors on va venir me
dire "Ouais, faut arrêter le maïs." OK,
on arrête le maïs, pas de problème.
Allez, on retire le maïs.
Tu fais du sorgot un peu.
Je fais un peu de sorgot. Ouais, j'en ai
fait 2 ans, j'ai arrêté. Catastrophe.
Bah parce que le
toute plante a besoin d'eau. Moi, j'ai
fait du sorgot. Je fais un peu de maïs
cette année. J'ai fait 10 hectares de
maïs sans sans sans irrigation. de
continuer. Excuse-moi.
J'ai Non mais pour pour te dire, on
essae on essaye des choses sauf qu'en
face c'est des beaucoup de petits
marchés de niche. Le sorgot, on s'est
dit on va faire du sorgot. D'un ce coup,
moi j'ai plein de voisins autour qu'on
fait du sorgot. C'était un contrat avec
une waisellerie pour pour mettre pour
les nourritures d'oiseaux, les petits
cages ou on a plombé le marché. On a
plombé le marché en 2 ans. Là, ils nous
ont dit "Ah bah on sait pas trop ce
qu'on va en faire. Euh bah tu vas
l'emmener à Rand, on va essayer de te
trouver un bateau et puis on va
l'exporter je sais pas où. Par contre,
je te le dis tout de suite hein, c'est
20 ou 30 € de moins. OK, super. Bon bah
déjà, j'ai fait des mauvais rendements.
En plus bah il aurait fallu un peu
d'eau. C'est J'ai fait du sorgo euh
année 21 et année 22. 22 rec can
caganière chez moi. Le sorgo, j'ai fait
3 tonnes de sorgo à l'hectare. Quand
quand j'ai acheté la semence, on m'a dit
"Oh, tu as des terre, on va sortir 8 9
tonnes." Ah 8 9 tonnes, cool, super, je
vais le vendre 200 €. J'ai fait 3
tonnes, vendu 180. Super. Bon ben, j'ai
perdu hein là, j'ai perdu l'argent. Donc
j'ai dit Sorgo merci. Au revoir.
Revenons au aux discussions avec ceux
qui sont pas d'accord avec les bassines.
Donc quand tu leur demandes des choses
opérationnelles de terrain opératif, il
y a des propositions en face ou pas ?
Bah les propositions, ce que je te
disais, voilà, on retire c'est
faire des petites exploitations, laisser
le cycle de l'eau, c'est c'est laisser
les tranquilles.
Oui. Oui. Oui. Tout en permet qu'un. Je
veux bien l'entendre ça aussi mais
j'ai je veux bien mais faire pousser des
pommes de terre sans eau, j'ai jamais
vu. Faire pousser des salade sans eau,
j'ai jamais vu. Du radis sans eau, j'ai
jamais vu. OK, ça marche, pas de
problème. Quels sont et c'est pour ça
que je dis pas que les bassines c'est la
solution miracle, mais pour moi c'est
une des solutions parmi plein de petites
choses. Amélioration de l'irrigation,
captage captage de d'une eau comme ça,
amélioration des types de production. Tu
vois, on parle de l'agriculture
conservation. Je te disais avec
l'agriculture conservation, je vais
garder un tout petit peu plus d'humilité
en période de gros cagnard, je vais
gagner de tr jours. Mais c'est de tr
jours, c'est un petit truc. Et en plus à
côté de ça, bah tiens, je me lance dans
un système arbo. Bah au lieu de faire
soit de l' arboréicole, soit au lieu de
faire l'aspersion à plein ou quoi que ce
soit, bah je vais plutôt essayer soit un
goutte à goutte, arroser la nuit. au
lieu d'arroser en pleine journée, en
plein cagnard sur un canon avec du vent
des fois mal réglé qui tombe sur la
route, bon bah on va plutôt arroser la
nuit, essayer. Et en fait, c'est plein
de petites choses comme ça et c'est là
qu'on leur demande "Venez plutôt nous
aider, venez réfléchir à des nouveaux à
des nouveautés qu'on pourrait essayer
améliorer." Et là,
ça plante un peu là des fois.
Et quand ça devient violent, quand il y
a des des des choses qui sont dégradées,
vous ça vous fait quoi ?
Ça fait mal.
Ça fait mal. Bah ouais, ça fait mal
parce que en fait au bout du bout, on
fait tous le même métier, on défend la
même chose, c'est produire. C'est juste
que voilà, à un moment donné, il faut
arrêter. Enfin, moi je on n'est pas là
pour détruire le truc du voisin si ça
nous plaît pas. Enfin, moi je suis je
suis des fois pas toujours d'accord avec
ce qui se fait autour de moi. Je vais
pas aller cramer le truc parce qu'en
fait ça me plaît pas ça, je crame. Et
c'est ça en fait qu'on dénonce c'est la
violence. Enfin, je veux dire, c'est
c'est insupportable. Ou ou alors ça veut
dire que bon, il y a plus d'état de
droit et à ce moment-là bon ben il y a
un me derrière quand même hein. Il y a
un mec qui s'est endetté. Il y a il y a
il y a il y a quelqu'un ou deux trois
agriculteurs qui sont venus qui sont dit
"Bah tiens, ça te dit on essaie de créer
quelque chose ici, on va faire une
bassine. PL allez hop, ils ont mis ils
ont mis le pay l'argent là et puis
derrière ça se retrouve dégradé ou ça se
retrouve interdit ou ça se retrouve où
ils sont hués. C'est les familles, c'est
la vie sociale, c'est tout qui en prend
un coup. Enfin, ça fait mal pour
certains.
C'est pour ça que vous quand vous avez
essayé de créer un éclair de lucidité
dans les gens qui nous dirigent par
rapport au aux malettes de votre
profession, vous avez vous avez évité de
tout cramer en montant à Paris parce que
nous nous on vous a regardé ça ça
faisait penser un peu à Wagner qui qui
montait à la capitale quand même.
Ouais, c'est c'est c'est l'effet de
style. Ouais, c'est l'effet de style. Et
puis au dernier moment, on plaque nos
nos contrepoids de tracteur sur les
blindés et ou ou on se met en mode
viking quoi. Mais parce que voilà, c'est
c'est comme ça aussi les mobilisations
que ça se mène. En revanche, enfin, je
veux dire appeler à tout cramer parce
que ça nous plaît pas, ça veut dire quoi
? C'està dire que le prochain à qui
s'app
Vous étiez prêt à le faire quand j'ai vu
des ballots de paille sous les ponts,
quand j'ai vu des aéroports pris,
quand j'ai vu des autoroutes prises,
quand j'ai vu des ballots de paille sur
les les voies ferrées, quand j'ai vu
monter à la capitale, taper sur la
chaîne logistique. Attends Quentin,
quand j'ai vu tout ça, c'était qualité
militaire les gars.
Ouais, ouais, ouais. Sur sur les
dégradation,
prendre les ponts, les voies ferrées,
les autoroutes.
Ouais. Qui qui paye à la fin les
dégradations ?
Ah bah c'est nous.
Bon bah voilà, en fait
donc il y a aucun intérêt à tout péter.
Il y a aucun intérêt à tout péter et et
les messages passent pas mieux parce
qu'on a tout pété. Moi je veux dire euh
enfin je sais pas si si mon si mon gamin
il tape une crise de ner qui jette son
jouet par terre parce qu'il est pas
content qu'il le casse, je je suis pas
sûr que si je lui hle dessus en lui
mettant une branlé, ça passe mieux que
si je lui explique que je m'accroupis en
lui disant ça écoute faut plus le faire
parce que voilà et là
après il a un crédit tu sais.
Oui voilà et je me dis est-ce que ça
fonctionne pareil avec le le
gouvernement ou moins les dirigeants ?
J'ai l'impression que oui parce que
derrière les gens, la majorité des gens,
ils sont quand même enfin voilà, plutôt
intelligents, plutôt sensibles au
respect du bien public. Ils disent "Bon
ben OK, les agriculteurs ils sont pas
contents, ils manifestent mais on va pas
tout péter sous l'hôtel de on n peut
plus, on souffre." Il y en a des
énervés. Il y en a des énervés et notre
rôle à nous,
il y a des gens qui sont à bout.
Il y a des gens qui sont à bout. Mais je
veux dire, on c'est toujours pareil où
on met le curseur et et moi j'ai pas le
même enfin je supporterai pas la même
pression que un autre qu'un voisin ou
quoi. Et nous notre rôle aussi de
syndicat c'est de pouvoir accompagner
cette colère mais comme il faut et et de
dire au mec qui est vraiment à bout mais
qui dit "Mais vraiment vous êtes des
nuls, vous arrivez pas à négocier quoi
que ce soit pour nous au national et et
à quoi ça sert qu'on adhère au syndicat
Bah, ça c'est à nous de transformer euh
ce que va dire les les avancées du
gouvernement, les annonces du
gouvernement pour pour canaliser ça. Et
et je peux entendre un juste titre que
ça correspond pas à tout le monde et et
que ces gens qui sont à bout ont
vraiment envie d'en découdre parce que
c'est de ça qu'on parle hein au bout là.
C'est de ça qu'on parle, c'est les gens,
ils veulent aller au enfin ils veulent
aller au contact, ils veulent aller au
conflit parce qu'ils sont au bout et
qu'ils ont pour certains plus rien à
perdre.
Ils ont la mort aux fesses, aux
trousses.
Ouais. Ils sentent la Ouais. Ouais. Ils
sentent ils sentent la mort. ils sentent
le enfin ils sentent le bout du bout du
processus et ça ça leur est
insupportable, ça je peux le comprendre.
Et voilà. et et nous derrière, il faut
qu'on essaie d'harmoniser ça
dans dans un mouvement, dans un truc
massif, un rapport de force pour pour
voilà et et c'est pas évident mais
voilà, je pense que c'est aussi
important de pouvoir manifester comme ça
encore dans ce pays parce qu'on a un
rapport aussi particulier avec les
manifestations en France notamment
agricole hein, je veux dire caractère
violent pendant voilà la Révolution
française qui est partie de de loin et
qui est arrivé tout en haut et
tu es plutôt Mara ou tu es plutôt
Robespierre
Joker, c'est contentire.
Non, mais je je pense que voilà, il y a
de ça aussi qui qui qui coule dans l'ADN
des agriculteurs,
les Français tout court
et les Français tout courts. Et et donc
voilà, il y a il y a aussi cette
responsabilité là et et moi j'ai
l'impression que de vouloir faire la
révolution, c'est très bien. Ça se
prépare
ou où c'est tu avais l'impression
Non non, ils ont écouté un moment, ils
ont pas entendu parce que s'ils avaient
entendu ou alors ils sont vraiment
incompétents et là c'est inquiétant.
Mais si s'il nous avait entendu, je
pense que là il s'affolerait un peu.
Mais là je je sais pas, ils sont
rendez-vous. On va voir. Ça ça bouge. On
a le salon d'agriculture, ils vont tous
venir. Vous ont proposé un poste ?
Non, un poste de
un petit back, un petit petite petite
amélioration.
Vous avez eu un contrôle fiscal ?
Non plus. Non, pas pour l'instant.
Vous avez été menacé d'un contrôle
fiscal ?
Non.
Vous avez un bon expert comptable.
Je jeouais.
Oui,
j'y donne 4000. Oui. Oui.
J'y donne 4000 €. 4500 € à l'année. Donc
ouais,
te plains pas hein.
Ouais bah ou j'ai pas envie de me
plaindre mais bon quand même. Non non
non non mais aujourd'hui écoutez je
Ouais quand on y allait avec les
revendications en fait comment ça a
fonctionné ? C'est ça ça a pris ces
parties d'un coup. On s'est dit il faut
il faut qu'on arrête toutes les
dernières manivres qu'on a pu faire où
il y avait un ou deux mots d'ordre.
C'est bon là rentrez tout chez vous. Là
on a vu qu'en fait ça pétait partout
tout le monde. Tout à l'heure on parlait
sur les filières qui vont mieux que
d'autres ou quoi que ce soit. peu. On a
parlé du compté ça va les gars ils ont
su s'organiser. On prend à l'averse, on
prend les gars qui travaillent avec un
industriel qui vendent 40 ou 41 centimes
le litre de lait, il vend à perte
clairementin. Je je veux pas le citer
hein, mais là honnêtement, il y a un
ménage à faire dans un industriel bien
particulier à 40 centimes du litre de
lait. C'est du vol. C'est du
Mais nous, on l'achète en supermarché
une blinde le lait.
Bien sûr, bien sûr. Mais il y en a un
entre deux qui qui qui se gave
ce sucre. Euh voilà, on a bien un peu
savoir et donc en fait on a pris tout le
monde, on a euh on a appelé tous les
départements, toutes les régions et on a
dit "Faites-nous remonter tous vos
revendications, tout ce qui va pas,
faites-nous tout remonter." Et là, on
est arrivé avec un une mallette, un truc
rempli, on a tout sorti, on avait sep
pages, on s'est fait wou là, qu'est-ce
que c'est que ça ? Mais il faut faire du
tri et tout. On s'est dit "Non, vas-y,
fais pas de tri, on y va."
posé ça, on a dit allez il y a tout ça.
Ah premier discours, premier discours,
elle a ressorti 5 si mesures, 10 mesures
du premier ministre he qu'on répondu.
Là, on a fait "Ouais, il y en a que 10
sur 120. Il est où le reste ?" Ah mais
mais mais je pensais que ça allait
suffire. Ah non non non, ça va pas
suffire. Intensifier. On y va, on
repart, on repart. En discussion, en
discussion. Et là, et là ça a craché, ça
a bossé hein. J'ai passé 10 jours ici à
Paris hein. Alors moi je faisais
beaucoup la relation entre les régions,
nous le national, comment ça va ? Non,
vous les brûlerz ! Arrêtez, arrêtez les
gars, attendez, on se calme. Est-ce que
on en est où des avancés ? Bah, on en
est là. Essayer de raisonner, concevoir,
voir où est-ce qu'ils allaient, essayer
de suivre aussi un peu les manifestants.
On a eu quasiment 80000 81000 qu'on a
recensé nous de d'exploitants agricoles
qui se sont mobilisés. Donc les mecs, ça
veut dire que quand on en arrive là sur
380000 agriculteurs qui restent ou c'est
que ça commence à faire du monde hein
parce que on peut le prendre sur les
autres corps de métier. Donc ça fait un
sacré pourcentage quand même qu' a sorti
maisc ils sont tous partis à fond, ils
ont laissé leurs femmes, ils ont dit au
salariés "Bon bah je suis désolé, je
vais te laisser toi leurs
femmes et monté sur leur homme
ou les femmes qui sont montées
clairement il y a les femmes qui ont
laissé les bonhommes en disant bon bah
il faut trouver une solution, il y a les
il y a les enfants pas d'enfants la
ferme ou quoi que ce soit faut gérer. On
n pas assez remercié les salariés, mais
il y a des salariés qui ont passé 10
jours sur les exploitations à gérer les
exploitations pour que leur patron
puisse le payer à la fin du mois. C'est
voilà parce que les patrons ont dit bon
bah là où des salariés moi j'ai vu des
salariés sur les manifes sur des manifes
qui sont venus sur des manifes en disant
bah je suis là parce que en fait je vois
la misère que c'est je vois comment dans
l'état est mon patron moi j'aimerais
bien qu'il me paye un petit peu plus
aussi donc bah il faut y aller quoi.
Donc des revendications dans tous les
sens on les a toutes présenté on nous a
dit OK ça on fait ça ça ça et alors on
nous a sorti un calendrier des pas de
temps des mesures plus ou moins
d'urgence de la perf. Moi, c'est ce que
j'en ai marre de toutes ces subventions
à gauche et à droite. On peut me parler
de la Pâque. Moi, demain, j'ai envie de
vivre sans PAC. Si demain je gagne
suffisamment de revenus ou d'argent sur
mon exploitation et qu'on me dit "Tu en
as plus besoin, tu gagnes suffisamment
au revoir la PAC". Que du bonheur. Là
là, on est on est on est comme ça, on a
des perfs derrière et puis de temps en
temps, on a faim. Allez. On nous a dit
"Les Viti, ça va mal, les VTI, vous
arrivez plus à vendre. Il y a plus de
structuration, vous vendez plus, il y a
plus rien qui va. Allez, je vous mets
160 millions. Oui, OK, c'est ça marche.
Mais dans 2 ans ou 3 ans, on refait quoi
? S'il y a le même coût climatique, on
fait quoi ? On recommence. C'est c'est
pas logique. Faut peut-être se réfléchir
et se poser les bonnes questions.
Qu'est-ce que je vais dire au jeune
demain qui va venir me dire "Moi, je
veux m'installer en VTI." OK. Alors, mon
petit pauvre, tu es prêt à vivre sous
perf ? Tu es prêt à à te faire
éventuellement une bonne année et puis
ah ouais à faire la quête, à faire
l'omone ? C'est pas ça notre boulot. On
veut vivre. Enfin voilà, on revient
toujours au même truc quoi.
Tu m'ouris ça à te couper juste une
seconde.
Vas-y, vas-y.
Quand je t'entends décrire que tu es
sous perf, moi je vois les cultures sous
perf d'un tran de produits
phytosanitaires et que en gros
l'agriculture
moderne
sans intran sans produits phytoitaires,
c'est un peu à l'image de notre
agriculture sous perfusion d'argent
public, de dette la dette c'est de
l'énergie future.
Tu comprends ce que j'essaie de te faire
passer comme parallèle ? Est-ce qu'il y
a pas un truc malade là-dedans ?
Il y a tout à voir. Il y a tout à
revoir. C'est ce qu'on demande. Quand on
dit on veut changer le logiciel, je te
dis on s'assoit autour d'une table tous
anti pour gouvernement monsieur
bienpensant tout le monde. On se met
tous sur tour d'une table, on réécrit
l'histoire, on réécrit l'agriculture de
A à Z. Il y a tout à revoir
du gros père Noël toi. Définitivement.
Ah je c'est ce qu'on pousse quand même
là. Là aujourd'hui on en est là.
Aujourd'hui, on dit on a 120 120
revendications. Là, on commence à dire
"Les gars, vous comprenez quand même que
c'est un petit peu le bordel quand même
sur l'agriculture. Là, ça va pas. Là, ça
va pas. Là, ça va pas. Quand il y a un
truc à un moment qui va plus là quand on
quand on a une exploitant, enfin je sais
pas, je vais prendre un industriel quce
qu'on casse son industrie d'un se coup,
ça part dans tous les sens. Il y a un
moment, faut peut-être s'asseoir et se
dire "Bon, je peut-être me remettre en
question quand même un petit peu là sur
mon truc. On revoit tout. Si le mec il
fait pas, il les voit à l'échec. Dans 2
ans, il est plus là. Là, aujourd'hui,
l'agriculture, elle est comme ça. Là,
nous, on en est là. Nous, on est là en
train de dire "Oh oh, faut se remettre
en question." Et on en a des
bienpensants devant nous qui nous disent
"Oui, bon, on va vous en remettre un
petit peu là ça. Allez, ça va couvrir la
crise puis taisez-vous, rentrez chez
vous." OK, cool. Non, non, non, non,
non. C'est fini ça. C'est fini.
C'est ça le rôle du politique en fait.
Le rôle du politique pour moi, enfin
j'ai l'impression quand même normalement
ce pourquoi on les a eu, c'est pour
qu'ils nous disent "Ben là, on va vous
générer les conditions. Vous voulez vous
remettre en question, vous voulez faire
ces transitions parce que la société
nous le demande, parce que nous on en a
envie." Et ben OK, on va vous mettre
dans les dispositions pour faire ces
transformations. Donc pas dire "Oh là,
ça barre d'un côté, on peut pas ce que
disait Quentin, on Et plus tenable ça.
Ça correspond même pas au au mindset des
jeunes qui s'installent. C'est pas
ici en France, on parle français
à l'état d'esprit des jeunes qui
s'installent. Autant pour moi. Et en
fait, c'est
Sébastien Chaval.
Oui, pas personnellement mais et et du
coup en fait ça correspond pas à l'état
d'esprit. Le truc c'est de dire ben
donnez-nous la capacité de pouvoir faire
ces transitions et là on demande juste
une pote. Arrêtez 2 minutes parce qu'on
en peut plus on en peut plus d'en
prendre de tous les côtés de machin de c
de là. Bon voilà, ce climat d'insécurité
qui est entretenu et par les politiques
et par les médias, ça ne nous met pas
dans les bonnes dispositions. Enfin, les
mecs qui sortent travailler de chez eux,
bientôt, ils ont la peur au ventre parce
que ah il est avec tes vages dans un
prêt, ça fait du bruit, l'autre ça
pollue l'autre voilà et donc ça c'est du
délire et et nous on n'est pas en
sécurité et on pourtant enfin voilà, moi
j'aimerais pouvoir faire ces transitions
et être voilà être un peu mieux
rémunéré, un peu moins dépendant de la
géopolitique mondiale que s'il y en a un
qui décide de de faire un coup de
travers à l'autre et ben que ça voilà,
ça me change pas trop ma vie. Même si
tout ça, voilà, je m'inscris dans dans
le monde et dans l'Europe, il y a pas de
problème. Mais que ce soit un peu plus
favorisé et là on y arrive pas sur les
politiques ne sont pas capables de faire
ça, ils sont pas capables, ils sont pas
capables.
Nous là, le pack de confiance, il est
rompu avec eux complètement. Enfin, je
veux dire, moi je je le dis, c'est c'est
fini. Il y a il y a zéro confiance. Zéro
confiance parce qu'en fait là, on a été
obligé de leur donner les 120 mesures
mais ils se foutent de nous. Ça fait 30
ans qu'on leur donne le le un peu moins,
je je un peu plus jeune que ça mais fait
15 ans que je fais du syndicalisme. Ça
fait 15 ans qu'on leur dit les gars,
c'est ça qu'on dit. Et là, il faut qu'on
leur ramène leur mesure pour leur dire
enfin moi je c'est bon, je fais pas le
service à prévente du gouvernement ou
des gouvernements. Moi ce que je fais
c'est favoriser l'agriculture. Peincré
ces dispositions là, d'accord mais qui
qui qu'ils y aillent. Qu'
y aillent.
Mais non mais toi aussi du cro au père
Noël.
Mais la jeunesse, il manque
d'expérience, je sais pas, on n pas
encore la sagesse, tu vois. Je je je
vais parler phyo phyu environnement
pollution
pollution il y a pas de problème
la pratique contaminée rivière
contaminée on sort des phyos allez on se
tape dans la main c'est pas comme ça
qu'on va y sortir de la main si demain
j'ai du revenu si je suis capable de
gagner de ma vie et que derrière on me
dit regarde tu as v on va sortir du fito
et ton revenu ne va pas descendre au
contraire tu vas peut-être un peu moins
produire mais de meilleure qualité mais
derrière on a su organiser construire
l'agriculture on y sort il y a pas de
problème. Sauf que là, c'est pas ça. Là,
on nous dit "Les gars, vous êtes au rat,
vous pouvez plus mais il faut rattraper
les erreurs qu'on a fait depuis 30 ans.
Vous allez sortir des phyos, vous allez
diminuer. Là, c'est ce qu'a en ce moment
là, vous allez diminuer de 50 % d'ici
les 5 prochaines années. De 50 % de fit
en moins. OK, ça marche. OK, qu'est-ce
que vous mettez en face ? Je vous mettre
250 millions sur la recherche. Ah ouais,
s'il y en a qui nous regardent, ils
peuvent aller rechercher un petit peu
qu'est-ce que les gros industriels,
on va dire créateur de chimie mettent
sur la table en terme de recherche. On
est loin avec notre recherche publique
avec 250 millions, hein. Faut voir un
peu plus hein, faut mettre le milliard,
le milliard sur la table par an pour
commencer à aller rechercher des
solutions alternatives. Aujourd'hui, on
nous dit mais 250 millions. sur 250
millions, on va mettre un petit peu par
là, un petit peu à gauche, un petit peu
sur de la pédagogie, un peu sur de la
formation et dans 5 ans, vous on vous en
retire 50 % au fur et à mesure là dans 5
ans bim de mois,
inchallah ça va marcher.
Bah et puis si ça marche pas, qu'est-ce
qu'on fait ? Bah là aujourd'hui, on en
est là, on dit mais ouais, moi je leur
dis, je veux une vision d'avenir.
J'avais interrogé le le ministre Feno en
lui disant
Marc Fenot. Je lui dis c'est c'est quoi
cette histoire ? 250 millions par an sur
5 ans 50 % en moins. Je veux une vision
d'avenir. Quentin-
je lui ai dit je veux une vision
d'avenir. Il faudrait mettre donnez-nous
le temps. Tirons la chaise, laissez-nous
discuter avec vous, trouvons des
solutions, mettez le pactol qui va bien
sur la recherche, sur comment changer
des nouvelles variétés, des cultures qui
prennent moins d'eau, des cultures qui
prennent moins de moins de maladie. Une
recherche accrue sur le bio aujourd'hui.
Bio, on l'a laissé comme ça et le bio,
il est en train de s'écrouler. Comment
on a envie ? On nous demande 25 % de bio
pour 2030 d'agriculteurs en bio. 25 %
des agriculteurs en bio pour 2030. On
est à 10 % 10 et quelques. Cette année
baissé en plus parce que ça déconverti
on a fait 01 pour 2023 plus 01 de
conversion. En fait, on a conversion des
conversions. On a des agriculteurs qui
sont convertis au bio. D'autres bah qui
ne s'y retrouvaient plus qui sont
déconvertis revenus au conventionnel. On
a fini à + 01 + 01. Et là, on est à 10
et quelques 10,6 10,7 et on doit être à
25 % pour 2030. Bah, c'est pas avec 01
par an qu'on va y arriver hein. Et
derrière, ils nous disent "Je comprends
pas." Bah mec, le bio il vend à perte.
Comment vous voulez nous emmener sur le
bio ? Moi je veux bien mais le nerf de
la guerre revient toujours là. Il y a
pas de souci. Accompagnez-nous. On crée
une agriculture forte, on se dégage des
subventions et des machins. Là, c'est
bon. Vous nous laissez gagner de la vie.
Faites-nous confiance. On y va.
Écoutez-nous un peu plus. Et aujourd'hui
non. Aujourd'hui non. On va nous parler
écoyaito, réduction de 50 phyos en
moins. On va avoir quatre agriculteurs,
10 ONG, quatre ministres qui vont être
là en face de nous qui vont nous dire
"Bon, on a réfléchi, on va changer un
petit peu l'indicateur hein comme ça sur
le qu'à quoi sert le phy0
et puis on va tenir 250 millions." Euh,
on leur dit "Ouais mais les gars, on a
fait 10 jours de manif, c'était pour
tout revoir." Oui. Oui. Bon, on va
revoir les indicateurs un petit peu mais
le reste on reste.
Non, mais ça c'est ça c'est c'est du du
vécu ça. D'accord ? Bah là où c'est pas
parce que là c'est du direct
c'était hier passe.
Ah ouais mais c'est on est en plein
dent.
Voilà il y a pas de problème. On est en
plein dent on est là on nous dit mais
c'est comme ça. Et moi je leurais dit
non non non vous savez ce qu'on va faire
on va se tirer une chaise, on va mettre
un peu plus d'argent, un peu plus de
temps. OK 2030 c'est un peu serré
mettez-nous à 2032 33 34 on essaie de
trouver des trucs qui vont bien. Appelez
les firmes. Aujourd'hui il y a les
firmes, on tape sur les firmes qui qui
vendent des produits, mais appelez-les,
mettez-les autour de la table. Faut leur
dire de toute façon les gars ça va plus,
le phy ça va plus. Est-ce que vous avez
des trucs en face à nous amener ? On
vous le dit tout de suite. Si vous avez
rien, vous dégagez maintenant. Il faut
il faut
ils ont rien. Et s'ils ont rien,
mais c'est euh enfin moi je je suis je
suis pas chercheur. Il on a des
chercheurs aujourd'hui qui sont là. Il y
a des gars qui réfléchissent. Non parce
que malheureusement ils ont pas le
revenu en face. Ils ont pas l'argent en
face pour aller faire de la bonne
recherche.
Ils partent à l'étranger.
Voilà, on peut parler des nouvelles
variétés, les nouvelles variétés de blé
qui viennent d'être validé en Europe
qu'on appelle NBT, NGT. Alors, on va
parler que je parle français c'est
nouvelles nouvelles techniques gén
techniques génomiques. Merci
où en fait on a une variété qui
aujourd'hui grâce à de la génétique.
Donc on va ouvrir le gène avec du
ciseau, prendre le ciseau et on va dire
tiens cette plante là elle a une maladie
qui est là. Je vais prendre je vais la
couper cette gêne de maladie, je vais la
retirer puis je vais lui remplacer par
peut-être une meilleure résistance à la
sécheresse. Boum ! On a créé une plante
qui va mettre 4 5 ans. C'est exactement
la même. Aujourd'hui pour créer une
variété, ça va durer 10 15 ans mais ça
va être à la pipette. On va prendre la
fleur mâle avec la fleur femelle, on va
essayer de la multiplier. C'est un
échec, c'est une réussite. On resse, on
ressaye 10 15 ans après, il y a Puis
derrière, on a l'extrême OGM où là on va
prendre ouvrir, on va prendre une
molécule totalement totalement
différente de la plante de base qu'on va
intégrer dedans. Tip on va connaître le
maïs au glyphosate, hein. On va prendre
on va prendre la molécule de glyphosate.
Pas de marque
glyphosate aujourd'hui il est dans le
dans le public donc c'est bon, il y a
plus de problème. On va on va dire on va
prendre la molécule. C'est une molécule
en plus hein qu'on va mettre dedans et
hop, on va se créer un maïs qui qui va
devenir résistant au glyphosate. Ça
c'est de l'OGM. Le le NGT he les
nouvelles variétés, elle
elle fait gagner du temps par rapport à
la fa gagner du temps par rapport au
truc. Là on leur dit
les gars go
euh le prix Nobel, j'ai j'ai oublié son
nom, il est où ?
On je crois qu'on avait de la recherche
française.
C'était le le le système Crisper Casper
Nine, je crois. Crisp non crisper cas
Ouais, je je on est en train de mâcher
les mots.
Voilà.
Crisper
euh
certains très bons euh en recherche en
France, on leur a dit "Non, non mais là
vous vous voyez trop loin les gars, là
vous êtes pas loin de toucher limite à
de l'OGM et tout. C'est mort, on
touchera jamais à ça." Qu'est-ce qu'ils
ont pris ? La valise,
avion, Chine, États-Unis. Et là, ils
sont arrivés, ils ont fait "ça y est,
nous c'est fait." Et là, ça y est,
l'Europe vient de dire "OK, bon ben on
va peut-être s'y intéresser un peu plus
que s'y intéressé" parce qu'ils ont dit
maintenant "OK, on y va, on y va mais
mais vraiment sous un angle très serré
hein. Faudra pas en mettre trop partout
quand même hein." Et voilà, bim, on
vient de se prendre 10 ans en retard et
derrière on dit "Ben allez, rappelez-les
ces chercheurs là, on y va maintenant,
on met de l'argent."
Non, non, mais il y a les filles qui
vont le faire. Par contre, pas de brevet
les gars, s'il vous plaît hein, s'il
vous plaît, nous faites pas mal.
Bah c'est ça les visions d'avenir. C'est
comme ça qu'on va tirer du jeune. Il
envie quand même d'en donner un peu mais
mais voilà c'est pour ça qu'on reste
quand même convaincu. Jeune agriculteur,
il y a le mot jeune. On reste une partie
très forte. On a envie de croire à
l'avenir. C'est compliqué mais on va
tout faire pour et c'est pour ça que
syndicat aujourd'hui quoi.
Non mais sinon les gars si ça marche
pas, vous faites un calendrier hein. Ça
ouais bah ça sera pour nous alors on se
partagera le Mago pour nous là pour le
coup. Ça sera pas pour les autres.
L'Europe l'Europe comment vous voyez
l'Europe ?
Moi l'Europe
enfin pour le coup à titre très
personnel, je pense que c'est un super
truc. Je pense que c'est enfin voilà une
un bel outil cette parté d'une belle
énergie de bon d'une histoire qui est
qui est celle de l'Europe là pour le
coup.
Moi, je suis inquiet, franchement, je
suis inquiet parce que quand je vois les
petits camarades autour,
ben voilà, ils ont tous envie de bah de
croquer dans la galette quoi. et et nous
on a on est là les Français des fois je
je sais pas je vais peut-être en faire
bondir quelques-uns mais après tout on
est là pour se dire les choses mais on
est là toujours vouloir donner des
leçons à vouloir faire mieux que les uns
avec les autres parce que voilà comme on
dit chez nous agriculture on est le coq
sur le tas de fumier quoi qui chante le
premier et et je pense que c'est plutôt
mal perçu dans ces temps un peu troublés
qu'on a à l'Europe de de vouloir aller
donner des leçons à tout le monde et
voilà et et encore une fois cette
position de de de d'acteur historique
européen qui voudrait dicter machin. Je
pense que ça c'est très très mauvais
pour l'Europe et et on se met en danger
sur le plan mondial et c'est ça qui
m'inquiète parce que du coup on on se
dispute entre nous et et ça c'est pas
l'essence de de l'Europe. Enfin pour moi
l'Europe c'est c'est c'est c'est enfin
j'en sais rien. C'est une communauté
vraiment et on
on veut de l'Europe en fait. La la
France veut de l'Europe et elle veut que
tout le monde soit comme mais personne
n'est pareil. Donc il y a un moment en
fait sur lancé.
Mais ouais. Non mais je mais mais je
voyais tourner.
Non mais si si tu veux en fait c'est ça
c'est tout le monde a envie d'y aller
mais personne n'y va franchement. Ou
j'ai l'impression qu'on y va là-bas, on
se regarde dans le blanc des yeux. Tu as
vu, moi j'ai une bonne idée, tu devrais
me la prendre et tout. Et en fait c'est
pas ça, c'est OK, on bah attends
peut-être tuas tu as une bonne idée, pas
une bonne idée, on va l'essayer. On se
donne la possibilité d'aller explorer
des trucs et tout et là non, chacun
reste campé sur ses positions. Enfin, je
sais pas, enfin sur la question
migratoire, la gestion migratoire, c'est
pareil en fait. tout le monde se renvoie
la patate chaude et et personne est là à
voir se dire "On va voir une vraie
politique migratoire sur sur l'Europe et
et on va vraiment se poser les
questions." Et moi, je me dis moi en
tant qu'européen parce que je me
considère français mais je me considère
européen, ça me fait mal, ça m'en ça ça
m'enquiquine parce que voilà, je je me
dis bah super, on a une monnaie, bon, on
a un espace où on peut aller et venir et
en fait non en fait non, c'est pas ça.
On a on a des choses qui sont qui sont
très injustes parce que il y a de la TVA
sur certains, parce qu'il y a pas de TVA
sur d'autres, parce qu'il y a de la main
d'œuvre. Il y a du dumping social, il y
a du dumping économique a et pourquoi on
n'est pas capable pourquoi on n'est pas
capable depuis tout ce temps-là de de de
donner voilà de faire table race de ça
et et donner de l'ambition à ça ? J'ai
je encore une fois, je suis jeune mais
j'ai l'impression que les les anciens
qui avaient créé cette Europe et donné
cette volonté à l'Europe et ben le
petits nouveaux là qui arrivent la
nouvelle génération, ils voient pas
l'Europe de la même façon, ils le voient
comme un outil géopolitique stratégique
pour servir les intérêts personnels des
pays. Moi ça m'inquiète. Moi ça
m'inquiète vraiment. Et je me dis que je
me dis que c'est dommage parce qu'on on
avait une vraie puissance, on a une
vraie force, on a des vraies
perspectives et là on se gâche. Voilà.
Moi, j'ai l'impression qu'on se gâche
que voilà et ça c'est voilà, je trouve
que c'est c'est c'est super dommage et
ça nous met en danger. Ça nous met en
danger tout de suite et ça nous met en
danger pour l'avenir parce que voilà, il
y a des messieurs euh qui sont un peu
moins fréquentables euh qui qui
regardent ça. Euh voilà, comme un
vautour posé. Ouais. Comme un vautour
posé sur sa branche qui regarde le
cadavre en train de de gigoter avec les
nerfs et ça c'est inquiétant.
Quentin
non mais enfin il a tout dit sur
quand quand on parle de l'Europe
je vais revenir dans mes rêves d'enfant
encore
je te rassure he 33 ans tu es encore un
bébé
ouais mais tu as envie tu as envie de te
dire tu as l'Europe on va tous
fonctionner ensemble poser une question
indiscrète
les cheveux blancs c'est génétique ou
c'est le stress sur ta ton exploitation
c'est génétiqu mon grand-père à 40 an il
était blanc blanc blanc non t'inquiète
après ça a été plus vite. que prévu. Je
pense qu'il y a un peu de stress quand
même. Mais sur sur le volet européen, on
a envie de de se dire "Bon ben, on va
tous marcher ensemble, tous dans la même
vision, on va tous y aller. Main
d'œuvre, le coût aujourd'hui, le le
revenu revenu aussi Europe efficace
quoi. Un truc où on sait que si je
prends bah nous face agricole hein, que
je vais produire mon kilo de tomate
derrière, j'ai une charge de main
d'œuvre ou si ou ça qu'elle soit la même
sur le pays voisin. l'utilisation de phy
je l'utilise comme ça c'est le même à
côté déjà au moins au moins au même de
l'Europe si demain tu mange de de des
tomates polonaises bah qu'elle est
quasiment le même goût que la tomate
française parce que en fait c'est la
même. C'est un libre échange au milieu
de tout ça. C'est une bonne mixture.
Super. Non, aujourd'hui ça fonctionne
pas comme ça. Je trop parler sur les
cofito cofito. On a eu la réglementation
sûre qui a été discutée à l'Europe.
C'est une réglementation où dedans
environnementale où dedans il y avait le
volet de diminution de produits
phytosanitaires. Elle a été rejetée là.
Là, elle a été balayée. Qu'est-ce qu'on
fait nous en France ? Ben, on a continué
à appliquer et on continue là à
travailler sur le plan écohyto.
Je on va pas le jeter le plan écoy parce
que c'est une nécessité de discuter de
produits phytosanitaires. Il y a pas de
problème, on va discuter. Mais encore
une fois, voà une concurrence au sein
même de l'Europe où nous, la France plus
vert que tous les autres. Et derrière
quand on dit ça à certains du
gouvernement, ils nous disent "Oui, mais
il en faut bien un qui commence." Ah
ouais, mais au bout d'un moment, une
fois, deux fois, trois fois, quatre
fois, bah ça commence un petit peu à
faire long quoi. C'est toujours nous les
meneurs là. Mais on a rien en retour. On
a rien en retour. Donc l'Europe voilà,
on a envie d'y croire. Moi, j'y crois.
Mais il il faut il faut il faut
reprendre un peu le ce leader Europe
d'amener tout le monde dans une même
vision, dans une même trajectoire.
Bon courage.
Euh les professions en tension, les
visas, les euh
la main d'œuvre externe.
Ah ouais, faut faut y aller là.
Je t'écoute. Ouais. Faut y aller. On en
a besoin.
On en a besoin parce que bah les
tomates, les pommes
en tout cas pour les fruits et légumes
notamment, mais enfin c'est pas demain
qu'on va les ramasser avec des machines
qu'on va pouvoir payer avec ce qu'on se
tire sur comme revenu sur les
exploitations.
Donc donc ce qu'on dit c'est c'est que
bah oui, métier en tension nous voilà,
je veux dire la main
voilà faut pas se cacher derrière le
petit doigt. C'est c'est c'est des
étrangers qui viennent travailler dans
les champs. C'est des étrangers qui
viennent travailler dans les champs.
Donc voilà, on en a besoin. Euh ça
travaille enfin je moi en PAC notamment,
mais il travaille avec l'Ofi,
l'organisme français de de l'immigration
et voilà. Après par contre faut quand
même que ça se fasse dans de bonnes
conditions. Je veux dire, on a un niveau
social en France minimum et faut le
respecter jusqu'au bout. Que ce soit les
conditions de logement que ce soit voilà
pour le coup c'est ce qu'on demande aux
agriculteurs. Et là pour le coup ça
c'est contrôlé hein et c'est très bien.
Mais
les vangur avec les hélicoptères c'est
ça ?
C'est-à-dire
c'est tu contrôles combien il y a de
vangers avec l'hélicoptère.
Ouais il contrôle bah avec les drones
c'est ça brou moins ça fait moins de
bruit. C'est plus discret, c'est classe.
Et mais voilà, on en a besoin. On en a
besoin de de on en a besoin, je veux
dire, on en a besoin. Je dis enfin les
arboriculteurs, les viticulteurs, les
les maréchers, ils ont besoin. Donc
voilà, pas de sujet. Pas de sujet.
Mais c'est peut-être dans la dans le
fond un problème un petit peu à
retourner aussi hein. Pourquoi on est
obligé de prendre la main d'œuvre
étrangère ? Parce qu'en France, bah déjà
payer 1002 ou payer 1003, ça intéresse
pas le jeune d'aller travailler, d'aller
faire ça, un truc pénible pour payer
cette misère là. Enfin, je les comprends
clairement.
Comment c'est le visa australien pour
aller travailler un peu dans les champs
là ?
Le working ? Ouais, ma sœur habite à
Melbourne est parti avec un visa working
tiens, dernière dédicace avant la
prochaine Coralie si tu me regardes. Euh
non, ouais, ouais, ouais, je Mais on a
pas la capacité de faire ça en France,
pas avec les travailleurs des champs.
Non, non. Bah, pas la même philosophie.
fait un agriculteur
australien, je veux dire c'est pas tout
à fait le même business qu'un
agriculteur français. Je me rappelle
parti m'avait invité en voyage. Du coup,
j'étais parti quelques temps là-bas puis
j'avais discuté avec des gars et c'est
c'est eux c'est c'est ce que dit
Quentin, c'est cyclique. Mais quand il
tape en haut, ils tapent en haut très
fort. Il voilà, ils achètent le village,
le bateau, la Marina et tout ce qui va
avec quoi. Donc ouais, ils peuvent
rémunérer et voilà. Par contre, quand ça
tape au fond, ils vendent le bateau, la
marina et tout ce qui va avec. Mais
c'est comme ça, c'est voilà, nous on n'
pas du tout le même rapport avec le
métier. Voilà. Mais oui, oui, mais ce
qui est vrai en Australie avec le social
ne je c'est pour le coup, on est
vraiment à l'extrême opposé du globe
vraiment. Mais s même enfin sur la
question du salaire, du rapport au
travail, c'est
ferait bien d'y aller voir un peu nos
dirigeants comment ça fonctionne aussi.
Quin je t'ai coupé. Vas-y, continue.
Mais non, mais mais ça ça répond. de
demain, demain, on a suffisamment et on
paye suffisamment et on vend
suffisamment nos camelottes à tout le
monde et que tout le monde a assez de
revenus, moi je veux bien payer
quelqu'un 2000 ou 2500 € pour venir
faire des vendanges ou arracher ou ou
cueillir des pommes. C'est c'est logique
l'histoire, sauf qu'aujourd'hui tout le
monde est tellement serré que bah voilà,
pour finir
vos modèles d'agriculture, est-ce que
vous avez essayé de les mettre sous
stress avec des facteurs extérieurs ?
faire des expériences de pensée sur bah
qu'est-ce qui se passe si on se tape x
année de grê, x années de géopolitique
qui flanche. Si on se tape un rideau de
fer avec les Russes, qu'est-ce qui se
passe si le monde est coupé en deux ?
Comment on fait avec le prix des intrans
? Comment on fait avec le prix des
machins ? Vous avez essayé de faire ça ?
Non
non, il y a pas besoin. On est déjà
tellement Ouais, en fait, on est déjà
dans la dans l'antichambre. Euh allez,
tu rajoutes un an ou deux et tu payes et
puis c'est bon. Mais ce qui va se passer
que on va rendre les clés du business
hein.
Moi, je pose ça à la banque, ils vont
faire une vente aux enchères et puis
c'est terminé. C'est ça en fait le bout
du bout. Là, on est enfin le stress
test. Euh,
tu sais que tu veux emmener les banques
avec toi hein ?
Ouais. Bah, ils vont peut-être se
réveiller à un moment donné, mais bon,
enfin,
moi je veux dire, j'ai je pense qu'on
met beaucoup de volonté là-dedans. On
met beaucoup d'énergie et au bout d'un
moment, si on met tellement sous
contrainte, on a faire des êtres humains
au bout du bout, hein. Donc, ils vont
rendre les clés du business et puis ils
vont dire "Bah, vous savez pas,
débrouillez-vous, bah les banques vont
tomber, les banques tomberont et puis
c'est s'entraînera ce que ça doit
entraîner."
Je me sens pas irresponsable quand je
dis ça en fait parce que je j'age ma
responsabilité tous les jours quand je
rembourse mes mes emprunts et mon
objectif c'est bien de d'aller au bout
de ces investissements parce que voilà
il y a l'engagement personnel et puis de
la fierté et puis voilà ça me plaît
la réalisation
puis la réalisation voilà mais si on on
met encore un peu trop de contrainte on
n'y arrivera plus et voilà et c'est ça
en fait qu'on se dit là on est comme ça
parce que on sent pas les gens qui sont
en capacité de prendre des décisions
pour pour l'avenir réellement en pleine
possession de leur moyens, je dirais.
Enfin et du coup c'est Ouais c'est moi
il faudrait pas qu'il y ait 3 années de
grê ou 3 années de sécheresse ou ou 3
années de trop de pluie enfin bref un
alléat climatique quelconque ou guerre
sur les climatique on a encore le le
petit côté un petit peu assurance on
peut essayer vis-à-vis d'une grê
chercher un système assuranciel une
guerre euh non on avait aucune assurance
he là l'assurance si on se l'était pas
créé blam on se l'it mangé plein de
fouet là et puis en fois deux hein donc
oui oui Moi euh j'en sais rien si ça
refait un yoyo ou quoi que ce soit, j'ai
intérêt fort à anticiper et je ne sais
pas trop comment mais il va falloir que
je réfléchisse dans tous les sens. Donc
s'il y en a un qui a qui a qui qui sait
me dire là à tel jour achète. OK.
Le suicide des agriculteurs, on en
parle,
on peut.
Il y a combien de morts par an ? C'est
c'est c'est un agriculteur qui suicide
tous les deux jours. Tous les deux
jours.
Mais je enfin
enfin encore une fois je c'est c'est pas
un enfin je sais pas comment on peut
l'aborder mais c'est pas un concours de
la profession qui suicide le plus. Enfin
je sais pas chez les gendarmes chez je
enfin je
j'entends dire qu'il y a d'autres
professions aussi qui sont sous
contrainte et
et et où les mecs passent à l'acte.
Voilà. Je enfin ce Ouais, c'est un sujet
en agriculture.
Le le sujet qui est quand même avec
l'agriculture, c'est que souvent c'est
une transmission. Souvent on est fils
d'exploitant, on a repris la ferme
familiale, la ferme peut-être du
grand-père ou de l'arrière-gr-père. Donc
on a un poids sur les général
mais qui est énorme parce que tout le
monde a réussi avant et on veut pas être
la génération qui va couler la boîte.
Donc on est là, on se donne, on se
donne, on se donne, on se donne, on se
donne. Puis au bout d'un moment, ben on
a beau se donner mais à la maison mais
quand il y a plus d'argent ça pète quoi.
Enfin, il faudrait que mon père il me la
redonne mais quand il y a plus à bouffer
dans leur atelier, les choses se
battent. Oui, ben mais c'est ça aussi à
la maison quand il y a plus d'argent au
bout d'un moment et que c'est et que
c'est le conjoint ou la conjointe qui
ramène,
bah on se retrouve dépendant un peu à
essayer d'avoir une entreprise qui coule
donc qui fait perdre de l'argent et au
moment ça craque et et malheureusement
malheureusement il y en a on essaie de
les accompagner via aujourd'hui il y a
des trucs qui sont créés avec la
mutualité sociale agricole
d'accompagnement essayer de trouver les
personnes en difficulté pour essayer de
leur dire bon bah peut-être arrêter ou
trouver autre chose ou de ramener encore
de l'endettement supplémentaire, ça a
jamais sorti quelqu'un de lui dire bah
attends rien vesti là-dedans, tu vas
voir ça va aller mieux. Alors là ça
c'est ça marche une fois sur 10, c'est
une cata directe mais d'essayer d'y
trouver un système attends on va
t'accompagner il y a des aides est-ce
qu'on peut te rapporter un peu ? Et puis
au bout d'un moment bah des fois il y en
a qui veulent voir personne parce que
ils ont tout perdu ou ils sont seuls sur
l'exploitation. la femme est partie ou
la femme est encore là mais c'est
compliqué
ou avec quelqu'un d'autre
et et c'est compliqué et et la banque on
a plus envie de voir la mutalité sociale
on a plus envie de la voir et on tombe
dans une dépression pour
Ouais c'est ça ça commence comme ça et
puis tu tu tu plonges petit à petit à
petit dans les infers et puis il y a il
y a une chose aussi quand même qui qu'il
faut se dire c'est que
les agriculteurs, ils ont pour habitude
d'aller au bout du bout des choses.
C'est-à-dire que
il y a cette fierté qu'on disait
notamment vis-à-vis du patrimoine, mais
un agriculteur, il va pas il va pas
accepter de déposer le bilan,
aller jusqu'au bout.
Il va aller jusqu'au bout. Les banques
le savent et donc ça veut dire qu'au
bout d'un moment, ils ont aussi accès à
des prêts et un système bancaire plus
facilement ou qui favoriserait
l'endettement parce que les banques
savent qu'ils vont aller jusqu'au bout.
Donc le mec va perdre sa santé, va
perdre sa famille, il va tout perdre
avant d'en arriver là. Et quand même
dans la majorité des cas, finalement la
banque récupère son actif et ça c'est
dramatique. Et ça il faut aussi que les
jeunes qui s'installent, il prennent
conscience que non, on débranche avant,
on arrête. Enfin, les billets c'est du
matériel hein, ça n'a pas de valeur. On
rend les clés de la baraque et on
arrête. Parce que la vie, la vie c'est
ça la valeur des choses. C'est c'est la
vie, c'est le vivant et les agriculteurs
devraient le savoir. Ils le savent mieux
que tous les autres. les les les
billets, les pièces, ça a pas de valeur.
Quentin, tu veux rajouter un mot ou on
passe à un autre sujet ?
Non non, c'est
on passe à un autre sujet.
Ouais, vas-y.
Quand vous avez fait un petit peu
Prigogine monte à la capitale, euh vous
avez été suivi un petit peu par les
services de renseignement, vos
téléphones vous aviez
Bien sûr.
Raconte un peu.
Vas-y. Quand tu étais tout à l'heure au
téléphone avec eux. Ouais. Ouais. Ils
adorent ça, ils adorent ça. Bon, en
fait, monde agricole a toujours été très
actif, très voilà, dès qu' les
mobilisation, on est quand même une
tranche de métier où on va dire que on
est quand même très suivi parce que
quand un agriculteur se met à se
mobiliser et à bouger, ça peut vite
bloquer quelque chose, ça peut vite
emmerder le monde. Donc ou casser, ça
s'est quand même amélioré. Mais bon, il
y a eu des arriérés de manif quand même
il y a eu pas mal de dégâts. Donc bon,
ils savent que quand ça pète, ça peut
péter fort.
Une claque de vigneron.
Ah celle, il ont des mains.
Bon, donc il y a toujours une relation,
on va dire en fonction des départements
qui se passe plus ou moins bien parce
que avec les renseignements
territoriaux, ils viennent te voir, on
les repère,
ils sont sympas les renseignements les
tr qu ceuxl ils sont très sympas. Ils
viennent nous voir. L'idée en fait c'est
que si on leur vend une petite carotte
derrière, ils vont nous en donner une
autre et puis c'est bon, on se sert la
main, on va travailler un peu comme ça.
Ils aiment bien savoir aussi. Ils sont
ils sont aussi un outil pour nous parce
que des fois, on les appelle en leur
disant "Là je te le dis, hein, euh
préparez-vous à quelque chose. C'est en
train de monter les gars, ça va
chauffer." vrai ou pas ? M'importe, tu
racontes ça derrière, ça remonte, ça
arrive sur
d'intoxication en plus. Bien sûr, ça
arrive un petit peu sur le bureau du
préfet et là alors les gars, ce qui
paraît ça a chauffé, ça vous dit on se
rencontre, on discute un peu ? Ouais,
parce que là, il des sujets qui sont
chaud chaud chauds, faut qu'on se voit,
pam et puis il y a des fois bon ben on
est là, on dit bon, on va rien dire au
renseignement territoriux, on va faire
une petite action coup de point dans un
coin d'une GMS ou d'un truc.
C'est quoi une GMS ?
Une grande surface. On on va l'autre
là-bas, il nous enquiquine un peu, on va
laisser la plier ou euh tiens euh il y a
la députée qui a sorti une connerie ou
le député ou ou le sénateur. Bon, on va
faire un truc, on va aller déposer une
ben ou la préfecture va déposer une ben
devant. Ça c'est action coup de point.
Donc ça, on essaie de se terre. Bon ça
ils apprécient un petit peu moins bien.
Des fois ils viennent nous voir en
disant "Oh les gars, on avait créé de la
confiance là va falloir falloir le
ramasser quoi. Ou sinon vous allez faire
la facture." Mais oui il y a
ramasser pas toujours. Tout le temps.
Pas tout le temps. Pas tout le temps.
Puis maintenant on a chopé aussi un peu
les techniques quoi. Le téléphone on le
met en mode avion hein quand on fait ces
conneries là ou on le laisse à la maison
hein parce que bon quand ça borne he
maintenant faut faire attention. Donc
euh faut voilà ça, on fait nos conneries
mais renseignement on a toujours un bon
échange plutôt plutôt assez bon avec eux
parce que ils ont besoin en fait c'est
les premiers à donner euh au plus haut
la température
capteur de température.
Clair. Totalement. Totalement. B voilà
encore tout à l'heure là là c'est on
sent que là il y a une tension quand
même toujours he malgré malgré les
mobilisations qu'on a eu les
revendication on voit que on n pas
forcément de réponse sur certains points
on sent que ça repart un petit peu. Bah
ça a pas loupé tout à l'heure. Oh tiens
un numéro inconnu.
Oh ben non bien connu parce qu'il me l'a
donné carrément son numéro. Il m'a dit
comme ça tu m'appelles quand tu veux. Ah
là je Ah tiens oui ça va. Ouais. Alors
qu'est-ce que ça raconte ? Ah qu'est-ce
que je peux te raconter ? Et puis là bah
voilà, on essaie de dire bah là
maintenant là faut être clair avec eux.
Voilà c'est ça va mal, c'est la merde.
On a on n pas été répondu partout.
Renseignement symptomatique en fin de
compte
de Oui oui oui
oui oui c'est ça vient chercher la
petite information mais mais pas celle
pas celle en profondeur pas celle qui
qu'ils auraient besoin de savoir pour
changer les choses. Ils viennent savoir
qu'est-ce qu'ils peuvent faire là vite
fait pour désamorcer le truc. un coup de
téléphone en préfecture, ramener un
dossier au préfet, dire attention euh ou
à la gendarmerie du coin ou les députés
alertaient en fait dire les gars en fait
et mais c'est malheureux en fait dans
quand quand je quand je redis tout ça
que les premiers lanceurs d'alerte
directement avec les préfets en fait ça
soit clairement les renseignements
territoriaux, ça devrait être plutôt
j'en sais rien, nos banques, nos
mutualités sociales agricoles ou
nous-même exploitants agricoles de de
dire au préfet bah ça va mal, ça chauffe
et en fait là ils disent ouais non et
puis d'un seul coup quand on appelle les
renseignements et qu'on dit les gars
j'ai cinq ben Tatel derrière rempli de
pneus et de fumiers. Dans 2 heures, on
est là-bas. Oh, souvent dans les 5
minutes, il y a un coup de téléphone du
préfet.
Le renseignement de terrain et sur du
long terme, il y a que ça de vrai.
Question pseudo internet arrivé par SMS.
Comment aimeriez-vous que l'agriculture
évolue ? En quelques mots,
en un mot bien. Maintenant, ça dég que
dalle. Comment on aimerait qu'elle
évolue, qu'on soit écouté ? qu'on soit
rémunéré sa juste valeur nous les
consommateurs qu'on vende au mieux qu'on
soit libre
les transitions
transition là
environnemental
environnement mais oui mais
l'environnement on est prêt à y
travailler mais qu'on nous écoute
autre question que pensez-vous de la
position du gouvernement concernant
l'utilisation des pesticides
bah ils ont une position où aujourd'hui
enfin j'ai du mal à voir un peu la
question mais position ils ont une
position où aujourd'hui elle est là ils
veulent pas 100 % l'interdire parce
qu'ils savent que derrière les solutions
alternatives, il y en a pas des masses
ou bah ils veulent pas mettre
suffisamment d'argent pour aller les
rechercher. Euh je peux prendre
l'exemple du glyphosate hein. Glyphosate
ça a été le grand débat des années et
des années sur le glyphosate et encore
toujours le glyphosate il est là c'est
ça qui tue et cetera et cetera. On voit
sur les OGM sur les États-Unis bref on
va pas dire de marque mais il vient de
créer d'une grosse firme aujourd'hui que
c'était l'homme à cétait le truc à
abattre. Il faut OK, ça marche.
Aujourd'hui, on dit moi je le retire. On
a quoi en face ? On a aucune solution
alternative. Donc si moi j'en ai une sur
ma sur ma sur mon exploitation chèvre
euh Ouais, c'est d'aller brouter. Alors
ça veut dire j'oublie toutes mes grandes
cultures mais ou plutôt Ouais. Et puis
où je vais m'installer dans le lzac et
puis je me mets des chèvères un chevau
de paille et
mais non aujourd'hui euh non si j'ai une
solution ben c'est je remets 100 L ou
150 L de gasoile et de GNR en plus sur
mon exploitation parce que je vais
travailler intensément mes sols,
détruire malheureusement ce que je viens
de réussir à créer où j'ai des sols
vivants qui fonctionnent et enfin voilà
faut savoir un peu ce qu'on veut.
Autre question pourquoi y a-t-il une
déconnexion si grande entre la base
militante et les dirigeants ? parce
qu'on n' pas su s'exprimer, parce qu'on
n' pas su raconter ce qu'on allait
faire, ce qu'on faisait. Et en fait, je
enfin moi pour le coup, on enfin la
question elle est bienvenue, il y a une
vraie déconnexion en tout cas une
incompréhension entre l'adhérent et et
son représentant, son demandant là comme
on est nous à Paris ou ailleurs parce
qu'on sait pas s'exprimer parce que
voilà, on n pas su faire aussi et que je
pense qu'il y a du décalage entre
l'agriculteur qui prend tout ça sur lui,
toutes ses attaques sur la ferme et nous
qui essayons de trouver des solutions et
qui prenons pas forcément le temps de se
pencher, d'écouter, dire bon les Les
gars, qu'est-ce que vous avez vraiment à
nous dire ? Nous, on peut le faire un
peu chez Ja, mais on manque de temps et
on manque de bonhomme et de et de femmes
pour faire pour faire ce travail. On
manque de responsable et en fait bah on
subit des problèmes, on court derrière
des trucs et on narrive pas à expliquer
vraiment ce que c'est que les combats
syndicaux et
un peu comme les services de
renseignement quoi.
Ouais.
On est presque aussi mauvais.
Tu veux rajouter un mot passe une autre
question ?
Ouais, c'est bon. Pourquoi la transition
vers l'agriculture biologique ou tout du
moins plus raisonnée est très peu
représenté alors que de nombreux jeunes
agriculteurs souhaite s'installer en bio
?
et ben le secrétaire général de jeunes
agriculteurs est en bio et il négocie
pour les agriculteurs bio et il essaie
de faire ça faire faire entendre
l'agriculture bio parce que voilà, elle
est moins bien représentée parce que à
un moment donné on a fait comme on fait
beaucoup avec cette société, on nous
demande de choisir entre le noir et le
blanc. Le bluot c'était le blanc pour
certains et l'autre le noir. Et c'est
pas une vision binaire des choses. Et
donc il y a peu de gens qui ont pu se
retrouver dans cette vision binaire des
choses et c'est déplorable.
Pourquoi soutenir le libéralisme et
l'industrialisation des fermes si on
peut soutenir une agriculture paysane ?
Parce qu'il faut tout. Parce qu'il faut
tout.
Oui, mais moi je
on a on a été c'est pour ça qu'on dit
qu'il faut tout revoir. C'est pour ça
qu'on veut tout mettre à plat parce
qu'en fait on a été formaté et on l'
toujours. Il faut nourrir le monde. Moi
j'ai enfin on peut revenir dans les
années 90 hein et même encore toujours
toujours. Mais à l'époque moi gamin,
j'allumé la télé des fois ah juste à 20h
le soir envoyé la frère Chazal.
Ouais voilà Chazal. et puis derrière à
nous montrer une famine supplémentaire
et encore et encore et des gamins qui
avaient mon âge à l'époque maigri comme
pas des horreur qu'aujourd'hui que j'ai
pas envie que mes enfants voient. Donc
moi j'ai été élevé en disant tu vas être
agriculteur, tu vas nourrir le monde, on
le nourrit, bam, on y va, allez, vas-y.
Tac tac tac. Et puis maintenant, on nous
dit "Oh les gars, non, c'est pas ça le
truc de le délire. On va faire du ultra
vert, quitte à moins produire. Tant que
nous on mange les français, ça va le
faire." Moi j'en ai qui disent ça, j'en
ai qui nous disent ça en face de nous.
On est là, on dit "Vous êtes sûr Oui,
mais il y a le monde. Non, mais parce
que vous croyez que c'est nous qui
allons sauver le monde. Regardez, il y a
tout qui va bien et tout. Plus personne
a faim et cetera. L'Afrique tiens mon
pote.
Oui, je pense qu'il y en a qui peuvent
aller faire des petits allers-retours.
Donc voilà, l'agriculture paysane sa
place. Il faut savoir l'emmener tout en
ayant quand même une grosse part de
production parce que on a quand même le
devoir de nourrir.
Pourquoi faire lutte commune avec la
FNSEA alors que l'avenir de
l'agriculture est ailleurs ?
parce qu'on n'est pas complètement
opposé sur certaines choses avec la
FNSEA et donc oui, on pousse sur
certains trucs et puis la FNSEA c'est
puissant, ça pousse ça ça pousse fort.
Et donc bah pour faire pousser quelques
idées, ben nous des fois on s'accroche
et on se suit un peu quoi, comme un
petit cycliste qui s'accroche à la ben
de tracteur pour pas pédaler à la
montée.
Ouais. Non mais il faut juste charger le
vélo dans le tracteur et boire une bière
avec les modération la bière. Mais non,
mais mais prendre la place en gros
prendre la place hein prendre la place
mais aujourd'hui c'est former nous
jeunes agriculteurs et peut-être demain
on sera les futurs représentants de la
FNSEA et en fait moi quand
qu'est-ce que tu visses
à
15000 balles par mois
déjà je sais pas s'il touche ça
il touche combien
euh alors là euh j'ai aucune idée sur
les salair je sais plus
de des indimités je sais pas du tout
mais pour l'instant non moi je vise
vraiment de de finir mon mes mandat
syndicat J c'est jusqu'à 37 ans.
38 excuse-moi. En plus on l'a fait 38
ans
38 ans arrivé à 38 ans on peut plus être
on peut toujours être adhérence syndicat
jeune agriculteur mais on peut plus être
élu représentant dedans. Donc après il y
a différents syndicats. La FNS
vieux agriculteurs
et ben après il y a FNSEA.
FNSEA si on veut suivre. Donc moi
éventuellement pourquoi pas. Mais en
fait là là où j'ai envie de dire
certains des fois agriculteurs qui
disent oui corrompu, oui ici, oui ça,
moi je leur dis bah tu as des super
idées, tu les prends, tu vas dans
n'importe quel syndicat que tu vas et tu
les pousses. Vas-y prends le leader. Mec
ils sont là ouais non confédération ça
m'intéresse pas. Ouais FA pourquoi pas ?
Mais c'est que des corrompus, ça fait 20
ans qu'ils sont là et les vieux et ça et
ça. Vas-y prends la place. Je suis sûr
qu'il y en a qui vont la laisser he
a eu des preuvr dans les syndicats
agricoles ? Non.
Des profs de corruption ? Pas de preuve
de corruption.
Pas de preuve de corruption.
On fera checker ça. Quelles sont les
évolutions positives récentes de la
Pâque ?
Pourquoi opposer écologie et agriculture
?
On l'oppose pas. Sur la Pâque, je vais
je vais être clair. Je vais tout donner
sur la PAC. Euh l'année dernière, il y a
un an, un an et demi, ouais. Sur la
dernière récolte, la récolte 22, j'ai dû
toucher 39000 € de pack. 39000 € de
pack. Aujourd'hui, on est sur une
nouvelle modalité PAC. 20 %
de du montant PAC est
ciblé sur des obligations
environnementales. On est peut-être un
des seuls corps de métier où on va nous
dire pour toucher ta Pâque, on va
revenir sur la base he j'aimerais bien
que ne pas la toucher la Pâque pour
pouvoir en vivre mais on me dit bah
voilà tiens tu as ta PAC qui va créer
une partie du revenu. Tu as 20 % de ton
revenu là c'est des obligations
environnementales. Je les ai respecté.
J'aurais dû avoir 39000 € encore cette
année.
J'ai perdu 4230
et quelques. Pourquoi ? parce qu'en fait
il y a trop d'agriculteurs qui ont
respecté cette norme environnementale et
puis à la fin l'Europe nous a dit "Ah
bah nous on avait mis un tel budget bah
on va pas pouvoir le réaliser pour tous
alors on va vous en donner un peu
moins." Ça ça a été encore un acte là
que ça et que tous là revendiquent
encore. Là on dit "Bah attendez les gars
déjà on est à suicier à suicier à fixer
et puis là moi j'ai perdu 4200 et
quelques là encore en plus cette année
qu'on nous a retiré de la PAC parce
qu'on n pas été capable de me payer mes
critères environnementals que j'ai
respecté. Donc nous on l'oppose pas, on
l'oppose pas la Pâque. Pour moi, la PAC,
elle va pouvoir accompagner. Mais on
revient toujours sur ce revenu et sur
l'accompagnement et sur l'explication.
En fait, on est sur de l'écologie
punitive actuellement. On punit et on
lui dit "Tu fais ça" et derrière tu
auras un petit carotte éventuellement.
C'est pas ça l'écologie. Il faut
accompagner, il faut faire une
transition.
Le chiffre d'affaires de ton
exploitation, c'est combien ?
Euh chiffre d'affaires sur
2022 320000 €.
Et toi ? Chiffre d'affaires 2020.
Bah ouais 380 et quelques. Je l' plus
exactement. Peut-être 380000 €.
Question internet. Quelle est la
différence entre la paysanerie et
l'agriculture ? C'est la même chose.
C'est la même.
C'est la même chose. Les deux
travaillent euh le vivant euh exploite
ou pas le sol mais peu importe en fait,
c'est de la sémantique pour moi.
Pensez-vous que l'agriculture bio
pourrait nourrir toute la France ?
Non.
Non mais non. Ben parce que ce que je
disais Quentin, il fait je sais plus
combien disait 85 quau 60 quau de
moyenne en blé la référence machin. Moi
j'en fais 30
en bio et entre bah il y en a qui vont
avoir le ventre qui gargouille.
Alors le blé le blé c'est une chose
maintenant il y a plein d'autres
cultures en fait.
Oui mais globalement le le blé
aujourd'hui je crois qu'on est en
surproduction en France ça va. Oui on
pourrait aller en bio sur le blé quelque
chose près. Oui ça va. On va peut-être
respecter les critères français mais on
oublie l'importation. On oublie
l'exportation, je veux dire hein. Donc
ce que je disais tout à l'heure sur les
crises famin ou quoi que ce soit, on
oublie ça. OK, on se nourrit que nous
entre nous, pas de problème. Mais après,
il y a tout le reste aussi à côté. Il y
a toutes les autres cultures. Et en
fait, quand on met tout bout à bout,
bah nous on des chiffres sur le bio, ça
ça laisse quand même perplexe à
réfléchir quoi.
Est-ce est-ce que sortir de l'Europe est
une solution ?
Sûrement pas. Sûrement pas.
Êtes-vous heureux de pouvoir utiliser
plus de pesticides librement ?
Du tout, du tout. Je me lève pas le
matin. Euh en terme de phyo, j'ai dû
lâcher un une ardoise de quasiment 70000
€ de phy avec les hausses de phy là pour
l'année pour l'année là. J'aurais
préféré m'en passer hein ou en lâcher
peut-être deux fois moins. Je me lève
pas le matin en me disant qu'est-ce que
je vais faire et si j'allais en épendre
un petit peu ? Non non non. Déjà je
prends ma voiture la veille ou
l'avantille. Je vais faire le tour de
mes parcelles. Ah tiens, il y a de la
maladie qui se crée là. Ah ça m'embête
de sortir. Il y a pas suffisamment. Bon
ça va peut-être passer, ça va le faire.
Puis des fois on vient le lendemain. Oh
[__] c'est pas plus que ça. C'est
bon, un passe, j'en mets pas. Puis des
fois euh bah on va connaître un l'année
dernière, avril très frais et plus vieux
là ici he par chez nous là et la pluie
de la pluie, un peu de fraîcheur et puis
tu arrivé un peu les chaleurs avec des
cultures qui étaient assez humides de
base, une terre assez humide et là un
température humide, développement des
maladies. L'année dernière, j'ai dû
faire il y a 2 ans, j'ai fait un
fongicide. Donc fungicide, c'est pour
les maladies. Cette année, je dois en
faire deux. Voilà. Donc bah c'est deux
fois le prix. Ça m'intéressait pas
d'aller le faire. Ça m'intéressait pas.
Ça nous intéresse pas d'aller les
traiter. C'est juste que bah c'est ma
solution. Si je le fais pas, je sais que
je vais perdre 30 ou 40 % dessus.
Connaissez-vous d'autres alternatives
pour la culture de céréal ? Pardon la
culture de la de céréales que le
glyphosate ? Je recommence.
Connaissez-vous d'autres alternatives
pour la culture de céréales que le
glyphosate ? Alors le glyphosate, il est
utilisé avant de mettre la culture. En
France, on traite pas de glyphosate sur
la culture. Pourquoi ? Parce que le
glyphosate est non sélectif, détruit
tout en fait, hein. Il va il va il va
tuer les herbes, il va tuer le blé, il
va tuer les mauvaises herbes.
Euh donc aujourd'hui, il y a des
solutions. Oui. C'est-à-dire travaille
du sol
intensif, fort. On va travailler
plusieurs fois le sol pour vraiment
évacuer ces mauvaises herbes là. Donc
bah après travail du sol, bon bah on
connaît aussi c'est ces débord derrière
érosion au vent, à la pluie, la
sécheresse hein, un seul un seul nu au
15 août. Quand il fait 30° dehors, vous
mettez votre pipette, vous prenez la
température, vous allez avoir 2 3°gr de
plus, un sol qui est couvert, bien
couvert, tout vert et cetera, vous allez
le mettre, va y avoir 2 3 degrés de
moins. Donc bah voilà, faut pas lier
aussi ça au réchauffement climatique.
Pour moi, ça fait part pour moi, le
glyphosate aujourd'hui est une part est
un produit qui permet l'accompagnement
face au changement climatique dans
certains coins.
Alors là, c'est un commentaire. Euh
d'ailleurs, c'est pas la la section
commentaire, donc il va se faire taper
sur les doigts, mais je vais quand même
le lire.
Le monsieur s'appelle Julien Métayer.
Incroyable. Ils ne sont pas politiques
avec 1 2 3 4 points d'interrogation.
S'il vous plaît, inviter de vrais
paysans, ils sont insupportables.
Donc vous êtes pas politique, vous êtes
politique. Je suis pas politique. En
tout cas, je me considère pas comme tel.
Question : Qui a détruit le bâtiment de
la Fédération de la pêche à la Rochelle
? On n pas suivi cette histoire.
Non.
Euh, question de Clément. Pourquoi on
entend la FNSE J réclamé toujours à la
baisse baisse des normes pour toujours
plus de compétitivité plutôt qu'exiger
des mécanismes de garantie de revenu
pour interrogation ? Pourquoi ne
parle-t-il jamais de l'euro alimentaire
? Sur 100 € dépensés en alimentation en
France, 6,4 € reviennent aux
agriculteurs françaises en 2017 alors
que la moyenne 9527 était de 9,9 €.
Source Philippe Boyer, source Rostat INC
calcul Inra, ça vous parle
en partie ? Oui oui oui. Pour la
question si on fait la synthèse c'est
c'est plus ou moins de dire pourquoi on
se bat pas pour le prix plutôt que que
pour les normes en fait.
C'est là qu'on communique mal en fait
parce qu'on on demande les deux et on a
même réussi à créer un outil qui nous
permet de ramener de la valeur qui
s'appelle égalime et et c'est des
contrats où on sécurise le prix et
dedans où on construit un prix minimum
qui est sur les coûts de production.
Donc enfin ça y est, on on y est. C'est
voilà. Deuxème partie du commentaire qui
a à la fois une un commentaire et une
question euh toujours de Clément 2. Lien
FNSEA Jr. Les JA ne sont-ils pas la
chambre de recrutement pour la FNSEA
permettant de repérer les profils
compatibles entre parenthèses par
exemple pas trop remuant contre la main
mise de l'agroalimentaire sur la
politique de la maison. Fermez la
parenthèse pour interrogation.
Ça l'a été. Ça allit encore pour
quelques pour quelques personnalités. Il
y a des gens qui après leur parcours J
vont à la FNSA. C'est pas la règle,
c'est pas la règle absolue, c'est pas
comme ça que c'est défini. Et voilà, il
y a aussi beaucoup de jeunes
agriculteurs qui ont fini leur processus
chez jeunes agriculteurs, qui sont
partis dans les milieux économiques,
coopération, peu importe.
Question internet. Les préfectures
vandalisées qui portaient les drapeaux
de la FNSEA JA. Vous avez vous avez
matraqué les préfectures.
Il y a eu de il y a eu des tas de déposé
devant. Oui, che certains certains
préfets où il y a eu des demandes de
rendez-vous qui ont été faits à à
demander et puis soit ils ont pas
respecté ou soit ils ont pas répondu au
aux attentes. Bon bah derrière mais en
fait un un tas de fumiers avec j'ai
envie de dire bon ça va hein, ils ont
été assez tenables parce que parce que
dégrader ou ou mettre à feu ou à sang
une préfecture ou à un bien public ça
reste toujours nous qui payons derrière.
C'est déplorable de voir ça. On dénonce
tous les actes de vandalisme et et en
fait malheureusement ça montre quand
même bah une colère euh et puis un
mal-être agricole.
Là c'est un commentaire. La loi égalim
est justement contournée par la grande
distribution grâce à l'Europe. Point
d'interrogation. Oui. Non. Est-ce que
elle est en partie contournée parce
qu'ils peuvent aller négocier en fait
les contrats égalimes à l'étranger et
c'est pour ça qu'on a entendu parler
d'une égalme européenne et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut surtout pas sortir de
l'Europe et que voilà, on revient sur
les sujets européens mais en fait oui
elle peut être contournée et c'est ça
qu'on dénonce parce que c'est des petits
malins.
Il y a il y a beaucoup de questions. Ils
sont fâchés que vous soyez copains avec
la FNSE ou là.
Sûrement. Bah oui, la FN
pourquoi ça pourquoi ça vous ça
parce que dans dans dans j'ai
l'impression que on aime bien les totems
en France. La FNSEA et le totem de
l'agriculture parce que ils ont défendu
et ils défendent un modèle qu'on
qualifie de productiviste et comme on a
un peu du mal avec ça au même titre
qu'on a un problème avec les lobbyistes
en France. Pourtant, Dieu sait s'il y en
a sur le territoire, sur toutes les
corporations, mais on a un problème avec
ça. Et donc tout ce qui serait tout ce
qui toucherait de près ou de loin la
FNSA serait considéré comme Satan. Ils
font pas que des mauvaises choses pour
l'agriculture la FNSA. Et je voilà, moi
je Ils ont aussi il y a bien des combats
qu'ils ont menés qui ont permis de
garantir ce qui est le pays aussi en
terme de souveraineté alimentaire. Et
voilà, ils ont fait des conneries. Je
Il y a d'autres syndicats qui étaient
représentés lors des manifes ? Oui, on a
vu la coordination rurale, les bonnet
jaunes, euh la confédération paysane
aussi était mobilisée, le modef qui est
un plus petit syndicat aussi. Euh voilà,
tous les syndicats pour le coup étaient
mobilisés. Oh, il y a beaucoup de
questions, hein. Oh là, je suis en train
Faites un peu la conversation entre
vous, je choisis mes questions.
Non, bah pas de problème.
Euh,
c'est bien si ça réagit.
Ouais, ça régagit fort.
Alors oui, elle a Non, on s'en fout ça.
Connaissez-vous Connaissent-ils le
couple Bourguignon ? Si oui, que
pensent-il de leur travail et de leur
discours ? Alors, faudra pas que la
communauté de de Finkerview meubl mais
j'ai vu qu'ils étaient venus Claude et
Lydia Bourguignon sur sur Finkerview,
j'ai j'ai pas encore regardé. Donc
voilà. Mais oui, moi j'ai j'ai les
ouvrages de de de Claude et Lilia
Bourgon à la maison évidemment. Et moi,
j'ai regardé pas mal de leurs vidéos,
j'ai suivi pas mal de leurs chantiers
étant donné que eux, ils sont quand même
sur un côté euh à dire euh il faut euh
fortement limiter le travail du sol, il
faut un sol couvert, sans chimie, euh
donc un système permaculture, hein,
clairement où il faut un sol efficace,
euh sans pollution, sans rien. C'est un
petit peu dans ce sens-là que j'ai
essayé de m'orienter avec l'agriculture
conservation. Un sol couvert sans
travail du sol, j'essaie de limiter
l'utilisation de ma chimie. Moi, j'ai
fait des réductions chimie, hein. Euh,
je me suis j'ai réussi des années à me
passer zéro insecticides, de réduire par
deux ou par trois mes utilisations de de
fongicide, insecticide pour les
insectes, fongicides pour les maladies.
Reste le volet herbicide qui est des
fois assez compliqué parce qu'en fait
très concurrentiel, on va prendre
mauvais enfin mauvaise herbe. Voilà, par
exemple, les bourguignons vous pas vous
parler de mauvaise herbes mais une
plante qui n'a rien à faire là mais
c'est pas grave, il faut il faut
construire autour d'elle. C'est ce que
tu as dit aux gendarmes.
Ouais.
Et sur et sur ces mauvaises herbes euh
ultra concurrentiel pour ma culture sur
du blé, de l'orge, du colza, peu
importe, ça va être et et là en fait ça
impacte fortement les rendements et
étant donné qu'on a des charges très
fortes devant et qu'on sait qu'on est
limité sur le prix de revenu, et ben on
a toujours cette carotte d'utilisation.
Donc mais oui oui, je connais. Que
pensez-vous des tracteurs autonomes de
John Deere avec la avec l'IA et les
satellites ? Avons-nous encore besoin
d'agriculture et les petits robots qui
ramassent les pommes et ainsi de suite ?
Là,
il y a de belles choses, hein. Il y a de
belles choses. Moi, je j'ai un j'ai un
exploitant juste à côté de chez moi qui
fait des betteraves en bio
euh betterav en bio et il s'est acheté
un petit robot autonome euh qui
travaille 7 jours sur 7, 24/ 24 et euh
et qui vient tournicoter autour des
betterrafes tout en avançant. pour
désherber les betteraves. C'est c'est
fabuleux. Euh il a payé 150000 € pour
1,50 de robot. Euh c'est de
l'horlogerie. Donc 1,50 ilutilise pour
15 20 hactares. 20 hactares de
betterave. Il est vendu pour 20 hactar
de betterave max. Euh pour l'instant
c'est sa première année. Il voit les
premières pièces d'usure arriver, il me
dit ou voilà, ça va sûrement coûter. Euh
il y a eu des il a dû avoir je pense des
des des accompagnements de subvention et
autres. Donc il y a des belles choses
qui se font. Après oui bah
l'agriculture, je crois qu'elle a le
droit aussi d'avancer dans son temps.
Aujourd'hui, on utilise un petit peu
partout pour tout et pour rien.
Je pense que l'agriculture, si elle a
des possibilités technologiques de
l'utilisation, au contraire qu'elle
l'utilise. Après, attention, on a
toujours cette notion d'homme, de main
d'œuvre, d'emploi et puis bah voilà,
quelle agriculture on veut aussi. Mais
ça peut être aussi une vision de main de
euh de notre gouvernement ou de voilà de
nous dire les gars de toute façon nous
on veut de l'agriculture 100 %
digitalisé 100 % euh informatisé et euh
et et robotique. Donc euh allez comme
ça, on oublie la main d'œuvre de toute
façon agriculture euh mais c'est pareil
aujourd'hui on jongle un petit peu sur
tout donc voilà.
Vous avez suivi un peu que quand les
agriculteurs se faisaient taper leur GPS
pour que ça parte dans les pays de l'Est
là.
Oui,
ça gueule fort ça non ?
Ouais, c'est pas très cool. Ouais, c'est
pas très fun comme truc. Ouais, c'est
surtout que en plus, je vais prendre la
marque, vous l'avez cité avec les robots
les jeunes dire euh il y a il y a ami
voleur, il y a un traceur dedans.
Ils doivent aussi comprendre comment des
tracer.
Oui. Oui. Bah oui, on les voit une fois
qu'ils arrivent en Ukraine, ils
s'éteignent.
Ah, c'est en Ukraine ?
Ouais. Ouais. On en a vu traverser, on
en a suivi parce que moi j'en ai, j'en
ai eu des voisins à côté qui se sont
fait voler et on a une application, je
viens de dire, où on peut suivre le
tracteur euh depuis son application,
savoir où est-ce qu'il est. Et en fait
quand le GPS disparaît, on voit le GPS
qui Ah ! Oh oh oh oh oh pouf ! Il
s'arrête à un endroit, il a disparu.
Signal perdu à la frontière.
Impressionnant.
Magnifique.
Que pensent-t-il de la de l'étude
prospective 2050 de LINRA ?
Laquelle ? Ah ouais, il y a pas d'
parce que LINRA fait plein d'études
prospectives et euh bon, c'est vrai
qu'ils en ont plusieurs. Je sais pas si
la question c'est sur le les produits
euh les produits phytosanitaires. Enfin
voilà, je
Attends, faut que j'apprétale. Euh
voilà.
INRA INRA 2050, je crois que ça parle
euh
du zéro phy
Je crois que ça parle euh
je crois que c'est très axé là-dessus
sur le Zé Phito 2050. Je peux pas dire
de bêtises. Euh je l'ai plus comme ça en
tête. Maintenant
tout tout ça, moi
j'ai envie d'y croire. Moi ça me dérange
pas. C'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure. Moi je veux bien taper dans la
main de n'importe qui si on nous
garantit une agriculture propre sans
sans phy avec un nouveau modèle
totalement voilà et tout. Mais oui,
c'est encore croire au bisounours et
oui, c'est voilà mais faut tout poser
faut tout poser, faut discuter et c'est
ce qu'on narrête pas de dire. Faut
arrêter de nous dire là à nos
générations là tout de suite ou là là
dans les deux prochaines dans les
prochains mois ou dans les prochaines
années qu'on doit réparer les conneries
qui ont été faites depuis 30 ou 40 ans.
Ta source sur les 20000 hectares en
superficie des exploitations en Ukraine,
c'était quoi ?
Ah c'était moi. C'était Julien de
Normandie cette semaine sur un plateau
télé.
D'accord. C'est qui Julien de Normandie
?
Un ancien ministre fort brillant de
l'agriculture française.
D'accord.
Euh
si le mec qui pose des questions, il a
pas l'air très rigolo. Bon, est-ce que
vous voyez est-ce que est-ce que vous
voyez des des Il y a tellement de
questions, est-ce qu'il y a des sujets
qu'on a pas abordé que vous voulez
aborder avec nous ?
Ouais, on en a pas mal brossé hein. Moi
de moi je trouve partout en fait là.
Ouais, il y a il y a plein de
commentaires qui arrivent et autres.Ah
là, il y en a. Moi, j'invite vraiment
tout le monde, tous ceux qui regardent,
tous ceux qui écoutent, tous ceux qui
veulent apprendre avec de l'agriculture,
faut aller discuter. On est là sur nos
fermes, on n'est pas enfermé hein à se
cacher derrière ou quoi que ce soit.
Vous voyez quelqu'un qui traite ou quoi
que ce soit, faut arrêter de chercher
les insultes ou la bagarre ou quoi que
ce soit parce qu'on en a ? Moi, j'en ai,
j'ai j'ai rigolé à l'automne, j'ai sorti
le pulvérateur pour le nettoyer. J'ai eu
le droit à un bras d'honneur et un va te
faire voilà,
il y avait rien, il était vide. C'est
juste que je l'ai sorti. Et en fait
cette personne-là, j'aurais préféré
qu'il s'arrête et qu'on discute sans
forcément aller spout sur la gueule,
mais qu'on discute qu'est-ce qui me
reprochait, qu'est-ce que moi je peux
lui reprocher et et que je lui explique
un petit peu quel est le modèle
agricole, comment fonctionne
l'agriculture. Aujourd'hui, on voit
l'agriculture comme elle est formatée
sur les médias ou comment elle est
formatée dans nos livres, comme on a
envie de la présenter. Le meilleur moyen
aujourd'hui pour connaître
l'agriculture, c'est l'échange. C'est la
discussion avec l'agriculteur même.
Alors là, ça tombe bien parce qu'il y a
une question qui va dans ce sens-là. Ces
messieurs accepteraient-ils une seconde
interview en présence de leur
contradicteur ? Au hasard, une figure
des soulèvements de la terre aurait sans
doute une argumentaire
constructif, pardon, à apporter à la
discussion. Il n'y a souvent que du vide
en face comme vous avez noté.
Euh
non, il n'y a bien plus que de
l'indignation stérile. Vous acceptez les
soulèvements de la terre en direct live
? S'il y en a un qui mouffe, c'est moi
qui tape tout le monde.
Vendu.
Vendu. Même à deux, vous faites pas le
poids contre moi.
On est d'accord.
Et eh
le compté il est au fort des rousses
dans le jur. Bon, il y a tellement de
trucs. Je voudrais Non mais a Non mais
question
Jurad,
je suis désolé, on posera plein d'autres
questions. Je voudrais avoir trois
bouquins chacun à conseiller à notre
communauté. Donc
qui choisit de commencer ? Et après les
trois bouquins, préparer un conseil pour
les jeunes générations.
Faut que ce soit des bouquins en lien
avec l'agriculture.
Non, non. Des bouquins qui ont été très
intéressants, qui vous ont aidé à être
à vous former, à vous éveiller l'esprit.
Alors là, bon ben moi pour le coup, ça
va, on va changer totalement de de de
style maisag.
Ah ben non, on retourne en Bretagne et
euh on fait euh Bernard Moessier, donc
le grand voyage. Euh on fait euh
qu'est-ce que Jour Barbare de C'est un
livre sur de Ah, j'ai perdu l'auteur, ça
parle de surf. Euh voilà donc culture
marine à fond et puis bah tous les
ouvrages d'Éric Tabarli sur comment
construire Pendwick et puis on est bien
quoi.
La la fille de Tabarli qui est en XP là,
elle est extraordinaire.
Si on peut faire une interview avec
Marie à Fingerview Marie Tarly. Ah bah
si on peut ça ser
je peux t'organiser ça
volontiers. il est beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus littéraire que moi. Moi,
j'ai été les seuls bouquins que je lis
et j'en ai encore deux trois, c'est
uniquement sur l'agriculture.
Euh
qu'est-ce que je peux aller ?
Bon, pendant que tu réfléchis, je fais
un commentaire. Il
a il y a le le le tout tout dernier tout
dernier justement avec [__] j'ai
mâché son mot avec Julien de Normandie
et
et Éric
sur euh le blé. Attends, [__] il faut
que je retrouve le titre. Euh là, ils
viennent de le présenter là. Ça, voilà,
ce livre-là euh je j'ai réussi à le
récupérer. Ça c'est le truc qui est
posé. Euh je pense que ça ça va être le
futur livre à lire. Ouais, moi je suis
très en fait ma plus grande des
littératures, c'est euh la compréhension
du sol. C'est la technique. Moi je
nourrir sans dévasté.
Nourir sans dévasté. Merci.
C'était Eric Orsena.
Éric Orsena et je viens de Normandie.
Exactement. Et euh donc ça c'est euh
c'est le petit livre de chevet là qui
vient d'arriver. Euh et puis sinon après
énormément oui plutôt d'écriture euh sur
euh compréhension du sol, la vie du sol,
sur l'agriculture. Moi je suis vraiment
plus axé sur le côté technique que sur
les littératures. Et puis après, sinon
euh tous les bons livres, je suis désolé
pour ceux qui vont me taper dessus mais
je les regarde à la télé dès que ça peut
sortir.
Avant que tu me donnes ton conseil pour
les les jeunes générations, un
commentaire, tu vas y répondre. Ni de
gauche ni de gauche. Le mec il porte un
col roulé quand même. Mais
j'arrive du sud et à Paris il fait froid
donc je m'habille c'est tout.
Est-ce que tu as un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? Une bouteille à la
mer, quelque chose d'impérissable ?
Lâchez rien, vos idées iront jusqu'au
bout. Et voilà, lâchez rien, on lâchera
rien et les idées iront jusqu'au bout.
C'est ça. Faut aux jeunes, vous avez
plein d'idées, vous avez des très bonnes
idées. Il faut venir, il faut j'y a ou
pas j'y a peu importe en fait, faut les
pousser, faut les amener et et je suis
sûr que de toute façon les générations
de demain vont réussir ce métier
agricole, vont réussir aujourd'hui notre
monde et il faut leur donner confiance.
Et et nous malheureusement là avant on a
on a brassé beaucoup on a brassé
beaucoup de noir mais je suis sûr et
certain qu'il y a encore énormément de
choses à faire sur ce beau pays.
Pierry Corel, Quentin le Guillou. Merci
bien.
Merci merci.
[Musique]